Oh, hello, everyone.
Hello, hello.
I'm so sorry, guys.
Oh, I always hate starting late.
It was so, it was also like out of my, like, what's the
word?
It was like out of my, um, like, hands, too, because it was
like, I don't know what the fuck happened.
So, basically, uh, I left my PC on overnight, but I have
been leaving it on overnight the last, uh, out of my
control.
Yeah, out of my control.
Um, so I think I left it over.
overnight like three times this week which is apparently not
that good and I left it over time like overnight for like
one day or something yes we're close to 900k oh I do have
something planned for 900k I don't know if I can get it out
right away but um I'm super excited because uh I do have
like something that I've been planning for a bit for 900k
subscribers and it's like a good it's a good Christmas
present too you know it's like hitting 900k would be a nice
present to myself.
It's a gift to myself.
Or I guess it's like, you know, as we all work together,
it's our, it's our gift to ourselves.
It's a nice celebration.
Um, so basically, uh, um, I set everything up, you know,
because obviously, um, Scooby-Doo Night of a Hundred Frights
isn't a, they never remastered Scooby-Doo Night of a Hundred
Frights.
So, um, people would be like, how did she get, how did she,
uh, get, um, get it to work?
Like, like, how, how was she able to play this game does she
have a playstation 2 right now did she so so i um set
everything up to beforehand but then i was like i did leave
it overnight i should restart my pc just in case um um
anyway so i restarted my pc and then nothing was turning on
like my pc was on Um, but my monitors wasn't on, uh, my
stream deck wasn't on, my keyboard wasn't on, so I got
really confused, because I know it wasn't a monitor issue,
because my stream deck and my keyboard weren't turning on it
as well, because they weren't, like, receiving any signal.
Um, and, uh, and then so I was just like, what the fuck is,
what, what the fuck is happening?
So then I, um, so then I, so I rebooted it again, And I was
like, you know, an SOS emergency call with like the PC
people too.
And I was like, what the?
I'm like, help.
I, please, I need, I need this for work.
Please help me.
Yeah, I hope it's never a RAM issue with what's going on
right now in the world.
Like I'm not paying a thousand dollars for RAM.
Thank God I bought RAM before this happened.
Anyway, so I got really worried because I was like, what if
my GP you fried or something because like you know um i have
a 50 80 i think it's either 50 80 or 50 90.
i have lost track like honestly i've lost track there's so
many numbers i don't fucking remember anymore um and so i
was freaking out because i literally got it like a couple of
months ago so thankfully my gpo didn't fry then i'm like
wondering oh no is it a motherboard because i always have
motherboard issues for some fucking reason i don't know why
i think i remember frying my motherboard last time so i'm
like um oh what if my motherboard fried um so i was
panicking and then after 10 minutes of panicking my pc just
turns on it fixed itself i guess so um so i was looking at
the motherboard and apparently so there's a light on the
motherboard um and the person on call was like, what does
the light say?
And I was like, it's orange.
And they're like, oh, that's not good.
And I'm like, why?
I was like, what do you mean it's not good?
Because they're like, oh, if the motherboard is showing an
orange light, it means that it might be an issue with either
RAM, CPU, or GPU.
Like orange is bad.
And I'm like, that's no good.
And then I was like, And while the guy was explaining me why
orange is not good, I was like, it's green now.
And then my PC turned on.
I was like, all right, fix it.
I was like, I was like, all right, it's all fixed now.
Yay.
I don't know how.
I don't know what happened, but it turned green light and
it's so over.
we're so back it's so over we're so freaking back uh i have
no use for you anymore um so it took like i think like 10 12
minutes for it to boot up i think and then like they said
that oh it's because you left it overnight too many times so
like they need like time to i don't know dump out i don't
fucking know i don't know pc stuff i actually was so tempted
to do a pc builder stream um this week Like with the PC
building simulator, but I know I'm gonna rage bait so many
people, but it wouldn't be intentional, intentionally
because I have no idea what I'm doing.
Like, I just be like, is this where I put the RAM?
I'll be like, is this the CPU while I hold up the fucking
motherboard or some shit?
Yeah, the PC said, not today, Satan, not today.
anyway um anyway so that's basically what happened it just
fixed itself i was panicking for um i believe 30 minutes and
then it fixed itself i have no idea what the fuck happened i
just assumed that i just left it on overnight way too many
times last week i usually don't do that i've just been like
very tired lately the last couple last week because i would
be like i'm just gonna take a little nap nap and then i'll
come back and do work stuff and it never becomes a little
nappy nap and then I wake up and it's morning and I'm like
oh and I'm like oh well guess plants didn't work out and I
was true do it again I'll try again like three more times I
was like maybe this time it will work you know maybe this
time I can will my body to wake up and then every time for
some reason it wasn't working that's why he said it alive
well I thought with my sheer willpower I would wake up like
after a couple of hours, but apparently my body was like,
no.
It's like, what do you mean, Willpye?
You have none, girl.
Yeah, I never learned.
I keep trying.
I was like, if I keep doing it, if I keep gambling, maybe
this time I'll hit it big, guys.
Jakarta, thank you for the super chat.
Thank you.
Nah, I wouldn't she never.
She never wins, guys.
Roll-roll, Ragi, Dokey's PC decided to act up, even though
she was on time.
But thankfully, Dokey was able to solve the computer
mystery.
Now let's see who the culprit really is.
Old man Windows.
Thank you, with the Super Chat.
Thank you, thank you.
No, because I think it was Super Chat.
I restarted my PC like three times a year.
Don't feel obliged to restart if nothing is wrong.
Thank you, the Super Chat.
Thank you, thank you.
I restarted it because, like, it's just like my parents
instilled this fear in me.
where like they're like don't leave it on overnight too many
times and then i guess like i got too comfortable because i
did and now it reinforced the fear like because if you like
if you leave it on too many times it will break and then
that and then i guess i got way too comfortable i was like
what if they were lying like after years of after years of
that fear i was like i got way too and then it came back the
fear is back the one thing they didn't lie there was a lot
you know it's like they'll be like eat more fish it makes
you smarter i think that was a lie you know like those like
um those like wives tales that they tell you that they're
like if you do this it'll be like to like trick children
into thinking like um and thinking certain things so they'll
be like eat more fish it'll make you smarter i don't think
that worked
and um and then other things were uh oh they would tell me
like don't eat sashimi it's really it's raw fish it's not
good for you but it's just because they didn't want to buy
me sashimi because it's too expensive so i think that's like
i know it's like some asian parents do that to kids because
there was a youtube short about it and i was like my parents
did that too
like no sashimi is bad for you it's not good for kids um
it's raw fish and so i'll be like okay i'll get a california
road then i mean i do that too we all had the same parents i
don't remember what other lies they told me growing up just
so like um just so like you know they try to teach you like
um try it so they don't have to like tell you the reason why
they don't want to do something uh but i forgot some of the
lies they used to tell uh you know because it's parenting
like you have to make shit up it's it's parenting you have
to make shit up for the children to believe you uh my
parents never um i never believed santa was real even when i
was little because my parents never encouraged the whole
aspect of santa claus So, so, you know, whenever Christmas
comes a lot, they'll just be like, all right, like whenever
Christmas is getting closer, they'll be like, all right,
what do you want?
So, you know, Santa, that's how I realized, wait, Santa
isn't real.
It's my parents buy me Christmas gifts, because they'll just
be like, what do you want?
Or be like, here's some money.
five and they're gonna fuck you what for christmas so like
that's why there was no whimsy there and and also the fact
that we didn't have a chimney so i was like how the fuck is
santa coming down and give me christmas presents so you know
my christmas tree would be like the presents that i knew my
parents got me because they'll just be like all right um
here's the gift we bought you It wasn't even wrapped, too.
That's the part.
There's added no presents there because I already have the,
they already gave me the presents unwrapped because they'll
just be like, here, I'm just like, here you go.
Or like, there was no presents down there.
So I knew Santa wasn't real because I was like, oh, Santa
chose, I was like, Santa only didn't come to my house.
Like, so, you know, my parents didn't want to be like, yeah,
Santa, you were a very bad kid.
So Santa skipped your house.
They didn't say that.
They just straight up be like, we got you the presents.
we had a tree though.
We had a Christmas tree.
So we just, I just, they just didn't encourage that, me that
Santa was real or anything.
Oh, and also that's how I found out the tooth theory was a
lie too.
Cause like, you know, whenever you lose a tooth, you lose a
tooth, you put the tooth underneath the, yeah i don't even
get coal so i was just like clearly santa's fucking bullshit
like like they just skipped my house my house was just
wasn't on the map apparently um and so you know the teachers
would be like oh um you put a tooth under the pillow um
you'll get money so then obviously you know i didn't tell my
parents about it so then i i put uh i put my tooth under the
pillow and then the tooth fairy never came and then i was
like oh maybe i just need to put more teeth more teeth like
under the pillow and i told my parents about it i was like
why didn't the tooth fairy give me money that's what my
teachers told me and then they're like oh
they're just like oh do you want money we can we can give
you the money
They just, I don't know, I don't remember how much money
they gave me.
They're just like, here's money.
So that was like, oh, the dude, I was like, I knew it.
Dude, baby wasn't real either.
No, it's just, just business.
Yeah.
The teacher thought your family understood the assignment.
when I realized the two fairies wasn't real adding.
The fairies were like, here's the money for your teeth.
Osteen, thank you for the super chat.
Thank you, thank you.
The biggest lie my dad ever told me was that he was so hot.
Thank you for the super chat, Osteen, thank you, thank you.
Oh, you think you was super chat, thank you, thank you.
I didn't tell me if I swallowed gum.
It will be in my intestines for seven years in middle
school.
I knew she was lying because I swallowed every piece of gum.
I've ever had since I was born they give a super chat.
Thank you.
Oh my god And then they lied to me and told me the
convenience store guy was Jackie Chan So so so there was
okay, so we had a convenience store near us and I always go
there for ice cream And they'll be like that's Jackie Chan.
I'm like, oh my god, Jackie So I would always go over and be
like hello Jackie I don't remember that because I'll take
pictures of it like oh my god Jackie Chan is like near me
and that's so I know that I don't know why the fuck they did
that and then um and then like and then like I would like
hang out in the convenience store because in my head I was
like I'm hanging out with Jackie Chan and but he was of
course he wasn't Jackie Chad why the fuck would he be here
he's a fucking movie star but I didn't know that I was like
five so but he would he would encourage it too he's like
that I'm Jackie Chad like he would also be in on it so like
for like the like two to three years my life was a lie
because I thought Jackie Chad lived five minutes away from
me um do you know for sure no because then I remembered
because then And then I went back to the convenience store
when I was like older like when I was 10 or some shit No, I
think like oh, yeah, no, I came back Came back to Canada
like to be like visit some people and I was like I think I
was like 12 or 13 And I went back to the convenience store
and then I thank God your part check.
I'm full Chinese But for some reason I couldn't tell it
wasn't Jackie Chan.
Yeah, but thank you for the super chat.
Thank you.
Thank you So I would like, I like went back to visit the
convenience store and I looked at his face and I was like,
there is no resemblance to Jackie Chan.
I have no idea how the fuck that lie went.
Like, how the fuck that lie lasted that long for me.
And it was around the time when Jackie Chan Adventures was
like playing on repeat, like reruns were always on, like on
YTV.
all the fucking time so obviously I was obsessed with Jackie
Chan uh because the reruns um the reruns were always on so I
love Jackie Chan a lot so then I was like oh my god I can't
believe Jackie Chan lived five minutes away from me at the
convenience store for some reason I thought like he just
lives there too um for some fucking reason I just thought he
lived at the convenience story as well uh why would jackie
chad work i don't i was five i was just so excited to meet
jackie chad i don't know why the fuck my parents lied about
that and the fact that he played i guess they're like
they're like you know he doesn't like because they're like
jackie chad's a little too real we gotta let her believe in
that uh because i'm like why the fuck were they willing to
like like give the young santa and a tooth fairy but then
lied for like three to four years about jackie chan working
at the convenience store like i have no idea why that was
the lie that they were willing to tell me uh mate thank you
for the super chat thank you thank you doesn't believe in
santa but believe he's a gas station jackie chad it's okay i
used to think that rudo was really too thank you the super
chat thank you thank you paturisu thank you the super chat
thank you thank you okay i'm afraid you can be a bit
gullible sometimes but don't worry jargoons will never lead
you astray probably paturisu thank you for the super chat
thank you thank you oh my god but yeah those were some of
the things that my parents um used it's like you know what
it's understandable it's all that's like it's parenting you
know like you have to i don't understand why they had to lie
about the jackie chan thing but like some parents uh some
parents have to lie to their kids uh so they can make so
they can make parenting a lot easier uh mafumo thank you for
the super chat thank you thank you um now i'm just imagining
the family guy oh my god it's jackie chancy but it's dokey
they give us a super chat thank you Yeah, that was my
whimsy.
They didn't let me, they didn't try to let me believe in
Santa or Toothberry, but they definitely made me believe
that Jackie Chan was five minutes, lived five minutes away
from me.
Yeah, he was my Santa.
It's basic parenting.
You have to make your children believe in the grocery store,
Jackie Chan.
Anyway, it's Scooby-Doo.
night of a hundred frights so about this game i've always
wanted to play like replay this game for a very long time
because this is one of my childhood games i'd never be in it
because i never know i like didn't didn't really know how to
read instructions or uh or like follow instructions in
general so i was stuck on this game for the longest fucking
time i kept replaying i remember like same with the piglet
game i kept replaying it over and over again but i was
always stuck on the first or second level because I didn't
know how to progress.
I told the story before, but it's very similar to Pokemon
Crystal.
I think it was Pokemon Crystal where there was a part where
you're blocked on the forest area because you're supposed to
talk to like the people in the caves about like the slow
poke shit where they cut off the tails and stuff.
So it was very similar to that where I never got past that
forest level because they blocked the forest level because
you have to progress through a side quest.
with the slowpoke tunnels but I didn't know how to read so I
I would I was like stuck there for like weeks like I would
replay that area and I was always stuck there for weeks
because I didn't really understand how to read at that time
um I knew how to read but I didn't process information I
just go like skip a skip a And so it only took like a couple
years later Where I replayed it And I actually started
processing information With what I was reading You know like
when you're reading it goes from one year to the other That
was me And that's still sometimes me too So yeah nothing has
actually really changed So but a couple years later I was
like I'm gonna see if I can actually progress this town And
I finally realized what the fuck They wanted me to do Oh
yeah, because I didn't know how to learn cut.
I remember now.
I was stuck on that level because there was a tree and I
didn't fucking know where to get cut.
I didn't realize that I had to, like, give the HM move to my
Pokemans.
So it's, like, all coming back to me.
It's because I didn't fucking realize that I had to teach a
move to my Pokemans.
So there was a fucking tree in front of me.
me and i was like how the do i get past the goddamn tree and
i kept running around everywhere being like is there another
way and i realized like oh my god like i didn't realize hm
or like was a tm moose or a fucking thing i was like how the
fuck do i get past this shit um um go ahead and say give a
super chat thank you thank you yo dokey you're playing this
game it was fun to me can't See how you do it.
P.S.
Santa was real.
The key word is was thank you for the super chat.
Thank you.
Yeah, I was stuck on there for fucking months, guys, because
I didn't understand.
I didn't understand because, like, Pokemon, Crystal and Gold
was my very first Pokemon's game.
So, I mean, yeah, so it was, like, my very first Pokemon's
game, like, the very first English Pokemon's game I could
play because my grandma would always give me.
me bootleg like always get me like those bootleg poke not
pokemon but those bootleg cartridges where it was like 15 it
was like you know like like a like a bunch of games in one
cartage and then there was there was like uh there was like
i remember there was like pokemon crystal in there but they
don't save that's the thing they the games the games don't
save so when you play it It would just you can only play it
once Like you can only play it once fully You can't turn off
your like you you can't turn it off or you lose everything
It wipes everything because there's no save file So I had my
grandma got me that and it had like I think it had like the
original like the yellow Pokemon yellow and like Crystal and
everything and then that's where I was introduced to Pokemon
And I remembered while I tried playing those Pokemon yellow
and Pokemon crystal in those carnages I I would always like
to stop at a certain area and have to replay all the way to
that area And it was just me trying to speedrun myself being
like if I play this a little faster Maybe I get to see what
happens next like but then also the entire text was a
Japanese So so I was like I don't understand what's going on
like me trying to figure out okay if i press this button it
will go it would let me progress and i have to always
remember that so everything was in japanese and i'm like but
i don't know i can't obviously i i could barely read in
english let alone read a entirely new language
so so it was a it was a fucking ride i remember that from
from little dokey
There's a cute Pikachu right there.
Anyway, it's going to be a night of 100 frights.
Looking forward to playing it.
I don't know.
I don't know that...
I don't remember exactly the story or the gameplay.
It is a platformer because games back then were all mostly
platformers.
But it was a very fun platformer.
And I'm going to beat this game for Lil Doki because she
never could.
because she was always very confused.
I was stuck in a lot of games.
Little Doki was stuck in a lot of games, including this one.
I'm playing the PlayStation 2 game, so the one that I grew
up with.
I'm doing it for young Doki.
I'll beat it for her.
There was a lot of games that I was stuck on, including
this.
Did the Little Doki ever watch the anime Scoot do we do
movies from the 90s and 2000s thank you the super chat
coyote thank you thank you i don't remember like which
movies i watched i watched i had like i remember i had one
vhs tape of the one with the the car racing because that one
was the most memorable one for me the older ones um i did
watch the one the lightning guy where are you trying to work
to do now all right i don't know Um, still around.
Does someone get out of here?
Come on, Scooby-Doo.
I see you.
Yeah, the Cyber Virus movies.
I love the Cyber Virus movies.
They're so good.
Fact.
Scooby, Snack.
I like how they recreated it in 3D like the classic
animation zoinks dookie yeah I like that I like that they
recreated it a new game I think the cyber chase was my
favorite because it would always replay every it would
always replay it on tv oh my god wow guys i can't play the
playstation 2 graphics look so hd yeah guys this is what we
see in our minds look this is what we see in our memories
whoa truly ahead of its time no silly We're here to solve a
mystery.
A mystery?
Eh.
Oh, babe.
Let me know if it's better.
Oh my god, we have a live studio audience, too!
That's us!
To be honest, better than I thought for PS...
Okay, I'll tell you the reason why.
Oh, wait, I can't do it.
I can't adjust it.
Don't worry, I fixed the graphics.
It was not this HD before.
No, no, it, no, guys, the OG, no.
I fixed the graphics.
To make it look like how it looked like in our heads when we
were kids.
He was just about to unveil some new top secret invention
when he disappeared without a trace.
Oh my god, who kidnapped him?
Let's ask this teenagers instead of calling the cops.
Don't tell me Because it's haunted, right?
Yeah, Shaggy.
How'd you know?
I upped it up a bit.
Yeah, I overclocked the PS2, guys.
Geekers?
Don't worry, Holly.
We'll help you look around.
You said it, Daphne.
We're not afraid.
Right, gang?
Let's get a bunch of teenagers.
I just saw the disappearance of a high-ranking scientist.
You guys can go poking around scaring up some spooksters.
We're staying right here in the old mystery machine.
Only ghost-free environments for us.
Rip, roast weed.
Yeah.
Okay, you scaredy cats.
Stay here if you want.
Come on, guys.
See you later.
Yay, ghost-free.
You know, Scoob, I could really go for a...
Ruby snack.
A Ruby snack!
Yeah, it's the original.
Fred is all...
Fred's voice actor is still alive, too, and still doing Fred
voices.
I think that's crazy.
Everyone else retired, but Fred.
And he still sounds like him, too.
Gee, Scoob, it's not like they got your name all over him.
Well, actually, they do.
Scooby-Doo!
Who did Nintendo
down there?
But, um, but, uh, no, he got baited by the Scooby Snack.
It's the perfect bait.
Okay, press O to enter.
Okay, but I don't know how to play this game.
I forgot the controllers.
It's been so long.
Okay.
There's a warp game.
What the fuck is a warp game?
Are there no instructions?
I don't have double jump yet.
Oh, guys, I can save.
Let's save real quick.
I forgot.
Like, these old games, it's like there's no auto save back
then.
I need 25 scooby snacks.
Yeah, there's no auto save back then.
You have to physically find shit.
You need a key to reach without the spring invention.
Okay, I got a spring invention here.
Alright, let's grab some more Scooby Snacks to unlock shit.
Alright, we got it.
Yeah, you need a game manuals.
Because, like, they don't actually give you the instructions
back then.
Like, in-game.
They just assume you could read the manual.
Which was an issue for me.
Because I couldn't read in general.
Yeah, it's save points.
Yeah, you screw up forgot to save.
Well, too bad.
Got me a key for this.
I'm just gonna grab all the Scooby Snacks.
Okay, 150.
Where's the playground here?
Alright, let's grab...
Let's go to Mystic Playground.
Used to go a little up?
Okay, I'll go up a little bit higher.
Alright, let me know if it's better.
Hello!
Hey, Scooby.
I'll give you some tips on some of the things you will find
around the Mystic Manor.
Make tracks, Scooby-Doo.
You can run faster by holding the R1 button while moving.
Jump by pressing the X button.
Oh, thank God.
Look for more of the clues to give you hints about the area.
You're in.
Okay.
Oh, okay.
I can run now.
Yes, there are a number of Scooby snacks that open.
Oh, thank God.
And lose a dog tag.
Eat some food.
It'll fill you back up.
Everything.
Don't worry.
I can fix all my problems with food.
These platforms look like they will probably stand on them
too, though.
Okay.
Alright, nice.
Oh, my God.
Okay, don't worry.
It'll rebuild itself.
Guys, it didn't rebuild itself.
I don't understand why didn't it rebuild itself oh no death
perception my mortal enemy no any anytime oh it did it did
okay guys see I just had to look away I just had to look
away guys
okay okay we don't need that one snack but look watch this
I'll do a magic oh my god look at look at that i did that i
she's a witch
okay let's grab that one scooby snack my ocd all right we
gotta save here look at that one percent all right sound guy
i'll put the volume up already let me know if it's better
Okay, we're in here.
Oh, I can dig, right?
How to dig.
How to be a dog.
Let's see who the witch really is.
That has turned up all over the place.
The char is very...
And it keeps you from running or jumping.
Oh, okay.
Never mind.
I thought I could dig there.
I don't know.
I thought I could be a fucking dog.
All right.
Whoa.
Is that a drone?
Oh, my God.
This game was ahead of its time.
Oh my god, this game truly was ahead of its time.
They had drones back then.
All right, thank you for the super chat.
Thank you, thank you.
Speaking of food, I also love to live dangerously.
Sometimes I add four tablespoons of feather to my craft
dinner.
Thank you for the super chat.
Thank you, thank you.
Oh my god, we have a real witch here.
All right, let's see.
Oh my god, it's so hard to...
grab fuck that one yeah fuck that it's fine we have to
collect as much as we can now so we don't have to worry
about it later all right let's see is there any more other
any other more scooby snacks yeah no i can't be bothered
this is way too far why don't you go down to the cove what
the fuck i thought you were trying to help me bro i thought
we cool now you want me to leave He's like, get off my
property.
All right, let's grab this.
Is there anything here?
He's just for the tire swings.
All right, let's go back.
We don't need those.
All right.
Did you win the sleep, gotcha, boss?
Addis, thank you, the super chat.
Thank you, thank you.
I did what it was during the, for the maid cafe.
I got it.
I got it once.
That was the high-alt chase for the rest of my life.
The one time I won the sleep, gotcha.
It was a 30-minute nap, and I was...
Okay, to be fair, I did come into the car very dead when we
were setting up.
But, like, it could have been worse.
It really...
Okay, I grabbed the key here.
Wait.
That...
Whoa!
Oh, it's okay.
I'm still okay.
I'm not that scared.
Wait, is that...
Is that Velma?
Oh my god, he's gonna do it again.
You'll find a professor's springing invention before you can
make this jump.
I still tried it.
I thought I could glitch my way up.
Velma, is that you?
Where is she?
Wow!
Oh shit, there's the game.
Oh, it wasn't Velma.
Scooby-Doo, I'm so glad you found me.
Oh, it was just awful.
As soon as we got inside the mansion, It's her, isn't it?
It's...
No, it's her, isn't it?
He is behind my uncle's disappearance.
Then he pulled on a lever.
These trapped doors...
It's Daphne too.
Oh yeah, all of them except you?
No way.
It'll help you get around a little easier.
Alright, nice.
She got...
She did give me a map, so maybe she's not that evil.
Wait, how come I can't go through here?
That's a hole.
Alright, there's some bats here.
How do I...
How to push books in?
Book is out.
How the paws have no thumbs.
My paw has no thumb.
How to push.
Oh, spooky.
I want to grab that spooky...
Scooby snack.
Wait, okay, oh, it takes my HP.
God damn it.
No!
It's fucking Chris's bait.
But there's a Scooby Snack, though.
It's a Scooby Snack.
Oh, I got it.
I got the Scooby Snack.
Yeah, I need an invention for that.
All right.
You need a Professor's Helmet invention to bash through
these.
Oh, my God.
What can I do?
Oh, I think that's why I'm...
I understand why I've been stuck in this game.
I'm like, what do I do with all these inventions that I must
procure?
I fell for again.
Ross, thank you for the super chat.
Thank you, thank you.
Alright.
How do I open door?
I don't understand.
Oh shit, there's a bat here.
Yeah, I don't know how to double jump.
Wait, where's Daphne too?
I cannot go.
I do have a hundred now.
Okay, we can grab this.
Okay, I can grab food here.
Okay, bats hurt, guys.
I don't think I can go anywhere here.
I can't open doors.
It won't let me open a door.
I have no opposable thumbs.
Oh, I did get a key.
I didn't get a key, though.
Alright, let's save.
I'm very paranoid.
That's why I'm...
It's why I like a lot, like...
is to the gate huh well so am i i'm pretty sure it's oh i
can get a shovel here oh nice get to work first one standing
in a fire flower patch okay all right dig time oh i can
fucking i can dig i can use my thumb my non-opposible thumbs
to hold a shovel but i can't push a buck That's why, like, a
lot of people are so paranoid with saving.
Because, like, back then in the PlayStation 2 era, we had no
auto-saves.
Like, we gotta do what we could do.
Alright, just use that shovel.
Yeah, but that's why there was a lot of paranoia.
That's why I would save all the time.
Even when we have auto-saves.
Did I go to a smuggler cove now?
Oh, it's open.
I am still paranoid.
This is a...
Be careful not to fall.
I think this is the...
As far as I got.
I remember...
The only thing I remember was the fishing...
The fishing village.
This was definitely the...
As far as I got in this game for Little Doki.
I unlocked the fishing village and that was it.
I just didn't understand the concept of swapping.
I think it was like...
When you get inventions, you have to like...
Swap your items, and I didn't understand.
Timer jumps around the flying fish.
Where's the flying fish?
Oh, there's the flying fish.
What am I going to do with this?
Oh, to grab Scooby snacks.
Oh my god.
Little Doki's going to be so proud.
Top of small monsters to squash them.
Rats.
That's right.
it's not murder they have no rights in the animal hierarchy
I'm at on the top that's right no rats for you
uh you need one of the professors to feed larger monsters
try sneaking past the monsters while they're asleep or not
paying attention how the fuck do I sneak it didn't say how
oh my god oh my god Scooby Am I glad that he's in here, and
I'm out here?
Wait, what's up?
Full copy, pasta.
Yeah, I can't fucking sneak yet.
Okay, maybe I can do it from here.
Oh.
I don't need to sneak if I just go down from this side.
There we go.
Easy.
But what I want to know is, where's the caveman?
rat.
Am I glad that he's in there?
We're out and we're out here, but what I really want to know
is, where's the cave man?
Oh my god, please.
There you go.
I gotta kill this rat.
Wait, what's up here?
Oh, nice.
Okay, oh, Scooby Snack!
Hang on to the pelican for a shortcut back.
Be sure to grab all the goodies along the way.
Okay, pelican.
I don't have depth perception, please.
Please, this was the worst part about 3D games.
It tests my fucking depth perception.
Come on.
Where the fuck?
Okay, no.
Come on.
Let me, let me, let me, come on.
Okay, there we go.
All right.
I'll grab all the Scooby snacks so I can unlock the areas.
All right, nice.
Well, I want to grab the Scooby snacks because that's what
we need to unlock more areas.
So I'm just grabbing them in advance so I don't have to
worry about it later.
Wait, he just drops me off?
Bro, what the fuck?
This is a round trip.
I thought this was a round trip.
Oh my god, it was single round.
I didn't know that it was a...
It's a shortcut back.
I'm gonna go down from this side.
Alright.
Whom?
Yeah, I only paid for one way.
Did you guys know?
I just found this out.
So like for me in Canada.
Oh, we're blocked.
Shaggy!
Wait, how did you get out of the tunnel?
Raggy!
What the fuck?
You were downstairs!
How did you get out?
It's locked.
Why it sure is.
Come on, pal.
Let me give you a hand or a leg.
Throw me up onto that life preserver.
Then you can swing from my legs to reach that crate.
Oh my god, nice.
We're okay.
We're okay, Raggy.
This is wrong.
Man, Khan was not supposed to let this happen.
Rinse us, Ragey.
Just a couple of guys.
It's a dog!
Man's best friend, you know?
Man's best friend.
I'm gonna hang around here.
Can't get it.
Hang around.
I'll catch up with you later.
A man in his dog.
Scooby is up, bro.
I don't know if I can, like, grab the snacks.
No, I need double jump for that.
That's true friendship right there.
I'll grab the Scooby snacks.
Oh, oh, row!
The kid bed!
Oh!
Not the kid bed!
Shit, okay.
It's fine.
I'm okay.
It's okay.
Yeah.
He's not frozen!
What's this?
Where is it?
Oh, it's fast travel.
Oh, I don't give this very ahead of its time.
Oh, I can literally fast travel for this.
Go grab this.
Oh, I got 50.
Let's go.
See?
This is why I grabbed all of this in case.
Okay, I need a spring.
Alright, I need to find the professor's inventions.
But I unlocked this area.
Oh, wait.
What's this?
Okay, never mind.
It's not unlocked yet.
I think this is as far as I got.
I'm pretty sure.
I'm pretty sure I was stuck on this entire water level.
There's a shortcut around the connection.
what oh okay wait does it take me back oh
it does okay because I was like where the fuck is the canary
ah yes the famous Scooby-Doo warp gates in my Scooby-Doo
lore yeah I can't I can only walk away very slowly it's okay
the crab can't get me I somehow travel at least point one
faster than him you know this the loading screens are very
accurate no waiting time oh no it's the fucking and it's the
ghost divers yeah I can't just walk it's the spooky scuba go
scuba divers yeah Oh, there's the spring traps!
Okay, now I can do a double jump.
Yay!
Okay, I can double jump now.
I get anything up here?
Can I double jump back there?
Oh yeah, also, by the way, the cameras do not move.
Wait, what?
I don't get out of here.
Do I just have to slowly walk back?
Wait, is there...
Where's the pelican?
Get over here.
Yeah, you can't move the cameras in these old games, too.
A lot of them, you can't.
I guess I gotta slowly walk back.
Oh, yeah, thank you, bro.
Not...
Oh, I can't even go there.
Alright.
Rot roll.
I've got my double jump now.
The long walk of victory.
Yeah, it's like fixed angles and everything.
I'll grab the sandwich.
I need that, actually.
Very nostalgic.
Yeah, it was on the PlayStation 2 on the GameCube.
I've only played it on the...
Okay, god damn it.
Okay, wait.
what oh my god it's backtrack yeah this is why the dokey
didn't understand i was like i got the invention what do you
mean i have to go back i was very confused oh my okay i have
to go to mystic manner and this is holy shit is that the
fucking map
Backtracking in my Scooby-Doo game?
You know, this is why Little Doki did not understand.
Holy shit.
I did not realize how...
Look, I was stuck on the fishing village.
I was literally stuck on level one, guys.
I never made it past...
I never made it past level one.
I did not realize all of this existed.
All right.
Oh, no, it's a...
I don't remember which ghost...
What villain this was.
All right.
Oh.
Seems to be locked on the other side.
Okay, I gotta figure this out on the other side.
Whoa.
Oh, I got the monster broken.
All right.
We gotta go this way for the...
Can I double jump into this hole now?
No, I can't.
Oh, wait, I can grab more Scooby Snacks here, though.
Yay, Scooby Snacks!
Is there more?
Yeah, there's another one.
Alright, I think I stockpiled enough Scooby Snacks.
This should unlock, like, at least three more places.
My non-Seroakin.
Oh, my God, I can finally get that.
Wait, what can I do with double jump?
Oh my god, I can't do anything in here.
I just...
Okay, okay.
Okay, I...
Oh, no.
Present Doki is also confused, just like little Doki.
Just like...
Oh, no.
Adult Doki is also stuck.
Something about the...
Oh, I remember it.
I remember it now.
Nothing changed.
It was here.
It was the key right here.
Okay, I got the key.
I got double jump.
There we go.
Now we can go here.
Okay, we can go here now.
Wait, can I stomp?
Nice.
I can stomp on spiders.
On the other side.
Alright, so okay, I can go this way.
We're in a maze now.
I don't have to kill him, but I'm sending a message.
I'm gonna ruin the environment.
I'm going to destroy the ecosystem of this place.
That's right.
Can I need the helmet power up?
I'm going to do it.
I kill all the spiders.
Oh my god, it's a fucking werewolf.
All right, who the fuck are employing all these actors?
It's like I'm in a real haunted house right now.
Wait, what's over here?
Oh, hey, it's a witch.
Okay, bye.
Just for a fucking sandwich?
What the fuck is that point?
I'm gonna grab another sandwich right here.
Oh, shit!
Okay, they better be paid a lot of money here, this
Scooby-Doo.
I startled the witch.
Yeah, whoever is...
Whoever...
Whoever is the mastermind of this shit.
Wait, is this good or bad?
Okay, that's a bad pot.
It's a bad Cauldron.
Doing very well in reducing the property value.
Okay, I can go here.
I'm so lost.
This map is a lot bigger than I thought it'd be.
Little Doki never got to experience this.
There are two of the Professor's Adventures, the Slippers
and the Lampshade.
You can use the Sliplers to sneak past the monsters by
holding R2 button while walking.
use the lampshade to hide from the monsters by holding R2.
Use your new lampshade and slippers to avoid the zombies
hiding.
Oh, hey!
Nice.
They'll never know.
Shh.
Be very, very quiet.
They'll never know.
They'll be like, why is there a lamp out here?
Why the fuck is there a lamp out here?
out here in the middle of this labyrinth maze.
Okay, wait.
Watch this.
You'll never know.
That there is a dog here.
Alright, wait.
We gotta grab this.
Oh, that must be a spring.
Okay, that was not a spring.
Can I use this?
Oh, I can use this as a platform.
Nope, never mind.
I cannot.
I got a little hopeful there for a second.
Not even make it.
Oh, I can.
I'm hiding in plain sight.
Yeah, it's good practice for Metal Gear.
What's this?
Wait, that's shaggy.
Wait, that's also shaggy.
Okay, that's a little creepy, bro.
I'm a little concerned why all the statues are just shaggy.
Apparently, we open from the other side.
Okay, but what if, like, I can't?
open it here oh it's a robbie oh it's a robbie whoa
he still found me how did he go oh how did he do it's okay i
don't understand my disguise was perfect
My disguise is impenetrable.
I got that spirit Halloween.
Oh, God.
How the fuck do I get over here?
Whoa, whoa, whoa, whoa, whoa, whoa.
All right, all right, dig.
Grab the sandwich.
Oh, my God.
He's just walking.
He doesn't care.
Oh, hey, Shaggy.
Oh, hey!
I didn't realize those were...
What the fuck are these, like, thorns?
Can
I just not fucking walk through branches?
Does that make my paws hurt?
Alright, here we go, Shaggy.
Whoa, whoa, whoa, this is very...
I do not feel shaved, Shaggy.
Alright, it's okay.
The power of friendship.
yeah it's all right he's doing it it's a very poorly kept
poorly kept guarded
oh god I was too fast I was a little too fast yeah don't
touch grass very bad for you I don't but um bum but um but
um oh shit there you go why did we not call the Why are the
kids doing this?
Where are the police?
Nice.
And there's firebuzz?
Oh, no.
I'm not feeling so good, Shaggy.
Raggy.
I'm losing my nine lives, Raggy.
No.
Oh, shit.
I'm so scared, Raggy.
You're a bad pet owner, Raki!
Okay, there you go.
Raki, I don't feel so good.
Okay, I'm okay now.
Not as scared anymore.
Raki, help!
Oh, it's fine.
Okay, God, I made it.
I made it across.
I want to grab this.
He's not a cat, okay.
You might as well be.
All right, can I have enough?
I love your 50.
See, this is why I stockpiled, guys.
I have to stockpile my Scooby Snacks.
Cops.
Group of hippies over cops.
It's fine.
Okay, yes.
The fact that the Noah's Auto is so annoying.
spam it.
Okay, it's just all rats.
Got killed the rats.
I need the helmet for that.
Can't wait to backtrack all of this later.
Oh no, I'm scared.
Oh no, I'm so scared.
Where are the sandwiches?
Okay.
These are not sandwiches.
Oh, nice.
Okay, I...
I don't need to grab the...
run past these.
Oh, I cannot!
I cannot!
I don't know why.
I don't know.
I thought I could just run past it.
Apparently, I was not built like that.
But I'm so scared.
Oh, God.
I'm so scared right now.
I have to go all the way back if I die here.
No, no, no, no, no!
Oh my god, oh my god, oh my god, where am I?
Oh no, where's a rambi?
Oh no, not a rambi.
Oh, please tell me.
Okay, enter.
One HP and a dream.
Yeah, it's because he's a scaredy cat.
Where the fuck am I?
I lived.
That's right.
Not today.
Not today, zombie.
Right this way.
Bro, there's just a lot of scooby snacks, bro.
I need a fucking sandwich.
I'm so hungry.
Oh, God.
No!
Oh, don't worry about it.
Oh, I already lost the I thought I could make it guys I
really did I thought he couldn't tell I thought I was so
incognito guys he's like there's no way that's that's who we
do stop like live here oh my god oh my god rats have
sandwiches I repeat rats are food
Little Doki was never progressing, was never finishing this
game.
Little Doki was never beating this game.
It's just a lamp.
Yeah, it's a lamp in the middle of the fucking greenhouse.
And no wonder she only was, she was only in the water level.
It's another sandwich.
Okay, we need as much sandwiches as possible.
I know it says like this way is where I have to go But also
sandwich though Wait, wait, wait Anything for a ruby scat
Wait, he followed me all the way here Bro, what the fuck?
Whoa!
Okay, I was almost too fast
Oh, oh, that's a tree branch I didn't even see it, it
blended right in Oh shit, okay, we're gonna grab the
sandwich A soapbox will replenish your soap bubbles when you
find that...
What the fuck is a soap bubble?
What the fuck hit me?
What?
What damaged me?
Oh my god, it's the goddamn tree.
It literally blends in.
Oh god, this... Okay.
Where am I now?
Oh, what did the...
Oh!
It's okay, we're fine.
We lost him.
We just ran...
Oh my god.
It's okay, wait, wait, wait.
We lost him, guys.
Look at that.
We just ran a little bit further away, and we lost him.
Yeah.
Off we go.
Does this game have cutscenes?
It does.
But we have...
I don't know where...
I am I think I've I think I'm way up I'm like way out of
schedule right now I'm not supposed to be here I feel like
oh my god I can't even grab that I'm way off track right now
the game was was like you're not supposed to be here I went
off road oh I am going the right way good okay that's good
Okay, we have headbash.
Wait, okay, let's grab this first.
And then go here, and then grab the warp.
And then, I'll grab the headbash.
Oh, God.
That's right.
Got work on your aim, Grandma.
Okay.
Oh, hey, cake.
Yum, yum.
Oh, my God, more cake.
Bats have cakes!
Oh my god, are you fucking kidding?
I have to go all the way back here!
God damn it.
Oh god, I have to...
Oh, he doesn't have the cake anymore.
Is he also...
Oh, it's like a one-time thing.
Okay, these are like precise jumps.
Alright.
We're fine.
Okay.
Size jumps, parkour, platformers, my strongest game genre
ever, apparently.
Right, guys?
I'm so good at platformers.
One of my all-time favorite games, actually just fully
playing again recently, Venice, thank you, the Super Chat,
thank you, thank you.
I remember enjoying this game a lot, even though I only was
in one level.
Even though, like, I only made it to the water level.
Which was the very first level.
I still enjoyed it with a very limited With a very very
Limited scope Okay Oh my god it's not that thank god You
think I can bash that Found a helmet I can press square to
dash ahead and bash the objects Oh I can bash the monsters
now Wait okay what did I get from this Oh my god so many
Maybe snacks.
Wait.
God damn it.
There you go.
Yay!
Cake!
I murdered someone!
Let's go!
Oh my god.
Okay, wait.
No!
Wait!
Speedrun.
It takes me at the bottom.
Yay!
Plan, guys.
Guys, it's planned.
Fully planned.
Let's go.
Yeah!
Murder!
The thing is, I actually have to go back because there was a
web right there.
Okay, maybe it's not much of a speedrun because I realize I
have to go back.
Oh, okay, nice.
There was, like, a web area.
So not as speedrunning as I thought it was gonna be.
Fuck, it's a web.
There you go.
Okay, it's right over here.
I can't believe...
You can't trial a dog.
Oh, wait, you can.
Wait, wait.
You're right.
You can't...
To be honest, you actually can't trial a dog.
But, like, the punishment is way worse.
Like...
The punishment is really bad.
Where the fuck am I?
all right i need a pee wait i'll be right back guys i have
to pee
my god he's has a magnifying glass next to you right smile
thank you this super chat thank you thank you oh i just
remembered a story i wanted to tell you guys so um i just
found out recently how um because like you know i'm canadian
so like like prices here is like fucking expensive like no
matter even when you're flying in the country and apparently
because like we don't have like um because our we don't
really have like super cheap airlines in general where am i
where the fuck am i so i found out like uh one of my friends
is like yeah i'm gonna go fly over to like um this state
because wait how do i get map out oh map oh fuck this is not
helpful This-
What the fuck is this map?
What the- What is this map?
It's not even a map!
What am I looking at?
Okay.
What am I even looking at?
Like, I'm so confused.
Like, yeah.
This map is a circle.
Okay, so, they're like, yeah, I'm gonna go to, like, like,
um, this, uh, this state over there, and I was like, oh,
shit, like, you're flying so much, like, isn't it expensive?
And then, my friend was like, no, it's, like, $50, and I'm
like, what?
I'm like What the fuck do you mean?
It's only $50 To fly To a different state in America So like
Apparently in America There's like super fucking cheap
airlines Like I don't know Like I think it's called like
Spirit I don't know I don't know what the fuck your airlines
are But like There's multiple like fucking cheap airlines in
um in america to the point where he can pay fifty dollars to
fly like i was like okay what the were
yeah spirit and frontier i was looking crazy it's like i
think i'm going back to where i came from i'm so lost Yeah,
but that doesn't exist in Canada.
We don't have that.
We have to pay, like, minimum, like, $200.
I guess if you're flying really fast somewhere, it doesn't
really matter if it's terrible.
The thing you gotta be scared of is just losing your
luggage.
Just don't do, like, super long flights, and then you should
be fine, right?
Right?
It's a whale.
Yeah, so that's why it's like, so that's why it's, like,
people in America can fucking just fly.
like fly all over the place without worrying
it is real i looked it up and then my friend was like yeah
look up the flight tickets right now and it was 58 i was
like what the fuck it's literally 58 i forgot which state i
was like looking at it was like there's like they're like
yeah look up blank to uh to this to this and i was
As long as you don't have, like, too much luck.
I guess if you do a carry-on, I guess.
Like, if you do a carry-on, it doesn't, like, matter too
much.
Just don't grab, like, actual, like, big luggage.
Doki, imagine a carry-on delaying your flight because she's
having a...
Oh, well, telling you to see if the chat thing can think.
Oh, no!
This is not what I wanted.
yeah they'll get you there all right we gotta do this again
that's actually just insane to think like flights are that
cheap right now in america not right now but you guys have
flights that cheap where the fuck is my fast travel Colin
Spirit I was gonna say run by warlocks Your soul and wallet
are not mated To the destination intact The things you do
For a $50 flat
I should have went backwards I didn't realize this would
take longer I'm rummy Rummy Oh raggy get over here I got
lost This was a maze It was a very it was a singular pathway
maze and I still got lost.
It was incredibly streamlined.
I still found a way to get lost.
Alright.
The rest of the affair is paid in faith in humanity.
Thank you for the super chat, Papa.
Thank you.
Oh yeah, but then you guys can also drive, too.
That's a crazy ride.
I remember in the maid cafe people were like oh yeah like i
i drove from a different state okay there we go where am i
is this where i am
where's my warp pipe warp gate is not activated i'm here
right where am i
did i not activate this oh my God.
I thought there was a warp gate.
Yeah, people were just driving, like, from a...
I was like, but in Canada, you can't just drive to another
like, another province.
That doesn't exist when you can't just drive over to another
province.
That would take us days.
So here?
Wait.
you can't.
But it would take us a very long time.
This.
Oh my god, I was going this way.
Is it?
Oh, there you go.
I want to go here.
Okay.
Where does this lead?
Use the Super Smash to activate and are you fucking kidding?
Oh my god.
I walked all the way back and I can't even activate this.
I Okay, that's okay, okay, all right.
So I can activate that, guys.
Okay, I walked all the way back here for no fucking reason.
It's okay.
We'll go back to the web.
It's bad.
We'll just go all the way back.
We'll go to the web area.
I did these jumps so many times.
I've done these jumps before.
Okay.
That is just so natural now.
Oh, it's fine.
It's fine.
I can take one.
One damage.
Oh, yeah.
Speaking of, like, traveling.
You guys hear about how, like, because I saw someone talking
about the strikes and stuff.
Apparently, I mean, I know it's, like, super common in
France, too, for people that go on strikes all the time.
Like, apparently, like, every couple of weeks, you have to
deal with, like, some union or some um some workplace going
on strike oh my god i could have just went home oh okay
that's okay that's okay i needed to go here anyway yeah it's
in the culture so apparently disneyland paris is on strike
right now um and like it's all the cleaners and it's like
the cleaners too that's on strike on disneyland paris so
like apparently it's like super Oh, I can open this now.
Why do I need, like, my fucking head for that?
I can use, operate a shovel.
Yeah, so the workers at Disneyland Paris are on strike.
So it's, like, super fucking dirty and everything right now
at Disneyland Paris, where the garbage is, like, everywhere.
And the thing was that...
All right.
Oh, hey, nice.
Chicken was in him.
Oh, my God.
What the fuck?
it's okay i can oh oh he doesn't die okay we gotta leave oh
wait i think that's a that has to be there has to be a
monster in there oh but then there's a swooby snack oh it's
okay we'll just go this way yeah apparently it's like but
like the thing is they couldn't like they can't like uh stop
the like close the park down because people already bought
the tickets like years in like not years months in advance
so so they can't stop the they can't just close down the
park because closing them down the park makes them lose even
more money than just like then running then have it like run
as it is all right cake yeah it's just not getting clean now
also apparently you know how i said really wanted to speak
your theme parks i said i really wanted to go to like epic
universe um apparently wait times for one ride is like five
hours i'm like for one ride at uh epic universe that's
insane i'm taking that there you go it's okay i just touched
the fire a little bit.
Look at that.
Wait, I don't keep it?
What the fuck's the point?
It said I took it.
That's bullshit.
I should have been able to keep the fucking key.
How do I turn off the goddamn stove?
Tokey fire bad tokey.
Yeah, but there's a key.
Oh, the starter's lag.
A double jump it.
Yeah, but I think that's insane.
Oh, wait, I did it.
I turned on the sprinklers.
Yeah, it hasn't even been a year.
And wait time is like five to six hours for one ride.
People were saying it's because there's not enough rides in
Epic Universe.
Oh, my God, I did it.
God damn, it's time.
I didn't know it was time.
All right.
We gotta go fast.
We gotta go so fast.
Okay.
I got the key.
And I also got a sandwich too.
Delicious.
Yum, yum.
What is Epic Universe?
It's the newest universal theme park.
So they have like how to train your dragon land.
The monster land.
I don't know what it's called.
The monster universe land.
What the fuck?
Azir.
I don't remember what the other lands were.
But these were the two I remember the most.
Because they were really cool.
The Toofless and Hiccup were really cool.
Yeah, like one rat is, like, I don't know.
That's crazy.
That's like, you lost, like, half the day.
Like, I do not want to be in queue for half a day.
Oh, I'm full HP.
Like, I could do, like, other stuff with my time.
Oh, yeah.
And the people were saying that it's cheaper.
It's cheaper to fly to Japan and go to Tokyo.
Disneyland than to fucking fly to Florida to go to
Disneyland that's insane the fact that it's cheaper to go to
the other side of the world for Disneyland than it is to
like go to one in-state like if you're flying to like if
you're from America it's actually is cheaper especially the
currency too people are saying it's also because like
currency in um like USD the yen is like good right now yeah
florida is fucking expensive like getting hotels hotels uh
parking oh yeah because like you know i don't drive
apparently parking is crazy that is crazy expensive what the
fuck he's just there oh my god that's a ghost ghost whoa i
didn't realize how expensive parking can be because i i
never had like a point of reference regarding parking
because i at the park because i don't drive oh i
don't but um i've never i haven't gone to tokyo disneyland
or disneyland sea since i was like little i want to go there
i'll go to universal in japan too universal in japan
apparently is really fun but that's a lot of keys but which
one's the right key oh they're all the right key it's the
creeper oh my god not the creeper shaggy raggy
Yeah, every time I went to Japan, majority of times I went
to Japan, it's just a business trip.
Okay, I need four keys to open this.
Oh my god, he's just chasing me.
It's okay.
I am just fast enough.
But where's the last key, though?
Where the fuck is the last key?
Oh my god, it's all the way here.
Alright.
Oh my god, he's still at- It's okay, I'm up top.
That's right.
I got the hot ground now.
Whoa, whoa, whoa.
Oh, whoa, whoa, whoa, whoa, whoa, whoa, whoa, whoa.
Yeah, but I want to know what's over there.
Does he know?
Oh, we closed.
Right.
It's a headless tractor.
I really want to go to the Nintendo.
Yeah, the Nintendo Land.
What's this over here?
Oh, it's more Ruby's Racks.
Ruby Racks.
All right, over here, I'll go.
Jesus, there's all monsters everywhere.
Yay, murder!
Let's go!
Make sure I've did a disclaimer.
You know how haunted houses are?
Like, don't touch the actors?
Also, he's a dog.
He can't read.
He doesn't know that.
All right.
He's also a dog.
He doesn't know that.
He doesn't know he's not supposed to touch them.
all right we gotta grab the monster token all right let's go
yeah dogs don't no no oh my god back back where i started
are you fucking kidding me a double head okay it's okay i
left the sandwich here somewhere
sandwich okay I did not leave a sandwich that was a scooby
snap wait does he have a cake nice yeah free cake oh she
respawned that's good for me anyone there no okay I can do
this why am I doing this I'm not all right we're not
collecting and shit besides besides that monster was
forgettable anyway he's not a lister he ain't a lister like
the others
are we leave no the lord all right does she also have cake
still oh no more cake yeah no i give up.
We're not doing that again.
My death perception ain't working right now.
Well, I'm not talking about the creeper.
I'm talking about the monster token.
The guy with the mask.
He's not an A-lister.
He wasn't in the Scooby-Doo movies.
In the live action.
Right?
See, the ghost, he was an A, he's an A-Lister.
If that was his monster token, I'd get it.
Alright, this way.
Wait.
Yeah, the witch doctor.
See, I didn't even remember his name.
Scooby didn't even call him by his name.
If he was an A-Lister, Scooby would be like, Oh, Ro!
The witch, the rich doctor!
Well, he didn't say it.
Okay, now I gotta wait for that, I guess.
Excuse me, yeah.
Oh, oh my god, he's doing round trip, too.
He's doing a fucking round trip.
See, there's no shadow.
It's so hard to see without the shadow at the bottom.
Tell me where to go.
There you go.
I don't know.
I don't know if there's anything important down there.
risky i feel like i have to wait for another round trip if i
go down yeah i'm not risking this i'm just gonna head
straight around the world around the world around the world
i made it across right it's a werewolf a werewolf i'm too
scared to like i fucking knew it the moment i ran i was like
i'm too scared to walk across.
I knew it.
I fucking knew it.
They always get me what I least expected it.
There's a warp gate.
There's a warp gate over there.
Then what's behind me?
Anything back here?
Oh, it's just more Scooby Snacks.
Oh, wait.
What's this door?
Where does this door go?
You always said where were werewolf i'll never never who was
where's who wolf when wolf in how wolf are you fucking oh my
god okay does this map like where am i
okay it's okay i can do this i can speed run this i play
i've done these jumps before i i've done these jumps before
okay it's fine this is punishment no i forgot where that
place was i was like what is this place i remember being
here all right we're almost there all right i know there are
the werewolves right here it's a werewolf and then he's
gonna jump out from here but i know i got you this time
that's okay never mind it's gonna come out down all right
Down we go.
Yeah,
no.
A lot of the older platform games is just all about
backtracking.
Thanks for the funny stream so far.
Glad we head to bed now.
See you all in the bots tomorrow.
Thank you, the super chat.
Thank you, thank you.
I'm glad you've been having a good time.
It's nice being able to play these nostalgic games too for
you.
as finally accomplishing something that little dokey did it
like all of this i'm like i've never seen any of this before
i'm just like i've never been here before god damn it i like
got hit by the chandelier this place is not safe What the
fuck?
Wait, why is he here?
Wait, is there anything on the other side?
I'm gonna double check.
I wish...
I wish we get another...
Are you fucking kidding me?
Oh my god.
You know what?
What a remaster of?
Would not remaster.
I wish toys for bots would make another Spyro game inspired
by like...
the original trilogy Spyro is like my top favorite game of
all time I'll still say Professor Layton is my most favorite
but I want Spyro is like number two I want Spyro game but
made by Toys for Bob yeah Toys for Bob what the fuck I did
not expect all of this because I went the other way instead
of the way where the guy was just chilling.
Like, where did this go?
Is this going to take me anywhere?
Oh,
that was the witch docker.
Where the fuck am I?
Oh, my God.
Because I was debating if I should talk to the guy and I was
just sitting there.
Oh, my God.
This map is so fucking big.
Wait, how do I get to that side then?
Oh, do I need Raggy's help?
Oh, Manga, I need Raggy to be here.
Yeah.
But, you know, like, because, like, all the fucking future
Spiral iterations were so bad.
We're so trash.
Like, after the trilogy.
I will say that one was Cinder.
I think it was, but her name is Cinder, right?
Like, Spiral's girlfriend?
That one was okay.
All right.
But, like, I still think the trilogy was the best out of all
of them.
Yeah.
You know, one, the trilogy with, like, where Spyro got a
girlfriend.
See, okay, the witch doctor?
That's A-list.
You guys got confused with the other guy.
The other guy with a mask.
Like, I remember this guy.
Alright, there you go.
No, I don't count Skylanders as Spyro.
That was just like, Spyro was not even like...
I feel like Spyro, too, um, in Skylanders was just like an
add-on.
He wasn't like, he was like a, like a side character.
He didn't feel like a main character.
Okay, yeah, this guy.
Okay, I was gonna say it.
The door is taking you back to the first room in the
mansion.
I should clean up these webs, but I think I'll just...
stand around here for a little.
What was the point?
What was the point of me going around in a circle?
Yeah, it was just there to sell.
It was just there to sell the game.
I don't know where to go now.
I'm so lost.
Oh my god, I'm so lost.
Where the fuck am I?
Oh my god.
What's the library that we're waiting for?
Oh my god, it's warp tab.
Alright.
Don't worry.
It's warping tab.
Where the fuck is the warp?
There you go.
Okay.
Mystic matter.
Where am I?
Here?
Is this the library?
Where is this?
Oh, it is.
Okay, okay.
Back to the library and go.
It's time to split up and look for clues, gang.
This is not a map.
It is not a map.
I'm like, where am I looking at?
Okay, back.
Oh, bye.
Yeah, no, the Spyder Trilogy was remade.
I wish they do like you know Spiral 4 and ignore the others
Like don't you there was no there was not There was not a
Spiral 4 There was never There was never the year of the
dragon It never existed So I wish they would make Spiral 4
But like from Toys for Bob Yeah that's what Crash did too
Didn't it?
Oh yeah, enter the dragon.
No, there was no.
No, no, no, no, no, no.
There was no.
Enter the, guys.
Enter the dragonfly.
Buff.
Scooby.
Buff Sparks won't hurt you.
Buff Sparks can't hurt you.
He wasn't real.
Voice by what's his name?
The Lord of the Rings guy.
The Lord of the Rings hobbit too.
Oh.
For those of you don't know, I think it was Spiral 4.
They made Sparks buff as fuck.
And then they got Elijah Wood.
They got Elijah Wood.
And David Spade as Spark.
Yeah, Elijah Wood was like Spiral.
And then David Spade was Spark.
How the fuck do I...
Oh, there you go.
It was bugged.
Okay.
I was like, how do I get over there?
Yeah, but he's so far.
He's not even close to me.
Are you fucking kidding me?
Okay.
That's fine.
Where the fuck did that open?
Oh, it's over here.
Okay, I don't think I need to grab more Scooby Snacks.
Like, I think I'm stacked right now in Scooby Snacks.
Go away.
Where do I go?
I guess I'll try here first.
Cosmo, thank you for the super chat.
Thank you, thank you.
Creepers.
There's no creepers.
Oh my god.
There's so many backtracks, so I don't know which backtrack
I should backtrack.
Yeah, this mansion looks a lot bigger than in the inside
than the outside.
I don't know if you guys saw what the outside looked like.
Wait, there's a fucking Twinkie right here.
Oh, it's the Bubba.
It's the soap.
Okay, I can't...
Wait, maybe I can glitch it?
Nah, I can't.
I was going the right way.
Okay, that's good to know.
Crazy part is I have not fought my first boss yet.
That's the crazy part.
There's like bosses there, and I have yet to encounter my
first boss.
Oh god Oh there's Shaggy Okay the stairs are not That's good
to know The stairs are not dangerous
Yeah Shaggy?
Shaggy are you okay?
Don't worry Shaggy Yeah there's bosses in this game The true
yeah the true boss is the Fucking bad desire Where's the up
there and we're down here.
Okay.
Let me grab the other stuff first.
Shaggy.
Yeah, I'll go this way.
I want to make sure there's nothing else that I forgot.
Okay, everything.
Oh yeah, that's just a short oh my god, I just went the long
way to get to Shaggy.
Yeah, games back then love fixed camera angles.
What's this?
Yay!
He princess carries me down!
Equality!
Get yourself.
Get yourself a guy like Shaggy.
He cares.
He cares about equality.
What the fuck?
Oh, he'll push the button.
Alright, stand over here.
Shaggy, I need you to stand over here.
Okay, never mind.
Oh, is he gonna chuck me?
Alright, there you go.
Yay!
Alright, then we leave him.
Looks like I'll be cooling my heels around here.
See you, pal.
Yeah, guess you're yourself a boy who can princess carry you
and you can princess carry him.
Treat you right.
Oh.
Yeah, I think he's dead.
Okay.
Now where do I go?
He took my own new platform.
Oh, I know.
My enemy.
Death perception.
Okay, we got this.
Oh, no.
Okay.
It's okay.
We can make this jump.
Oh, my God.
It's okay.
We made the jump.
That's all that matters.
I don't...
Where do I go?
We made...
We got to go right.
There you go.
Here we go.
Uh, this way.
350 jesus christ these snacks are expensive oh my god when
did inflation hit the scooby snacks do i even get royalties
okay that house is a lot bigger than what i saw down there
what where did this when did this house grew like that what
when the fuck okay the scooby market crashed i just want to
know what the who added all these new installments in the
house what it called when you like expand the house in
construction this is not the same house
Yeah, they did like addition.
They did like additions to it.
What the fuck?
Where am I?
That is definitely a grower, not a shower.
Wait, is that a bad guy?
Oh my god, it's a gargoyle.
Oh my god.
Okay.
I definitely don't remember the gargoyle.
Oh, I died.
I'm dead.
Oh no.
Where did I go?
I still have to go right because that's where the fucking
helmet was.
Oh my god, but how do I get to the right side?
This way.
Okay, I think I fucked up my jump earlier.
all right off we go
is it this way it has to be this way can I drop down because
I saw a gargoyle over here and then I go oh no oh fuck okay
okay okay okay sorry I no I self missed okay it's fine what
if I just drop down from here oh my god oh my god oh my god
oh my god Oh my god, I can't...
I can't...
No, no, no!
No!
It's okay.
I can do this again.
I figured it out.
All right.
I achieved the system.
I found a shortcut.
I'm running.
And I drop down from here.
And then there's the gargoyle.
Oh my god.
This is...
This part just freaks me up.
Where am I?
Oh!
I don't understand!
I'm hitting straight!
This time.
Okay, we drop down.
And then there's the rock row.
It's a gargoyle.
Am I, every time I feel like I wasn't, I'm not gonna hit it.
Oh my god, I keep freaking out because I keep thinking I'm
not.
I keep thinking I'm not gonna hit it.
So I keep jumping back.
I'm freaking out.
Okay, the set.
Okay, I'm not risking it.
I'm not risking it.
I just went for it.
Okay, there is a door.
But I feel like I can...
Okay, I feel like the magic carpet's gonna take me all the
way to the top, baby.
Right.
Guys, where is the magic carpet taking me?
This is not up.
Okay, guys, the magic carpet is not taking me all the way to
the top, baby.
It's taking me all the way to the bottom.
Okay, it's this way.
I can't believe they renovated, added, expanded the house
while I've been trapped in the fucking mansion.
They added like 10 more floors and 10 more.
like 50 more rooms.
Like, have I been trapped in this manner for 20 years?
Like, what the fuck happened?
Alright, this way.
Constructions will continue.
It doesn't matter if this- Are you fucking kidding me?
It's edgeguarding me!
All right.
That's okay.
I made it across.
There we go.
This guy plays Smash.
Yeah, the moment you enter the manor, you're in like this
hyperbolic time chamber.
Like, time literally stopped in the manor.
It's like, it's like...
It's been 20 years.
We've been waiting for you.
missing.
Where's the last key?
What the fuck?
I'm missing a key.
That got all four keys?
You have been trapped here since you were a kid.
I did?
Okay.
I didn't realize.
I thought I had I was missing a key.
Oh, there was only three.
Sorry.
Apparently I'm really bad at counting too.
Guys, I'm just role playing as kid dokey guys.
I knew that.
I knew there was three.
That's crazy.
I'm at 30%.
I've yet to encounter a single boss.
Okay, does he... Does that kill him?
No.
Oh, it does.
Okay.
Yeah.
Scooby has committed another murder.
Yeah, so like... You're supposed to be saving the rest of
the Scooby gang?
I've yet to encounter anyone from the Scooby gang other than
Shaggy.
Okay.
Oh my god, there was a carpet the entire time.
Yeah, I need one of the inventions.
I'm missing one of them.
Oh my god, are you fucking...
God damn fat!
Oh my god.
Mystery Gan's parents have been trying to find their missing
teenagers for like 30 years and they were going to give up.
No, they didn't know they've been trapped in this goddamn
haunted mansion.
Where time does not exist here.
All right, one HP and I dream.
Are you okay?
It's fine.
There's a cake down here that I can't get.
That's here to obey me.
And they're like, ooh, this is something.
You really want that cake right now.
Mysterio Inc.
vanished 30 years ago.
It was the last place that people saw them.
Look this, wait, I can grab a set.
There we go.
See, I don't need no umbrella.
If only there was a responsible adult.
If only, if only there was a responsible adult to supervise.
Okay.
Magic carpet.
Alright.
Maybe he has a cake to- nope.
He has no food in him.
Oh, oh, God.
There's the flaming chandelier.
Anything over here?
Landing is covered with sticky tar scoop.
I'll let you move freely with the sticky tar.
All right, not this one.
I'll get boots.
I think the invention was literally boots or some shit.
Like, wow, congratulations.
You invented dog boots.
A revelation of your times.
Modern out- modern Thomas Edison right here.
Oh, no, no, no!
Okay, at least I got the Scooby Snacks, though.
Let's just take me.
Panic in the attic.
Where am I now?
Where am I?
How many attics are there?
Yeah.
Okay.
I feel like I've been...
I've been stuck in this attic for 50 years!
Who needs to sneak sneak when I can just beat them up?
Okay, and I actually needed that too.
Night of a hundred addicts!
I feel like I might as well.
It really is.
Way too many.
Okay, there should be a key here.
Key get.
See?
Who needs sneaking?
Well, I could just bash these people.
Bash them in.
Boop.
It's okay.
I'm a dog.
I don't know what's right or wrong.
But I did it, guys.
Look, it's not my fault.
My owners taught me this.
Okay.
All 100 fights are just every door that leads back to the
attic.
Yeah, yeah, who needs self when you have blood force trauma?
Exactly.
Okay, okay, I should just stun him.
Okay, we leave, we leave, we leave, we leave, we leave, we
leave, we leave, we leave.
Sure, there's nothing inside that fucking box, too, right?
Yeah, see, look at that.
That was just bait.
Is that all the keys?
Wait, but what's over there?
What's on the other side of that area?
What the...
Okay, we're going this way.
That's...
That looks a little too fucked up.
What if the devs were adding it to Expedia?
Thank you for the super chat thinking, thank you.
It's like he doesn't know.
And he doesn't know.
Why can you stun him?
Yay!
Oh my god, was that it?
Is there anything else up top?
Oh my god, there's a Scooby Snack.
Okay, that was it.
It's literally just food.
Oh fuck, okay, it's okay, I didn't get hit.
Oh my god, where am I supposed to go?
Oh, thank god, another warp.
400 goddamn!
The Scooby Snack fucking stock market,
400 jesus christ it keeps going up oh my god and now there's
goddamn a storm's coming out oh my god they got two actors
now this is a fucking budget production for this it's insane
okay
oh no oh no it open wait where did it open where's the
opening oh fuck okay oh it's timed isn't it it was time
wasn't it yeah it was okay it was time
okay i'm here now i don't know where i am but i'm here now
booby snacks.
Oh, my god.
Come on!
Where else was I supposed to go?
This way.
Where?
What the fuck?
Okay, button?
Oh, there we go.
You have to go up here.
I'll wait for the carpet.
Any minute now.
Any minute.
now.
Carp is gonna come down, right?
Oh my god, thank god.
Okay, I did it.
Clutch.
I made it to the other side.
Nice.
Dark and storm united.
At least it's not the attic this time.
Get away from him!
Alright, Shaggy, you're saying it.
I'm a hero.
Save your progress and get a chance battle.
I saved him.
I'm gonna hear...
Oh my god.
I'm gonna get so many Scooby Snacks for that.
I'm gonna restore my fucking Scooby Snack economy.
I don't have an umbrella.
What the fuck?
Oh my god.
Why am I here?
Now I know I find the umbrella.
Where's the closest 7-Eleven that's gonna upcharge me a $20
umbrella?
Wait.
Is he gonna... Can he throw me?
He can't even throw me!
But I'm going back.
Maybe he can throw me.
Where is my 7-Eleven to sell me a $20 umbrella when it's
raining?
Yeah, I was gonna say, was he gonna throw me?
He just said hi.
Oh, there we go.
Okay, thank God.
Okay, this way.
Okay, I need you to throw me a bit better, Shaggy.
There you go.
You have to go up to him.
This way.
God damn it.
Okay, I'm fine.
I actually need the Scooby Snacks.
The economy's been pretty rough on me.
This way.
Ever since the Scooby Snack market crashed, it hasn't been
the same for Scoobs.
Oh.
No.
No, please don't tell me God damn it It's all the way and he
came back
All right The fact that he came back
Okay I go this way This is fine I'm confused there because I
thought
No It's the same place.
I didn't realize it was the same place.
Okay, there you go.
Let's try this again.
Okay, here we go again.
I thought Dino was a different place!
I didn't realize it was the same area!
Right?
Okay, okay, okay, we made it.
Okay, we can wait.
Does it go down?
Do I?
Hello?
How the fuck?
How?
What the fuck do I do?
First flame chimney?
Okay.
Yeah, it's raining.
There's a button I have to press.
Where the fuck is this button?
Oh my god.
Oh my fucking god.
Oh, goodbye, Shaggy.
Oh my god, they kidnapped him.
He'll be fine, right, guys?
Oh.
Okay, isn't that, like, one of the fire?
Guys, Shaggy's gonna be fine, right?
Gravity doesn't exist in the Scooby universe, right?
Guys, it's okay.
Oh, wait, see?
I told you.
Boing.
Guys, I told you.
Gravity ain't real in the Scooby-Doo universe.
Isaac Newton didn't discover it yet.
Get out.
I breathe so fucking high.
It's okay.
Isaac Newton isn't real in the Scooby-Doo universe.
He's too powerful.
I know.
Yeah, I can't jump yet.
all right here we go oh okay oh we got first boss fight this
has to be it oh my god it's the vampire
ah the infamous gooby-doo allow me to introduce myself i am
the master mega oh my god like mega man go is that tim curry
i'm the one who made professor graham disappear professor
graham i'm also the one who's brought back all of your old
clothes but why yeah why is a mystery you will never solve
but we're the mystery gang no mystery is too hard to solve
I thought you were smart.
How did you get trapped by him?
You remember the black night.
I remember.
Wait, how did you do that?
I thought you said magic and real, mama.
What else are you lying to me about?
Oh my god, back when Tim Curry actually did like video game
voiceovers.
Wait, is that?
Right?
I don't want to do this.
Oh!
I understand.
What?
Guys, I don't understand.
What do I do?
Do I wait for you?
Come on, get over here.
Look closer.
Wait, why are you walking away?
Hey, bro.
Yeah, he got their scent!
Okay, okay.
Okay, okay, it's right.
Yeah, yeah, I get it now.
It's like this game is made for babies.
What are you gonna do with that?
Okay, it hit me.
Okay, that's, that's like, that's fucked up.
This did not look like it was gonna hit me, guys.
That axe did not.
Oh, and it conducts electricity too.
Oh my god, this is bullshit.
How the fuck am I supposed to- Okay.
Bro, this guy is just walking back- Okay, this is fine.
God damn it, it was so close.
Bada, bada, bada, bada, no.
Oh my god, he keeps, like, getting triggered and then
walking to the other way.
No!
I've kicked off.
God damn it.
So, yeah, he'll walk back.
He'll walk back, guys.
backward I at least needed him okay it's fine and then he's
gonna walk this way and then bam okay I need a fucking slam
this god damn it this goddamn witch be but don't go back
don't go backwards oh there you go are you fucking kidding
me are you fucking kidding okay we're gonna go we're gonna
go this way first i'm gonna wait for him to go all the way
back all right he's gonna god damn it he's walking back
three uh at least the music is banging okay he has to go
back nice okay i'll take those i take those Are you fucking,
oh my god, it's that one area.
It's literally that one area.
It's, oh my god, he's actually blocking me.
He's actually fucking guarding it.
He's guarding it so hard.
Oh my god.
It's always, he's just there.
He's just there.
Oh my god, are you fucking kidding me?
Okay, okay, it's fine.
Oh my god.
It's just one.
It's just
Please stop the laugh track.
It's not funny I Okay, I got it.
I got it Okay, we did it guys.
We killed him We killed another man today That's Scooby
Thank God the evils defeated.
We did it, Velma!
I committed murder to the Velma.
You won't ride me, all right?
No snitches, remember.
Okay.
Something fishy is going on here, Scooby.
We solved the mystery of the Black Knight ages ago.
Yeah.
I don't know.
I've been trapped in the attic for 20 years.
A spooky groundskeeper?
Yeah, and ghosts and monsters?
Scooby-Doo, you know there's no such thing as monsters and
ghosts.
We both saw the ghost!
I thought he was a monster, but really he was just a guy in
a mask.
Aha!
I found him!
Jinkies!
Bro, he's literally controlling the weather, Velma!
Thanks, Scooby.
I can't see a thing without these.
Janky, Scooby.
It's the creeper.
The creeper?
Where?
He's everywhere.
What?
Run, Scooby.
Roma, what?
Roma, what's going on?
Yeah, I see creepers.
Oh my God, is it all in my mind?
Oh my God.
Planky's wife.
Hmm.
Hello.
I'm Professor Alexander.
Graham and you found one of my amazing invention crates
let's see now what's in this one she didn't take her meds
here we go well inside this box you should either find my
automated herring scraper or my and is stick galoshes oh
looks like it's the galoshes oh my god I told you guys guys
that's crazy he invented rain boots oh my god of our times.
A fucking genius.
I can't believe it.
The...
Are the smartest man alive?
He invented boots for dogs.
Uh, Warren, thank you for the super chat.
Thank you, thank you.
Top tier inventor.
Give him a noble peace prize right now.
Look, in the Scooby-Doo universe, we didn't have boots until
this guy invented them.
That's a genius right there.
Remember, currently half the minutes because they sold their
inventions and cost them and would make thousands more than
what they were stealing.
But I'd like to think it was about the message.
Look, that's... Where am I?
Where did I go?
What the fuck?
How did I go?
Oh my god, how did I get here?
How...
Oh, no.
Oh, my God.
I don't know how I got here.
No, I'm all the way down here now.
Oh, my God.
And the map doesn't tell.
There's a warp here, but where?
I don't remember.
How did I get here?
Okay, was there?
There was a tar thing here, right?
Was it here?
No, it wasn't.
I'm back in the attic again.
No!
Okay.
Let's go to the attic.
Alright.
All doors lead back to the attic.
There was a tar thing somewhere, but I don't remember where
it was.
Oops, all addicts.
I'll never escape the attic okay
this way all right that's fine just a spider okay that's
okay it's okay I can do this again I've done these jumps
before oh my god I almost did that jump too all right I'll
get rid of the spider all right We gotta figure out where
the fuck is the tar area.
Okay, I don't know.
Okay, that's fine.
I'll take it.
Was the tar here?
Oh, it was.
Okay.
That's where I went.
Oh!
All right, we leave.
I have to go.
Oh, it's... It looped back.
It's a loop.
That's how I got here.
Was there anything back here for Tar?
I don't remember.
I just want to double check.
What was this area?
Oh my god.
No, no, no, no, no, no, no, keep, let me die.
Okay, we go back.
We go back.
I remembered.
I remember what this area was.
All right.
We go back to the fishing village.
because I found we invented boots okay I gotta figure out
how to fucking okay all right that's the attic okay oh my
god this takes forever to go back wait we never went to the
super secret lab though warp gate not activated warp gate
not activated wait oh it's It's not the basement yet.
Smugglers code.
Because it's super secret.
We never figured it out.
Because it's very secret.
Alright.
Now that we're here.
We can finally make it across.
Oh my god.
Too secret for me.
Alright.
Now we're here.
Okay.
It's like...
Oh god.
What am I?
Oh my god.
What?
Okay.
It's fine.
We're okay.
We're just fighting against the escalators.
Like, what is this?
Oh my god!
What is this fucking fall guy shit?
No!
I'm so close!
I was so close, dude.
I don't get out.
I made it so far.
Wait, what?
I can't even bash this.
It's so slippery.
Okay, there you go.
All right, there you go.
Wait, why did we bash that?
Give me a sec.
Oh.
My god, she's farming me I'm just farming me I'm trying to
bash the fucking no Let me alone
Oh god Oh god Oh my god They're all coming after me Oh my
god, okay, it's fine It resets me Okay It will, it wouldn't
Okay, at first it wouldn't I tried to fucking bash, use the
bash But it wouldn't let me bash I don't know what was going
on Oh my god, I was so close to the end, too.
Okay.
It's fine.
This part is crazy.
This part is actually crazy.
Like, I think if I get hit one time, like, it's over.
Oh my god, please.
We're almost there.
We're almost...
No!
Like, oh, there you go.
There we go.
Please tell me it's slower.
Oh my god.
Okay.
I was just there.
Where the fuck was that?
What did it do?
How do I get out of here?
I fumbled, okay?
Okay.
I fumbled it.
Am I trapped down here?
Oh my god.
Oh wait, it's over here.
That's bullshit.
That's actually bullshit.
Like, why the fuck did it lead?
Oh my.
Oh, please, please, please.
Please.
we made it we made it oh okay I don't know how little kids
get through that part I don't I don't know I don't know how
they have the reaction time for that
we go this way I think we're fine we don't need the scoopy
snacks right now a movement that's a crazy ass movement tech
right now be fair kids are really insane at Minecraft to be
fair I will have to say Oh my god, are you fucking kid?
Not again, not again.
Get me out of here.
Oh, I can see where it is sleeping.
Okay, there is a key over there.
I gotta grab that key.
Okay, I had to fall down anyway, guys.
The key is right there.
Okay, I grabbed the key, though.
Yeah, some kids are very good at Minecraft parkour.
It's okay.
The Scooby snack.
the scooby snack bubble hasn't burst yet guys it's okay oh
wait no we want it to burst it's okay the scooby snack
economy has burst now guys everything should be fine now
me two more over here
where the fuck is okay it was like right here somewhere oh
there you go we need one more key
all right where is this open the fuck Oh, okay.
Okay, that was crazy.
That was crazy.
Oh, yeah, I'm happy now.
All right.
That is the next one.
The next key is over here.
Right.
Crab.
Oh, no, not the crabs, Ruby.
Not the crabs, Scooby.
all right we go this way the door is over here
all right this should give me the door god damn it all right
nice unlock the door wait wait how did I get back oh my god
this is the beginning I don't even how did I get here how
did I get to the beginning of the fucking door this again.
I was like, wait a minute.
Why is there a door on the other side?
We made it.
Alright, now we're at the door.
Oh my god, wait, his legs are shaky.
Oh, I like that.
The attention of detail.
You know what I miss?
Right.
Video game movie tie-ins.
That monster inking was so good.
I don't know if anyone ever played the monster in the shrek
games back then on the playstation 2 i missed those now
movie studios just make roblox games or fortnite fortnite
collaboration is our like video game tie-in now
i that's that's okay okay
all right we gotta do this all over again I will, yeah, 90%
of them were bad, but when they were good, they were really
good.
I used to love the Shrek Titan games, the Shrek Titan games,
and I remember the Shrek Titan games was really good.
The Monster Ink one was really good.
Um, what are the ones that I really liked when I was growing
up?
There were some really good ones.
Yeah, there were some really shitty ones because it was like
hit or miss.
But game don't, like, uh...
Hollywood execs, some Hollywood execs actually cared about
the quality of the game.
Oh yeah, the Spider-Man 2 games too?
I feel like, I mean, I feel like there were more hits than
misses.
I think the Game Boy Advance Titans were the really bad
ones.
When they tried to make games for all consoles, and they
made one for like, like the Game Boys and Game Boy Advance
and shit.
But when they did games for like PlayStation, it were really
good.
Do I need those?
It's fine, I don't need them.
Yeah, the GBA ones were bad, but the PS2 ones were really,
really good.
Okay, I can just stand here.
That's good.
I thought I would have to, like, go through PTSD from the
last one.
Oh my god.
Apparently the SpongeBob one was really good, too.
Are you serious?
How do I get to the cross that?
Oh, I'm scared.
Oh, God.
No!
This is so hard to control.
Oh, hey, nice.
Okay, I didn't have to do any of that.
Okay, that's cool.
All right.
They just gave me a freebie.
450.
Okay, it's not that bad.
It was 450, guys.
Oh my god, I'm almost broke.
That's gonna hit my savings.
It's okay.
I'm replenishing my savings right now.
Yeah.
Okay.
Nice.
Full HP.
Oh, no.
I'm glad he's trapped in here.
We're out here.
Yeah, I can kill him.
Wait, there's a door right here.
Oh, invisible wall.
It's not fair.
Okay, fishing village, lighthouse.
Where do I want to go?
I mean, it says keep out, but dogs can't read.
Oh, yeah, the Madagascar game was fun, too.
Yeah, I remember playing that.
I like the Madagascar game.
It says keep up, but little did they know dogs can't read
From words that came You should be very, very quiet Oh wait,
he's not in there
Famous last words He's like, it's okay, guys He's not in
there, guys Billy, thank you for the 10 gift of chips Thank
you thank you but yeah I feel like nowadays they just do
like they just do Fortnite collabs they don't have to
fucking spend hundreds and thousands of dollars on a video
game titan they just fucking make they just oh my god they
just make they just do a Fortnite collab and call it a day
which sucks because I do miss those either Fortnite collab
or a Roblox game
oh my god efficient village am I in?
Wait, this is too far?
Yeah, this is too slanted.
I don't know, the long way.
Also, I think it's because no one really plays platformers.
A lot of these games were mostly just platformers.
So there's like no reason.
Oh yeah, a key.
There's like no reason to Fund these types of games If it's
just...
Because platformers aren't as popular as they are now Or as
they were back then
I'm missing one where he asked me this one Oh my gosh, yes
I'll have the Scooby Snacks too
Oh shit!
fucking gay man oh my god they're everywhere
all right where i'll go here
oh i knew it i'm oh i can't do the body slam yet scooby
don't know how to slam the body oh this is not good for
scooby what the fuck
oh my god i'm so scared of getting slab.
I'm, like, not even gonna risk getting the Scooby Snacks.
Yeah, it's mostly indie does that make platformers now.
I agree.
Like, big game companies don't wanna risk it.
I feel like it's...
I feel like...
Indie games don't even...
It's like the year of the indie games now.
Because no...
Because people don't want to...
Like, uh... Because, like...
Big publishers, you have to follow like lots of rules and
everything too.
And indie devs don't want to do that.
Because like the fucking, what is it called?
The board of directors control how the game.
Control the development of the games and they don't want to
listen to that.
Give me that cake.
Right.
Yeah, they just don't want to listen to business, people.
They want to make the game that they want to make.
Where the fuck?
How do I get across the boat from there?
Alright, what is this?
Five!
Oh, I'm broke!
I'm broke!
Oh, no!
Yeah, also, AAA games are definitely a lot more expensive
because they have to pay for, like, everyone in the company.
Oh, my God.
I used to be on top of the world.
What happened?
I'm $34 down to my name.
All right.
I don't have an umbrella.
We haven't invented umbrellas yet in the Scooby-Doo
universe.
Yeah.
Whenever it starts raining, we just toughen it up.
We have yet to invent umbrellas, guys.
It's a horrible time in the Scooby-Doo universe.
The Scooby-Doo lore is crazy.
Yeah, yeah, whenever it starts raining, we just run out
there with our hands above our heads.
And just tough it out.
Or just never go outside when it's raining.
Oh, I started digging here.
Well, well, thank you for the raid.
Thank you.
I hope you had a good stream
Oh my god, my food's here.
Wait, give me a sec.
Oh god, fuck.
Okay, it's okay.
The king man can't Doesn't deal with how I grab them grab my
food.
I'll be right back Okay, I hope he doesn't kill me.
All right, we're fine.
Okay, I'll be right back my food got here
Man, it's a good thing.
He's he's he's down here and we're up here
Yeah, jumping wasn't invented yet back in the back in the
caveman days.
They didn't know how to jump guys Jumping was a unique
concept that wasn't invented yet And who's he's up here and
we're down there and who's the show Man,
I love the movie tag games my favorite was T.
Tanya Tari Let's get it.
Let's...
Alright.
Ooh, I ordered a lot of food.
I'm hungry.
I haven't had lunch yet.
I woke up after my nine-hour stream, and I was like, oh,
fuck.
What's this?
Oh, he gave me free chocolates.
Nice.
Alright, let's try this real quick.
Oh!
I decided to be a little wild order ramen I usually don't do
it because like I they did separate the ramen and like the
noodles and the soup I usually don't do it I don't risk it
just because like I hate I hate it when the noodles get a
little too soggy but I risk it because it's a good ramen
place
And sushi.
I got sushi too.
Yeah.
I have to mix it together myself, which I'm fine with.
Oh!
They fucked it up.
I said I wanted an extra extra tasu because I had chicken
tasu.
So I wanted tasu with it too.
It's fine.
I've been having really bad luck with Uber.
Uber eats.
I've accepted it.
It's just life now.
We'll never escape the wrong order food, Yasha.
Alright, let's party the soup in.
There we go.
I hope the soup is.
It's so show you
That's a lot of soup That's a lot of soup.
Oh my god.
It's oh shit I got splash damage I was like trying to I was
trying to like take the katsu Pick up the katsu and it's a
slash Give me a sec.
Come on.
You just want to mix it.
Oh my god, this katsu is so chunky.
Yeah, I have to take the katsu out.
It's so fucking chunky.
Oh my god, there you go.
Okay.
Trying to mix the noodles right now.
Because the noodles are all stuck together.
Just want to mix it.
Oh my god, I took the katsu out and I lost it.
half my soup.
Like, the distribution.
The katsu was that heavy.
Like, the soup.
I thought it was like, I poured the soup and it was like,
cold.
And I took the katsu out and, like, because there's a giant
block of katsu.
Because it's a cheese katsu.
It's cheese chicken katsu.
And then the moment I took it out, like, the entire block
was, like, half the soup was gone.
The water level.
It's okay.
I had more soup.
I was like, wow.
They gave me a lot of soup.
I was already full.
Wow.
I usually don't eat on stream, but I'm really hungry.
Because I have not.
I have not had lunch yet.
And it is 429.
Oh, shit.
Oh, you guys are having good food today.
If not, I hope you guys treat yourself.
and tomorrow for some good-ass food or for dinner.
Treat yourself.
Scooby is so scared.
He's like eternal torture.
Oh, no.
Noinks.
Hmm.
Treat yourself.
I love that.
I love Parks and Rec.
It's my motto.
Always remember to treat yourself.
Hmm.
I'll take a few more bites and then we'll go back to gaming.
Yeah, treat yourself now.
Now I've been craving ramen for a while too.
Because I haven't tabbed.
There's like a German Christmas market that's going on in my
city.
They hold it every year.
And they try to find a good time to go.
Because I don't want to go during like Christmas week, you
know?
I'd be like, oh, I don't want to go during Christmas week
because that's going to be fucking hell.
I love those.
I hear like a lot of places do it.
I went there last year and I didn't get to eat.
I didn't get to try a lot of the food.
I want to try more.
Because I like, as stupid as I came in there, like, already
eaten and stuff.
went there during like dinner time but I was like oh I
should just not eat in the whole day so I could save my
entire stomach for the German market hmm
that schnitzels and everything too
yeah I want to go there again but I need to go there like
not during Christmas week what's
a German Christmas market
I know what it's actually called.
It's basically like it's really cute I saw like other places
do it too like um people like places around like in and a
they like do these German markets It's basically like it's
really cute like they're like little hat like the the stalls
have like they're like wooden like wooden German
architecture Yeah, crystal chris clean market and it's like
super cute because it's like these like wooden German
architectures and everything like each stall and there's
like you can get like um obviously it's like a market so
like get christmas stuff and also like other types of like
arts like artisan thing i guess like it's like artisan um
like people like local sellers we sell their things too and
then then it's like just the food is so good like i know i
don't know like for your city's christmas markets um german
christmas markets but the food is so fucking good too yeah
There's like cute dessert places too for it.
Right?
Mm-hmm.
And there's Santa.
Santa for the kids.
Oh my god.
I guess I've ever seen the Krampus.
What's it called?
The Krampus Festival.
Where like the fucking outfits are literally demon tier.
I feel like...
NA did that, I think children would actually cry.
Bro, it's crazy.
The Krampus Festivals.
Yeah, it's so fucking metal.
That shit is metal as hell.
I will say, children nowadays are super callable.
I feel like...
I feel like parents now...
Um...
I think it's because, okay, this is my theory.
It's that, like, a lot of kids, a lot of parents now grew up
with, like, really bad parenting in a way where, like, they
felt like their parents, like, they felt like their parents,
uh, um, what's the word?
We're really neglectful of them.
So when they became parents, they're like, I'm not going to
be, like, my mom.
care for my child i would pay attention to them and um and
spend time with them but then they ended up being like super
caught the child ends being like super caught on and um yeah
and like like too much attention given to the child and
everything and making sure like oh um and making him super
sheltered okay i will say i think that's why I was super
sheltered because that's what happened to my that's what
happened to my mom her mom was like like neglectful to her
when she was growing up because she had like two two younger
brothers so like for those who don't know in asia cultures
like uh sons were highly valued over daughters so because of
that um she had to take care of like you know she had to be
like the babysitter of the brothers and like the brothers
were treated a lot better than her so when she got older and
she like when she had me she was like I'm not gonna be like
my mom I'm gonna treat her and I ended up being super
fucking sheltered and yeah I ended up being super sheltered
and I didn't know the real world because of that just like
she's like I'm not gonna do the things my mom sure if my
child gets all the attention and everything and now i don't
and then i the first time i've ever touched the kitchen
stove was when i was 18.
and then i had to learn everything at college by myself yeah
yeah
i was allowed to touch the kitchen stove or the oven i think
because they think i would like i don't know burn the house
down or something
Yeah, I'm not gonna be a bad mom like my mom.
And it went from one end to the next.
Yeah, it went from one extreme end to the next extreme end.
And you learn Katzdan.
Yummy.
Thank you, the super chat, Patrick.
Thank you, thank you.
Yeah, but Jackie Chan worked at your corner source.
Australia would be okay.
One, two, three, four.
Thank you, the super chat.
Thank you, thank you.
Thank you.
I think like the new generation of children are Are way too
Clouded Way too clouded and like And like Oh, it's not
independent at all Oh, and the fact that they are iPad A lot
of them are iPad kids too A lot of them are iPad kids So it
actually rots their brains They're not actually Practicing
critical thinking Because apparently studies are coming out
That AI AI and chat GPT is like actually making us think
less critically now.
We're actually going backwards and developing our brain.
Like our brains are technically sort of getting smaller now
because we're not critically thinking anymore.
Yeah.
I think that's crazy.
So we're not like actually thinking for ourselves.
And also, there's that, what's it called?
Tocomelon.
It's really bad.
Because I talked about this before.
But, um, you kids' content now, it's all brain rot.
Because they're like, you don't need it.
Because, like, you know, you know, back then we had, like,
Teletubbies, Sesame Street, um, Between the Lions.
Shit like that.
Like, we're educational shows.
But, like, kids, now, they just go on YouTube or go on
Roblox and because of that a lot of them are like YouTube
slop or like kids slop so they're not like actually like
educational for children for to develop their brain and Coco
Lemon a Coco Melon I talked about it for it but for those
who haven't heard about this before Coco Melon actually
makes your kids more stupid it actually makes your child
dumber if you make them watch Coco Lemon or Coco Coco Melon
yeah Look, I told you guys, I literally sit next to a child
and a father and she had like a fucking music video playing
in the corner of her fucking iPad, like those kids' iPads,
while playing a Roblox game.
And I was like, how do you pay attention to that?
I was like, it's like those memes where like the silver
surfer is in the corner.
Bro, something was fake.
That's what she was doing.
I was like, Jesus Christ.
It's not a meme.
It's actual real life.
I was like, it's actual real ass life.
That they're doing that.
I thought it was just a funny meme.
Alright, subway surfer.
No, but it was like on the corner.
It was on the corner.
I don't watch this when I'm gaming.
I do work like I eat like I play videos when I'm eating
I can't even listen to music while I play rank I don't know
how people do it I personally can't it distracts me way too
much and you and you a guy he's like top 500 and Overwatch
he doesn't even play with audio I don't know how he does it
he like he doesn't even play with audio he has the audio off
and just has like a tv show on the side like a youtube video
or or someone else's stream on the second monitor while he
plays overwatch top 500 with no audio he's just like i don't
need audio i know what's going on yeah i was like bro what
the but
i could not do that but also like i feel like top 500
players and pro players like there's a huge gap between the
two i was like i don't know you guys saw a clip of faker
doing the stopwatch test because when you're pro player you
gotta be aware of so many things including like cooldowns
and everything through sheer instinct like keeping track of
enemy cooldowns and everything so like there was a clip of
faker being like can you stop the time like stopwatch
through pure instinct um at five seconds like just to like
internally count like internally realize like when when you
have to stop like when it would be five seconds because he
has to be like when you're a pro in league um or just pro
player in general you have to like be able to be aware of
counting down enemy cooldowns and everything so you know
like when they don't have cooldowns so so he literally was
like yeah i could do that and he got the stopwatch looked at
camera stopped at exactly 5.00 seconds like exactly it was
crazy i was
like that's and then like i asked my pro friends i was like
can you guys do that because i was curious so i asked like a
couple of pros i was like um i was like wait screen share
and uh close your eyes and click the stopwatch they're not
as good as faker but it was like four point it was like 4.9
something or like 5.0 like it would be like one it'll be
like 0.0 something seconds off but it's not like faker where
he gets it exact i was like Jesus, like 5.0, exactly.
Like, my friends, they would, like, be, like, 0.something
off.
It was still pretty, like, cool.
It's still pretty cool to see.
Like, being able to get it around there.
But 5.0 is, like, insane.
It's, like, inhumane.
I swear, he was grown in a test.
He was grown in a test tube to play league.
I swear to God.
They were like, we must create the ultimate being for League
of Legends.
I...
The perfect league player, yeah.
Bro.
I heard that he's gonna meet the president soon, too.
And they might talk about, like...
I was like, oh my god.
That's crazy.
exempt from the army just so he could play more league like
getting exemptions for like pro players for league players
yeah he's gonna meet like the press yeah because he's giving
a lot of clout and stuff like a lot of attention to Korea
because he is the best league player in the world and I saw
an article saying like saying like he's there might be talks
of like talks of him with him and the to try and see, like,
like, the players, I guess, like, for League, to be exempt
from, to be exempt from the army, so they can keep bringing
more medals for League.
Yeah, he served his own, in his own way, yeah.
Yeah, they give a super chat, thank you.
Yeah, because it brings a lot of attention to Korea, too,
like, what he does.
Right?
Yeah, he's just that good.
Bro, how old is Faker anyway?
Also, like, they're often not doing it in a way because
unfair.
I think it's also because, like, for BTS,
I think it's also because, like, they think, like, yeah,
like, they want to make...
They don't want to, like, look bad, you know?
I guess it's, like, different circumstances, too.
And everything.
Hmm.
he's like 29
I read in an article that all the players that Faker used to
fight with like not fight but like burst with like all the
his like arch like his rivals back then they're all coaches
now and he's still gaming I thought that was funny like
Like, his rivals that he versed over the years all became
coaches of big teams.
But he's still actually playing.
Yeah, he's still going.
And that's interesting.
And he still got it.
Bro, he's going to be, like, those basketball players.
Where...
Yeah, kids of, like...
I swear, his kids are going to get scouted.
Whatever he settles down, his kids are going to get scouted.
like basketball players like basketball player kids
right that's gonna be crazy no it's gonna be genetic because
it's all hand-knit coordination if he gets kids
when that's like esports retirement it depends on the esport
it depends on the game there's some players that are like 35
plus and still pro a random wide eye expression from your
skin so he kills me every damn time see you think of this
super chat thank you thank you
sorry guys I'm still eating I just didn't eat lunch at all
so I'm hungry
but it's like a Valorant place
those children the kids from like Valorant couples going
places from I swear I think Valorant is the only esport that
I've seen we're like both because like there's a very big
female pro scene too in Valorant and like I swear like I
feel like Valorant is like the only esport I've seen where
like um where like a lot of the Valant pros just date each
other and like because like the top Valorant pros are
literally just it's the next generation of gamers like no
not apex because there's not really a lot of female a pro
like there's no pro circuit for female apex players i mean
there is but it's not like that big but there's a very big
valorant pro circuit for female players as i know because
i've seen like i've seen like the top like you know team
like the top valorant teams for like guys and girls it's
just all like You see the Twitter profiles, you click on it,
and it's really, like, another pro.
Oh, my God.
I read the, there's, like, this, the, there was a, I don't
keep up with Valorant, but it's all my for you.
But, yeah, it's the dating game.
But, and that was really funny.
But there was a, there was, like, a women's tournament for
Valorant recently, like, a really big one.
And I think it was, like, Brazilian team.
They were talking about the stats of the Brazilian team.
And apparently, the top fragger, the best in the tournament,
the best player is on the Brazilian team.
The best, like, Valorant player for that tournament was on
the Brazilian team.
And then the worst player on that tournament was also on the
Brazilian team.
And apparently, they were both dating.
Some people are like, wow, it's crazy.
The worst player.
This is the first time the worst player and the best player.
player are a couple like in the same tournament
yeah it like balanced it out
very it balanced it out I thought it was funny like stat
wise basically
I think they won the tournament too i still think like it is
wild though like i think it is i personally think dating
inside when you're a part of some a team and you're dating
the players in the team it's like it's scary because it's
like the dynamics for that as a team as itself is so bad i
feel because you it's like the whole like never date your
co-worker shit it's literally that It's a bad idea.
Like, I was like, that's risky as fuck.
And someone's like, the power of love.
God, deep synergy.
Bro.
But when you get an argument, I've seen this happen.
I talked about this before.
But...
I've seen this before as a spectator.
That's crazy.
I won't mention which game it was.
But...
I was watching I was watching a scrim um and the couple was
fighting during practice and the rest of the team was just
silent it was so uncomfortable and I was just watching too I
wasn't even part of the team or anything I was just watching
and and like the couple was just like hard fighting each
other and like the rest of the team said nothing and we're
just sitting there and was Like, what the fuck do we do?
I was just like, oh my god.
That's so uncomfortable.
And I asked my friend, I was like, bro, what the fuck?
Like, is this, is this like common?
And then my friend was like, yeah, no, this happens like
almost every scream.
And I'm like, bro, that's a terrible environment.
like like their friend was like yeah like yeah so
they're like mom and dad's fighting and you're just like in
your room with your headphones I'd be like everything is
okay it's okay I guess what up you guys want to play game
you guys
Yeah, put the headphones on.
Pretend everything is okay.
Okay, I'm almost done, guys.
This game has been running for a very long time.
Why is it wrong to date if playing pro?
But okay.
It's like, I meant like if you are...
It's like in a team environment.
Because you're both...
Because like, you can't really...
You have biases in the team.
So if you're in a pro play, even in sports, pro play...
work as well there are biases and there's favoritism going
in um so that's what's wrong because like you know yeah
there's conflicts of interest and everything so like and
then if if if they break up you can't just leave the team
because there's con if you're contracted and you break up
you can't just leave the team because you're contracted to
play until like the end of your contract so obviously that
fucks with synergy too yeah like you know you got play on
the team with like you know your ex so the put that the
drama is too high yeah it's very awkward
yeah that's one thing that's the risk that's the riskiest
part even during like the day Part two but You know if you
criticize One of the players You know one of the couples
Like obviously their partner Is gonna hard defend them
Because I've seen that happen before So one time I've seen
it happen before Like one of my friends told me about it But
There was a couple on the team And every time they criticize
One of the players Like in the couple The other player will
hard defend them Being like No What they're doing What's not
their fault like they're doing okay so the other player
would never learn because like the other what like they
always have someone defending them being like so they'll
never learn to be better because like they always had
someone be like no you're doing great you're doing it's not
you it's not you it's like the team or like it's something
else so there's always like that coming in too so that's why
i think like like like never date your co-worker is like
very important
It just discourages feedback and criticism, too.
That's why, like, that's the whole thing.
Wow.
I said they never learn.
Now, what about the drag wounds dating each other or dating,
insert, bad name, rest in peace with Mr. Broken Bonding.
Thank you, the super chat.
I suggested some names, too.
I was like, you guys should be called boobies.
you know boo or boobers I was like oh my god what do we guys
call boobers or boobies
I thought it was funny or the boobus
very choice yeah because it's boo you know boo they're like
they're like mince little boobies that's so good obviously
she said no I said that during like we were setting up for
the main cafe
he's like shut the fuck up Yoki I'm like fair I think it's a
great name I think boobers is also good
yeah and then like whisk boob goons can be boob goons
boogoons boogoons you know
as a vtuber fan a lot of vtuber vtuber don't have fandom
names I don't know if you guys noticed that especially those
who are like more um there's some like I think it's a I
think especially on Twitch, a lot of Twitch F YouTubers, I
think I'll be specific.
A lot of Twitch F YouTubers don't really have fandom names.
Because it was like, fandom names I think was like, um,
started because of, uh, because of JP's side of like, uh,
with JP.
But when like the Western side of YouTubers started going,
there wasn't really fandom name stuff before.
Yeah, Twitch YouTubers normally don't have them.
It makes it more, it makes it more like a community.
And I like that.
Alright, I just finished eating, guys.
Sorry, this was a long intermission.
I just wanted to finish my food.
It was a nice hangout, you know?
Nice little intermission.
I'm just chatting.
But everyone on Twitch has a cute name for the channel
points and subscription.
Patreus, thank you for the super chat.
Thank you.
yeah it's like i don't know it's something like it's just
twitch things it's just i don't know how to say it it's just
twitch things twitch is like a whole different world even
though i know i started on twitch first but still like back
then i was a twitch streamer and i called we had bark nights
before but that was just me copying hollow lab en that's
just me when you know first debut and i was like oh i should
do stuff like that you know so i was like okay guys we're
gonna be called the park nights now back
when like they first debuted and everything
all right let's go let's play now he's been he's so tired
the king man is so very die.
It's fine.
I grabbed a sandwich right here.
I have no idea what that pushes.
I'll go upstairs.
Oh, shit!
Okay, that's fine.
I can take these.
Alright, up we go.
So I'm slowly...
Oh my god, I fucking coursey's here.
Guys, it's okay.
I'm slowly rebuilding the economy, guys.
I'm starting a new savings fund.
I legitimately don't even remember like half things I talked
during the food.
Oh, no, I don't have a lot of HP now.
I will say, I actually don't remember half the things I
talked about.
Oh, shit!
I looked, okay, okay, it's fine, it's fine, we're fine.
Wait, does it go back up?
Oh, do I have to press that button?
I have to press the button again, okay.
Oh, wait, no, it goes back up, right?
What is he even supposed to be doing?
Do I have to?
Oh my god, I think I do.
Oh my god.
I have to race.
Are you fucking kidding me?
Okay,
I have to race.
I have to race against this stupid thing.
I don't even know what I'm supposed to do here.
Okay.
I'm going as fast as I can!
Four legs can take me.
Okay, we're almost there.
Okay, now what?
Oh, okay.
Oh, I have to break it.
Super...
Oh, I got super smashed.
Okay.
After jumping and smashed that.
I got the super smashed now.
Am I supposed to be here?
Oh, thank God.
Okay, okay.
me up.
Okay, that's good.
I thought I broke the game.
Alright, nice.
Alright, um...
Alright, it doesn't move.
That's cool.
Alright, where do I go?
Scooby?
Oh, I can use Fight enemies too?
Oh, it doesn't work on this guy?
Alright, let's try it.
Oh, it does!
Wait, that's good.
Okay.
Another mechanic I can use.
I think that is more... That one It's definitely more
reliable.
Yeah, it's 100% more reliable.
God damn, I cannot get the spooky stacks.
Yeah, I like that more.
I like that more than the goddamn fucking head bash.
It's so inconsistent.
It's so hard to control the head bash.
Okay.
Alright, I don't think I can afford this.
Oh.
No, I'm poor.
I'm so poor.
Scooby-Doo!
The Scooby-Sack economy didn't work so well for us.
Okay, but what does that do?
What the fuck did I do there?
We're homeless.
I don't know what this is doing, either.
We're one-way shortcut to the courtyard outside of Mystic
Manor.
Oh, my God.
Okay, we gotta backtrack.
We gotta go back.
We gotta grab all the Scooby snacks.
I thought I had it all.
Oh, it activated this.
It's okay.
We can make it.
Yeah, it's this.
I just noticed it.
Alright.
When I go back, there's a lot of Scooby Snacks I missed out
on here.
Yeah, no, I need a lot of them.
I don't even know where, which ones I...
Where I left majority of...
Oh, shit!
That's fine.
Alright, we got this.
It's fine.
There's a lot of sandwiches all around.
Okay.
Where is the shadow?
Where is the deaf perception?
Oh my god, we're in.
Okay, I got it.
I found it.
Yes.
You don't understand.
I couldn't find...
No!
Slap dunked into the ocean.
Right, right.
Are you fucking kidding me?
it's fine oh my god everything got reset
all right we gotta grab the sandwich though if i can find it
okay there you go all right yeah there's so much more no
don't don't don't don't don't do this to me okay we made it
okay those plus two That plus two adds up, okay?
The plus two adds up a lot.
All right.
We gotta figure it out.
Okay, we are here.
It's a warp game.
Oh, my God.
We are here.
Okay, there you go.
Where the fuck am I?
Where's this place?
How did I get here?
Okay.
Okay, there's some here.
I know I left a lot at the fishing area.
There must be more.
Okay, there must be.
Yeah, I knew it.
There's some here.
Oh,
no.
Oh, no.
Scooby, you're gonna drown.
Okay, we're fine.
We're fine.
Everything is fine.
Dog did not drown.
I'll get up there.
Okay, nice.
all right 200 to go just just 200 to go guys
all right i'm sorry toky opening i bought 40 of the scooby
snack production prices have already tripled no marsha thank
you for the super chat thank you thank you Not the Scooby
Snack production!
They stopped selling it to the people!
Now the Scooby Snacks is only reserved for the developers of
OpenAI.
Dogs.
Also, I guess the devs too.
It's only reserved for the dogs of the devs.
In OpenAI.
No, they don't need that.
We gotta go to that one area.
It's like, is it back here?
It might be back here.
Okay, I gotta save.
Must be back here.
Pop the bubble, Scooby.
You gotta do it.
Oh, this is like an extra jump, too.
Which is nice.
I wonder if it's like...
I knew it.
I fucking knew it.
I don't know what that did, but I knew it.
I knew there was stuff there.
Oh my god, I could do double jumps here.
Yeah, I left a lot of...
I left way too many treats.
Is it this?
Okay, I assume that...
I pushed the button!
What the fuck?
Fuck did the button open?
Oh, round one.
The fuck did the button- oh, it's this.
Okay, that makes more sense.
All right, that's a lot.
No!
I need those snacks.
Please, I need those snacks.
You're gonna take the kids!
They're gonna take the kids if I don't pay for my Scooby
Snacks.
Okay.
This reminds me of the infamous Crash Bandicoot Lover.
A bridge lover.
Okay.
That spot is close enough.
It's close enough
Wait unless There is like three more down there Bro,
you gotta be like you gotta have like the reflexes of a
fucking adult to play this game.
I swear to God
The brain power and The IQ and the reflexes of an adult
No wonder I like never progressed.
No wonder I was stuck in that one area.
I literally only got to one area in this game.
But for some reason I still love the game.
Alright, there you go.
I got the monster token.
Alright, there has to be more Scooby Snacks back there.
Yeah, kids were definitely built different.
But, uh, pro, they give a super chat.
Thank you.
Yeah, kid meat had no chance.
Oh my god.
I forgot all about these boxes.
Guys, I forgot about these boxes, guys.
The pile is like, don't worry, guys.
I don't need to grab these snacks.
It'll be fine.
I will need them.
All these boxes.
Okay, we're close.
Wait, there's like one snack up there.
What's over here?
What is this open?
What the fuck did that open?
That stop out the box?
Oh, I stopped all the boxes.
Oh, you guys use Chico's.
Smart.
I didn't...
The only Chico's I ever used in a video game was for Heroes
of Might and Magic.
And for those who never played that game, it's just like
a...
I know, you're like, how were you playing that as a kid?
It was my dad's hand me, though, because he loved it.
And then he had, like, a little paper written.
Yeah, like, those, like, you know, the paper strat where you
write all the Chico's.
on a piece of paper.
So he had that.
He had that.
And he had all the cheats for heroes of might and magic
where he can just give like...
So there's like a...
So in the game, you're supposed to like build like it's like
a tactical thing, like a tactical game.
And you're supposed to...
Oh my god, how do I get that?
And they have that to build like a fucking army and stuff.
Each turn you're supposed to like...
How do I get up there?
you're supposed to like build up your army and then fight
other armies but then it's my dad instead of like building
an army he just goes he uses the strongest fucking unit as
for the cheat code which is just all angels and it literally
one-shots things and that's how you played the game he
literally oh my god how the fuck do i get the snack
This is the shadow.
Look, look, look, look, look.
Look, you can see it.
You can see the shadow right here.
Why?
Okay.
And it's just, it's just all angels.
I don't even remember the cheat code for it, but...
He did that and then he like...
And then he got bored of the game, so it was like a
hand-me-down to me, and then I start...
And he gave it to me to play with all the...
with all the chicas and everything how do i get that look at
all those snacks oh it's like this oh never mind i figured
it out who would have thought there's a thought about using
your 3d there's 3d in my 3d platformers guys that's crazy 3d
in my 3d platform
Okay, I'm almost there.
Oh my god, I'm so close to getting.
600.
Okay, this stupid fucking crab is in the way.
Oh my god, I have the umbrella here.
This would have been great.
We are close.
We're making it.
We're gonna make it.
Okay.
I'll grab these two.
Oh my god, just 20 more.
Just 20 more.
I can see the finish line.
Okay, I can only grab up these two because I don't have a
goddamn umbrella.
Okay.
I didn't go this way.
So maybe...
Whoa!
You found a one-way shortcut.
back to the courtyard god damn it wait that's good actually
if i get oh my god wait that's good okay wait that's good i
can use that and then use the fast travel but i want to be
sure i don't know what's over here first wait was this uh
wait i've never been here where does this go
oh wait i have been here what the fuck i came from there
100 now.
Okay, we could use the shortcut.
Wait, no.
What the fuck?
Wait.
Oh, wait, I have.
Oh, I can double kill him?
Oh, my God.
Oh!
How how to death percept?
My greatest enemy.
That's good.
I know now, though.
I know now.
He can bleed.
Okay, we don't need those.
It's okay.
We figured it out.
He can absolutely bleed.
Okay, but what's over here?
Bill's Boat Club.
Okay, we're just going here now.
Just full kill them.
We gotta get as much of the Scooby Snacks as we can.
We gotta rebuild the savings, guys.
Yummy.
What the fuck is over here?
Wait, this is back where I came from.
Oh, the fuck?
Yeah, this is a circle.
God.
It's okay.
I wanted to be here because I wanted to.
Alright, we figured it out.
A Scooby Snack is a Scooby Snack, guys.
Whoa.
Scooby-snack is a Scooby-snack.
Gotta take what we can get in this economy.
Alright.
It's okay.
Alright, then we can get back to...
It's this way, right?
Yeah, we want to go back to the Mystic Matter anyway.
The courtyard.
Oh, we're back in the courtyard.
all right and then we have the tp all right where the fuck
was that place i took it first off does anyone know where
we're in was it here it was here right i don't remember
where it was called this is not a very good map god damn it
what the fuck was it It was the lighthouse, right?
I think it was.
Okay, we're here.
Oh my god, we're not here.
Where am I?
It was here.
Lighthouse, first house.
Oh my god, we did it.
Alright, we did it.
Alright.
We found it.
There's my life savings.
Patroas and Ava's Super Chat.
Thank you.
There was this retro game called A.
of empires too and there was a cheat that let you summon a
card that had two machine guns let's feel just play with the
funny cards instead of play i mean if i if it was during the
roman times and i could have a car with a machine gun i can
you really blame them can you really blame them it was a car
with machine guns though yeah
all right let's see oh my god how could you say no to gun oh
my god i thought like there was a hole there how how do i
okay how do i dodge that wait what you gotta a cookie's a
cookie
oh you want to think uh pokemon thank you a super chat that
you think what would you do with a scooby snack all right i
don't want to risk dying down there okay how the fuck do i
do this without i guess it's the bubbles right is bubbles
dangerous has to be the bubbles yeah it's the bubbles
but shaggy so like I don't think I don't think the Scooby
snack is gonna tempt me guys oh shit what was he in prison
for oh raggy I'm sorry I didn't know what you would talk
about how did you get locked up he's locked up for his
crimes oh my Oh, you're not going to help Raggy?
Alright, grab this for me.
I didn't expect to see Shaggy locked up in a goddamn
dungeon.
Everybody says that until they have a Scooby Snack in front
of them.
That's true.
Oops.
Sorry.
I got a key.
Oh my god, I'm at the secret lab.
What's this?
I gotta get that.
This way to the...
Okay.
And how do I get up to the secret laboratory?
Thank you.
Come on, get over here.
Did you get it?
Did you get it, Shaggy?
It's a secret.
Oh, my God.
Okay, where do I have to backtrack now?
I'm so lost with all the backtracking.
I don't even know where I...
Okay, there's a door here.
Never mind.
I don't know where to go.
There's a door.
Oh, my God.
Not the goddamn swinging axe.
It's a classic.
Axe swinging Can I kill a ghost?
Oh no, I can't It's crazy, apparently you can't kill a ghost
What can you kill?
That's already undead
What's this?
You just found the Oh my god He invented plunges Okay, Steve
said Oh my god, what is this universe?
We didn't even have plungers until now?
What?
Every time you clog the toilet, you just gotta buy a new
toilet, guys.
This is that rough.
It was really up rough back then.
It was really...
That's crazy.
Guys, you don't understand.
Every time, every time you clogged up the toilet, it's just
too bad.
You gotta buy a new toilet, guys.
I'll make the rules Oh my god I have no bubble abilities
It's suction cup man I where do I go
Because I'm so lost I feel like I've backtracked so much
This map is more confusing
thing like where am i creepy crawlies in the hallways okay
okay who remembers how to play this game
go back to the dungeon there was a what there was a wall in
the dungeon and we have no idea either I have
to go to the mountain side where I got the fucking helmet.
When did that happen?
I'm in the dungeon now.
That's fine.
I do it this way.
Okay, it's fine.
It's just a pit.
It's just just the endless pit.
I mean, maybe there's like...
We're gonna try and find the teleporter.
Oh my god, we're gonna go all the way down here.
Shortcut!
It's fine.
We'll take those.
Where am I?
I'm so confused.
Oh Head over and over to the helmet helmet mountain where
the fuck is helmet mountain?
Okay, we're gonna figure this out guys We got hedge maze
helmet mountain.
Okay We're at the hedge maze now Is it chills and spills on
the haunted hills?
and a skull okay is that a real word is that okay oh there
you go there we go there you go we found it scared stiff i'm
like are you like is this aad did you aad gender oh there
you go scared i found it scared stiff at skull at skull
cliff i found it it's really literally right here right here
i was like what the is that title bro wasn't lying it
literally called that
can you blame me that that looks so ai generated like the
title of that
oh yeah i grab as many spooky snacks as possible hello Where
the fuck is the button for this?
Yeah, back in the day, that was normal.
Oh, I gotta go down there, yo.
I was so confused.
I was like, where the fuck do I go?
Oh, I was like, okay.
I was gonna die there.
Scooby was, like, I'm living on life support just now.
Right?
I got that crab out of here.
Grab that scrooby snack.
Oh, wait.
Okay, I got double for that to full kill the crab.
There you go.
And I get kicked!
Yeah!
Okay, what is this open?
Okay, that opens that.
And then now I have to backtrack all the way to the other
side of this goddamn hill.
I'm Doki.
Actually, it's called Cliff.
Oh my god.
Back to the other side now.
Now I figure out how to get down there.
And grab the Scooby Snack.
Oh my god.
I'm rebuilding.
220.
That's fine.
I will say.
Why did the Scooby Snack?
led to the fucking abyss.
No, no, no, no.
We all saw the Scooby Snacks, guys.
Oh, my God.
I have to do a button again.
I have to do that button.
The Scooby Snack led us all the way down.
It was like, jump this way.
I was like, oh, okay, maybe it's another pathway.
Oh, my God.
I have to push that button again.
Test of your greed.
It was truly the final test.
Yeah, we need that sandwich anyway.
Oh my god.
That's actually so bullshit.
Alright, here we go.
I definitely...
There was no way Kid Doki was figuring any of this out.
There was no...
There was no way...
Oh my god, I almost jumped off again.
Oh my god.
Okay, we wait.
There we go, we wait.
There we go.
We made it.
Enter.
I know it says do not enter, but we enter.
Whoops.
Alright, nice.
Free cake.
okay there has to be like a pathway there that hasn't
spawned in yet because i have to press a goddamn button okay
it's button time oh shit okay oops oh god okay it's fine we
made it we made it
all right next jump jump scooby jump oh shit whoops she
didn't see me though yeah like how the fuck am I supposed to
get across that oh oh that's an umbrella spot god damn I
figured out how to fucking invent umbrellas now all right
Yeah, I might need like 600 cookies or some shit.
Most likely.
For the next cookie spot.
Oh, we made it.
Oh, there's a goddamn...
I see you.
God damn it, no umbrellas.
The world is so cruel.
The Scooby-Doo world is so cruel.
and someone please start inventing things again was there
like a law like scientists are forbidden to invent stuff is
that why we don't have blunders umbrellas and fucking rain
boots it's a crime it's a crannly crime when it's raining
you just gotta toughen it out with wet shoes
Yes, I can't believe it's a crime.
The other side.
You're too busy inventing ghost costumes.
How do I?
How do I get...
Oh my god, it was up top.
It was...
I was like, where's the platform?
Of course the platform was up top.
Right?
Nice.
Cake time.
Okay.
Alright.
This place is so dangerous.
No wonder no one.
No wonder only one person lives up here.
What's over here?
Okay.
I gotta find a button!
No!
Oh my god.
No, I'm all the way back here.
No!
Oh my god.
So I was talking about crossovers.
I think my favorite Scooby-Doo crossover was with
Supernatural.
That's crazy that they were able to get Scooby-Doo, like,
Wonder Brothers to agree to that.
Scooby-Doo is Wonder Brothers, right?
But the Scooby-Doo, because it's crazy because, like, Um,
you know how they're like, Velma's like, ghosts aren't
silly, ghosts aren't real.
Like, that's just a guy pretending to play dead.
And then it's literally a dead man in the bed.
And she, like, touches like, oh my god, it's a real dead
body.
And then they all start screaming and be like, oh my god.
Ghosts are real.
Like, it literally, literally blew the Scooby-Doo gang's
mind.
They're like, wait, they're like, what?
Ghost turned real though And then Velma had like a fucking
nervous breakdown Cause like Everything she knew was a
fucking lie Like It was a really good episode
And then it's like the Scooby-Doo gang Like found an actual
real dead body And like Jackie has a fucking panic attack
Cause he's like That's oh god Zoic system is he's dead Yeah
got to yeah and then and a shaggy breaks an arm and he's
like wait because like um physics exists now because they do
a crossover with supernatural so then physics exists and a
shaggy breaks his arm and he's like what this never happens
before he's
like i've done this i've never broken an arm before how is
this possible
How many physics exists now?
Their whole world blew up.
Oh yeah, and John Cena exists in the Supernatural, in the
Scooby-Doo lore.
He's a real person.
Because back then, they used to do crossovers with real
people.
Oh my god.
So like, John Cena exists in the Scooby-Doo land.
The Scooby-Doo universe.
Yeah, he like jumps out.
He's like, he's like, I feel like.
jumped out of a plane before and this never happened.
But yeah, I jump out of a window and I break arm?
Question mark?
Oh my god, that was crazy.
Like, it actually, like, I got an eye frame in the water.
Wait, I gotta get 600.
Wait, it's back here?
Wait, there was...
It was like an island.
Here.
How the fuck do I get to the island?
Oh my god.
Like how?
How do I know which one's the island area?
Wait, it's the water coming back up.
Guys, the water's coming back up.
The water came back.
Okay, where does the fucking...
Okay, that's not worth it.
fuck that that's not worth it i'm going back okay i'm going
i'm going grab the scooby snack i'm going never never mind
never mind guys all right here we go
uh dookie what happened to it not being worth it but now i
had to get 550 scooby snacks
Oh my god.
Okay, we gotta figure out a place to farm more Scooby
Snacks, guys.
Okay.
Where can I have get more Scooby Snacks?
All right.
I know it's Smuggles Cobra.
I left a lot of Scooby Snacks.
Maybe here?
Yeah, it's here.
Okay.
We gotta...
We gotta grab the tiny ones now.
It's here.
Oh my god.
I have to grab the tiny ones too.
I'm so poor.
What the fuck?
How the fuck do I get up there?
Like, what?
Okay, there's no way I'm getting over there.
God, I'm just like, I'm digging through that.
Oh, no.
I have to do this parkour shit, too.
All over again.
Oh, my God.
There's so many snacks over there.
There's so many.
I saw so many snacks over there.
I saw, like, the fucking problem is that.
Oh, my God.
All these snacks I overlooked.
Because I thought I thought I was better than this.
But I was wrong!
No one is better than this.
I was wrong.
I wasn't better than this.
All right.
Okay.
What the fuck?
How do I get over there?
Every Scooby-Doo snack counts.
God damn it.
I don't know where else to get Scooby snacks now.
Fuck.
Alright, we're going back.
We're going to start all the way back.
Yeah, no, we played the picnic game.
I'm on stream too.
Oh my god, it's all the way back.
It's all the way back there.
Okay, there might be Scooby snacks though, guys.
There might be Scooby Snacks all the way back.
We gotta go back.
It's okay.
Just a little...
A little unforced trauma doesn't hurt anyone.
God damn it.
Oh no, I'm one.
I'm one away.
This has to be the door.
Oh, thank God.
That's the door.
coast for some ghosts oh my god it's here it's here I went
so far back that's it I have to use the bathroom I'll be
right back guys go enjoy some Scooby Doo
I'm going to vacuum my floors after the stream.
I cleaned a little bit.
I accidentally, when I went to the bathroom, I hit my hand
on the tray that had the sushi, and it flipped over and the
lid came off.
So like, I did clean a bit.
I cleaned a bit with some tissues, but I'm going to get a
vacuum.
And a towel later.
Yeah.
I don't think a lot spilled, though.
Not a lot spilled out.
I finished the sushi.
It was just from the soy sauce.
Like the soy sauce and the...
And stuff.
So I just have to, like, vacuum a bit.
And then, like...
Get a towel or something.
Yeah.
No, I went, like, on my desk.
My PC desk.
Oh my god, this is hell.
The backtrack of the century.
I still...
Oh my god, I swear to god.
They...
They made this to fuck with people.
I swear to god.
They made that to fuck with you.
You're not supposed to be able to grab that Scooby Stack.
There's no way.
That Scooby Stack is unattainable.
No, just for any particles.
I want to grab the vacuum for any of the particles that, no.
Because I can't tell.
That's evil.
That's so evil.
I think I'm walking, I'm backtracking so far back to, like,
the original fishing place that I was at.
You know what game I really want to play?
I really want to play...
Where does this go again?
Oh, my God, it's all the way back there.
I remember that.
Was, what is it called?
The one where Nickelodeon did a huge crossover with Jimmy
Neutron, Danny Phantom, Timmy Turner, and SpongeBob.
I forgot what those games they're called.
I heard they were, I remember playing the first one, and
they were really fun.
I'm going all the way back.
Fuck this.
Nick, what's it called?
Nicktoons?
I don't know where to go I don't know I don't know where am
I not backtracked
this is torture like where am I not guys
where I got the where did I get the oh my god it's not
mystic bad Oh my god, no.
Not the Mystic Manor.
Was it the Mystic Manor where I got the boots?
I didn't know.
I thought I was so rich.
I thought I was fucking rolling in Scooby Snacks, guys.
How is I supposed to know?
The market was this bad.
Okay.
I didn't know the market became this terrible.
Oh my god, there has to be.
Oh, it's okay, it's just one.
It's Doki, they start.
It's just one.
Doesn't add up.
Okay.
It's fine.
Oh, my God.
There has to be a Scooby Snack somewhere.
Okay, there you go.
There you go.
Nice, nice, nice, nice.
We invented... We invented plungers in the universe now.
Okay, there is one.
Okay.
All right.
It's 550.
We're so close.
We're almost there.
We're actually so close.
I can see the finish line.
It was 550, right?
Or was it 600?
I can't.
I don't remember.
I know so many Scooby snacks.
I have to get so many scooby snacks.
The economy is so brutal.
There's one over here.
All right.
It's fine.
Wait, is this lit?
No, okay, it's just a regular platform.
Come on, go up.
Okay, 522, we're making it.
We're gonna make it.
Scooby.
Oh my god, wait.
Everyone counts.
Every single Scooby snack.
Is there any more up here?
Oh my god, what's that?
No, that's just soap.
That's just soap.
Maybe that's the last...
Guys, maybe that's the last room.
Guys.
No!
Okay.
It's okay.
I wanted to be down here so I can grab more Scooby Snack.
Yes.
It baited me so hard.
My god, that's a big scooby snack.
Oh my god, I'm making it.
Oh no, it's a wrong way.
What the fuck?
Okay, it's like a huge bait.
Like, there's no way I can get there.
There was no way.
No.
Okay.
Here.
That's fine.
I can slam dunk a witch.
We're here.
Okay, there's a portal here.
It's fine.
There's a portal next to me.
Okay.
This area.
Okay, there's a lot of Scooby Snacks here.
I remember.
There's a lot of them.
Okay, goodbye.
Goodbye, Scooby.
Where the- how the fuck do I?
Okay, there we go.
There's an ending here.
Okay, that's just a sandwich.
Where are all the goddamn Scooby snacks?
That's just a pit.
I'm literally too off please there has to be a fucking okay
oh my god there has to be someplace I could grab more okay
there you go oh thank god I found it
oh my god we made it we made it
Okay, and then, guys, watch this, guys.
Oh, wait, up I go.
What the fuck?
Where am I going?
Oh, shit.
Wait, that's new?
Oh, that's more Scooby.
It's okay, I got more.
Oh, what the fuck?
Oh, I got costume.
Hold down R2 to hide.
Oh, wait, this is better.
Oh.
We're upgraded from lampshades
Yeah, they'll never know all right now I just jump off Okay
now, okay, okay now now just jump off
Yeah, now I'm a monster too.
Okay now we can go back we have 550 This big All right
Okay.
Edge maze.
I think it was here.
Here we go.
We almost unlocked everything.
Alright, use your goddamn Scooby Snacks.
Oh, this has to be the last one, right, guys?
This has to be...
There's no way there's more Scooby Snacks, right?
I have four keys.
Baby Doki never stood a chance.
I don't know how Baby Doki would have done any of this.
Okay.
I'll get rid of all of these guys.
Then grab as many Scooby snacks as possible.
Oh, that is a crime.
The fact that like It's not like Standing distance at the
Scooby Snacks and I have to fucking Run, jump for it.
That Is a fucking crime.
You could have lowered it like Five more centimeters That
you could have like fucking arrow keyed it Five times.
This is a fucking crime.
You gotta make you work for it.
Yeah.
Oh my god I have to jump for all of this that's so fucked up
so i assume that's the door right yeah it is i need one more
key okay i thought it was like that other scoopy snack that
they forgot to key in the goddamn
you forgot to like key in the rest of the fucking scooby
snacks in okay let's escape fast
Oh Yeah, I have to scavenge it Every scooby snack matters
Yeah Oh this one oh that's no
I was gonna do a fucking I was gonna use it as a jump pad
Okay, I'll do it one more time I don't get I don't get it oh
my god i don't it's fine okay i don't get it we're not going
for it we are no longer going for it
yeah i wanted to slam dunk the gargoyle
but he won oh that's the shortcut all right one more chance
nice okay nice Look at that.
Gamer!
That's right.
That's me.
Gamer tab.
Alright.
Oh, shit.
Alright, we gotta grab this.
Oh my god, what?
Okay, I don't know how the fuck that worked.
I just gotta trip- was that triple jump?
Oh, guy.
That felt like a triple charge.
Okay, those three Scooby-Stocks won't add up, guys.
Trust me.
Okay.
How the fuck do I get across that?
Yeah, I was gonna say, I feel like I shouldn't have been
able to jump that.
Yeah, I knew it.
Yeah, I was just supposed to headbutt it.
Okay, that one looked particularly far away for some reason.
No, please, please tell me the ice.
Please tell me the ice is still down.
Are you fucking okay?
I didn't get it.
Okay, it's fine.
It's fine.
Mistakes, okay?
I learned.
I thought I could do...
I was trying to make it a speedrun thing.
You know?
I thought it was...
I was trying to do a speedrun strat, but the jokes was on
me.
All right, down I go.
No speedrunning here.
Okay, it's fine.
They don't add up.
They don't add up, guys.
It's fine.
Okay.
Oh,
shit.
Oh, shit.
Okay, wait.
Clutch!
Saved!
Saved, saved, saved.
Not even close.
What the fuck is the storm invention?
Oh my god, I gotta do all that?
I'm just a fucking dog!
What the fu- Okay.
Alright, Scooby should get more than just a scooby snack you
should get his own fucking apartment at that point
and give the dog his own apartment
i think i'm timed
oh my god i am timed or i drown or scooby drowns
oh well i'm racing against the clock right now
Oh my god, okay, I got it.
I'm doing it too fast.
I've just have to wait a little.
Yeah
Oh god, okay, okay, okay.
That's that's fine.
That's fine.
It's a little too scary.
I wait, I wait.
What the fuck?
Okay, that's fine.
That was a little too close for my liking.
Okay, I'm just gonna wait.
Whoa.
All right.
Sonic Enhancement for the Super Smash.
You have a Super Smash and a Gravo stun nearby.
Oh, okay.
They'll stun people.
I remember we're killing them.
Do I need the stun as well?
Oh.
Yeah, that's the way.
I went too fast there.
That was scary.
There was like moments where I was about to fucking die.
All right, now it's ghost time.
Ooh.
Environmental ghosting.
Hot buff paths high and low.
Yeah, unfortunately, the ghosts are a little too shrug.
Like the little eyes thing that they did too.
It's three.
Whoa.
Okay.
I'll grab this.
Oh, wait, is that... Okay, no.
Fuck do I Can't jump this way?
How the fuck do I jump that way?
Okay, I guess Fuck that.
Better grab the keys again?
Oh, oh my god To grab the goddamn keys again.
My keys.
Are you serious?
Okay, come on.
That's not fair.
Oh, come on.
He's guarding the keys.
How the fuck am I supposed to grab the keys?
He's... he's spawn capping it!
Bro, that guy's a goddamn spawn camper!
Oh, now you want to go this way.
Oh, it was three already.
Oh, whoops.
Oh my god.
Fuck you.
Can I stun the ghost?
Okay, there's the zombie.
Oh, I think if I press the button, all these coffins are
going to come out.
What's going on?
What?
What the fuck is supposed to be happening with these
buttons?
What?
Nothing's coming out.
I'm so confused.
Oh, I gotta knock the urns down?
Oh!
My god.
It's like this puzzle was built for children.
Damn.
There we go.
That was someone's crap.
Jeff cheapen out That's on them They're cheapen out on the
urn
Oh my god Every time I get on that It's like spooks scares
me so much
Alright There we go
Okay here we go
Nice Oh fuck do I get the monster token though
Wait, where does that open?
Oh, this.
Oh, that has to be a boss fight.
They literally made an entire window based off of him.
There's no way.
That gotta be a boss fight.
He has his own window, guys.
I gotta go this way.
Right?
It's okay.
There's no other You're sad I look for a way to activate
them.
What?
Oh, I must Bego from here then
It's the Glider from Fortnite Oh my god It is It's the thing
from Fortnite guys It's the Glider I don't like that Yeah
Yeah that's it Oh The zombies just chilling there.
Oh, no, no, no.
Any else here?
It's a spider.
Oh, hey, there's a portal.
That's good.
Oh, it's going back, please.
No.
No!
Okay.
It's okay.
We can make it.
We can find it.
600.
It's possible.
We're so close.
That's so odd.
It's good.
There's a door here.
Look, see it?
We're gonna make it.
Yes, we're gonna make it.
Fuck, damn.
I didn't even see that.
Okay, so that's destroyable.
Yes.
In the end, it does add up.
Who would have thought?
Every Scooby snack count.
It's bullshit.
Why did every snack count it?
Okay.
I assume I need a bubble.
go up there oh no every stat counts no no why didn't they
warn us
there's no way you have to collect all of them i refuse to
believe it there was another door i saw another door
i saw another door guys This door.
This door.
This door leads somewhere, right?
See?
Yeah, it doesn't stun him.
Are you fucking kidding me?
Are you...
Are you kidding me?
Okay.
Okay, they're just...
Oh!
Oh, these stacks just looking at me!
They're just, they're just looking at me, teasing me.
Be like, you know you want, you know, you want this, that.
Oh, no touchy.
Everyone warned you.
I didn't know.
Have I went down here yet?
To look for a zombie with a different room?
Like, why?
zombie
there's this zombie too which zombie is it that's a pet
there's this zombie
that's a good good good ghost oh my god it just gives me
sandwiches
Oh my god, okay give me a...
It's time to figure out where else to go!
Back to Mystic Manor!
Okay, we'll go from here backwards.
Okay, here backwards.
And then we go back from here.
Okay.
There we go.
Oh my god.
I remember leaving all of these.
I was like, it's okay.
We don't need any of that.
I was wrong.
I was so wrong.
I was so foolish.
Oh
Awesome, thank you for the rain Thank you, thank you I hope
you had a good stream
Okay, I need to figure out how to get to the other side
Okay, oh my god, there it is Oh my god, there's Scooby
Snacks There it is Guys, how many do I need, guys?
Oh my god.
Why?
I took advantage.
There were so many snacks just lying around.
I took them for granted.
I took these Scooby snacks for granted.
I didn't know.
I didn't know what I lost until now.
Poopy snacks.
Oh my god, this is hell.
This is such a tight jump.
God, this jump is so tight.
Okay.
Alright.
Oh, you fucking kidding me.
Okay, it's fine.
Got every snack counts.
This tests my fucking perception right here.
That's fine.
It's fine, guys.
It's fine.
Every snack count except for that particular snack, guys.
It's okay.
That snack...
Every snack counts except for that one.
Just that one, guys.
It's fine.
Where do I go?
Where the fuck is the door for those here?
Right!
Gulp.
Alright.
No, it's okay.
It's just three.
It's just three snacks.
It's only three.
It's five.
Those three don't add up.
I remember this.
I grabbed these snacks already.
Yeah, I grabbed them.
Well, I remember someone said the map tells you how many I'm
missing.
289 out of 300.
Where the...
Oh, it's the entire...
Okay, where...
Where is this 344 2 that they are speaking of?
Like, where...
Can it please stand up?
I think I think it's gonna add up.
Tokey, maybe it's adding up, Tokey.
No, no, no.
It's not adding up, guys.
Well, we know where three of them is.
No, that's impossible.
Oh, my God.
There's two.
There's one here.
I remember now.
A 400.
All right.
This is good.
It's good.
We're 100 left.
Okay, we're getting there.
80.
80 to go.
Okay, there's a door here.
Oh, my God.
It's this area.
How do I... Okay, there you go.
I was going to say, how the fuck do I charge this?
Okay.
See, I told you guys.
It's fine.
is five all right 327 okay that i'm willing to take those
okay we're gonna go down for the warp and we'll go down here
there's a 240 and i like those odds
okay we can speed run this part
all right we're gonna head to the warp here warp tab
oh wait what wait that's a lot of scooby snacks oh my god
that was a lot where's the warp though oh my god the warp is
all the way up here i don't i just remember the warp tape is
up top
don't say that don't say 700 because if there's a 750 that
means there's a 650 and a set There's a 700, there's a 650,
and a 700, and a 750.
If,
all right, let me go up here.
The warp gate is up here.
Okay, here we go.
We go to the warp gate, and then we go down here, and then
we go down.
Sure is.
Sure.
is scooby it sure is
okay oh my god oh my god i fucked up there that's a lot of
scooby snacks that i forgot about oh my god okay yeah that's
that's i got a little too cocky there
look i didn't know i didn't know
Oh my god, how did I even avoided all of these?
They were in my pathway!
It adds up.
It really did end up adding up.
How could this happen?
What do you mean it adds up?
Right!
It's a headless factor!
Oh my god, I haven't even hit 600 yet.
The fact that I haven't even hit 600.
Okay, there's the carpet.
Yeah, I know I don't need to collect all of it, but I need
600.
Guys, that's the thing.
We need 600 to even progress.
We'll head down the roof a bit.
I didn't get all of them.
I'm pretty sure I got all of them.
Yeah, I got all of them.
Yeah, this was on the other side.
Oh.
All right, this is where Shaggy got kidnapped.
Shaggy, I need you down there, Shaggy.
I got no, no.
Shaggy and Shaggy, no.
I don't, Shaggy, no.
Oh, thank god there is a magic carpet.
Okay, that's good.
I got a little worried.
Because I actually needed him down there.
Because I have no umbrella.
Kendra, thank you for the raid.
Thank you.
I've had a good stream.
I'm trapped in an endless cycle.
An endless cycle.
Of Scooby Snacks.
84.
Wait.
Up, going down.
Going up.
Going down.
Oh my god, the worst part.
What the fuck?
Okay.
Why is it in the air?
Oh my.
Oh my god, wait.
The worst part, I can't get out of these Scooby Snacks
because...
Because I don't have the goddamn umbrella.
Okay, it's all sandwiches.
But that means there might be Scooby Snacks.
There is no Scooby Snacks.
It's just all sandwiches.
It's just...
Oops, all sandwiches!
Oh, that's cute.
It says, I said, go away on the carpet.
That's very unfortunate.
Maybe there's spooky snacks that I missed down here.
I didn't miss any here.
All right, it's fine.
It's fine.
Okay, we're missing 137.
Okay, we got five one where there's, I'm missing a lot.
Okay, here.
Oh, okay, here too.
All right.
There's a lot of missing here.
Oh, sandwiches.
Alright.
Which way?
Mr. Ragnarok.
Okay, here.
Oh my god, right off the gate.
Okay.
There's apparently a lot of Scooby snacks that I'm missing
from here.
The bookshelves has a hidden...
didn't snap.
I'm fine.
I find an opening.
There's some here too.
Wait, this way.
What?
That's an opening.
Oh, there it is.
What?
Open up!
There we go.
Oh, no.
That has not.
That already been in here.
I already fucking been in here.
This door is locked from the other side.
What?
Where?
Oh.
Where was that?
Okay.
Nothing missing here.
Anything missing back here?
Oh.
I'm here to collect the Scooby Snacks.
Scooby Snack Tax Season.
I feel like I get more if I go backwards.
I'll go back there.
That has, like, more...
More snacks I can obtain.
Okay, I'm gonna go back.
I like that the animation is the classic running animation.
From Scooby.
I really love the attention of details.
Bye.
Geronimo!
Okay, here.
This should be where I got the...
Where I'm gonna get the snacks.
Alright.
How am I gonna grab the snacks?
Ooh.
Okay, that's bullshit.
Okay, come on, buddy.
I...
Oh.
Okay.
I'm just, okay, fuck this.
Okay, okay.
Like, how?
Their hitboxes are insane.
All right, there we go.
Okay, their hitbox is, like, bullshit, guys.
That ain't a real hitbox.
Yeah, do I?
I gotta grab that, though.
There we go.
Ruby snacks Ruby snacks Where's that push?
Go up Are you fucking kidding me?
You stupid bat?
Lie higher.
Oh my god!
Oh!
There's no way!
There's no!
Like, wait, that's the shit is trolling.
The bats are trolling me right now They did not code a
hitbox There's no way I refuse to believe That bat had a
hitbox They did not fucking code in a hitbox Without one
particular bat
Oh my Okay
Okay Okay 609 I'll take those
Creepers Bitch the creeper I don't know Get him out of here
Okay open up open up open up open up lady we're gonna get
hit over oh yeah it's this way
right right fuck this particular witch in pert in I can't
even talk anymore in particular let's try to say in
particular I'm fucking...
This game...
There's so many Scooby Snacks.
There's so many.
Where are all the Scooby Snacks?
What?
Okay.
Oh, hey!
Snacks!
Oh my god, it's this area!
Okay, okay, wait, wait, wait.
it i i remember this area this is the area where i left the
most scooby snacks it did in the end it did end up adding up
i will say this area i will say this area added up
here you go
all right go scooby go go keep going oh my god he didn't
even give me more scooby snacks all right i'm gonna go no no
no no no no no i have 24
up all right nice all right down here's a warp pipe
all right we did it okay we go here go to the hedge maze and
then the graveyard this is it this is it we're gonna make it
and then We pay our taxes.
That's fine.
We got our taxes paid off, guys.
This is fine.
And then we save our game just in case something happens.
Oh, God.
Please, Kar, stop moving.
Please, Kar, I forgot to save my game.
Okay.
Okay, I was gonna say, why is it not letting me save?
There you go.
Someone quick, catch that car.
Oh my god, look at all those Scooby-Treeks.
Oh no, he's burning.
What the fuck do I do?
Just stop dropping, roll, Shaggy.
Stop dropping, roll!
Oh wait.
There you go.
all right nice one down what the fuck is this pumpkin doing
here all right last one
okay that's bullshit okay that's fine he has the key oh my
god he did it shaggy did it he stopped dropped and rolled
you have a key shaggy let's get that key so we can get out
Okay, princess carry time.
Come on.
Come on, carry me.
Yay.
He has a great upper core strength.
Not gonna lie.
I will say that.
Great date.
Like, because, like, Shag, Scooby is based off of a great
date.
How?
Okay, I'll have to jump.
Okay, sorry.
I forgot I had to do work, too.
I thought he would do most of the work for me.
That's my bad.
I didn't realize.
No, Great Danes are fucking huge and very, very heavy.
So Shaggy has some big upper core strength to do all of
that.
Or so to continue.
Yeah, he's a big, he's a big-ass doggo.
coffins above.
Hit the stone switches to find out which one.
Okay.
I need those.
I didn't even hit that.
What the fuck?
I didn't even open the coffin.
Oh, I hope it's not time.
Is it?
No, that's a ghost.
The ghost was in that one.
What's in this one?
Oh, yeah!
I got it!
I got the Scooby snacks!
Oh my god, that's a lot of scooby snacks.
That's free real estate.
Right there in this market and economy.
Okay, that's a ghost.
I know it's all ghosts, but you know, it's just like the
challenge.
See what I mean, not a ghost, isn't it?
Damn.
I'm gonna grab these scooby snacks before I...
Move, progress.
That's like Ram 6.
You can't take them for granted right now.
I'm not even at 200.
That's the saddest part.
In the snack economy.
I swear, there's like only one dog treat or some shit in the
Scooby-Doo universe.
I'm not surprised.
They don't even have fucking umbrellas.
Alright, down we go.
Ah.
Snackonomy.
Scooby Snacks are like diamonds.
It's all ran by one company.
Are you fucking kidding?
Okay.
I can't even do anything about the ghost.
They just exist.
Can't even kill it.
How can you kill something that's dead?
Yeah, but what if I'm a...
Okay, he doesn't care.
I was like, but what if I was a suit of armor.
Okay.
215.
400 to go, guys.
400.
Oh, this has to be the boss.
Am I getting my umbrella?
Scooby, help.
We gotta save her.
She's hot.
Strike.
Keep it up, Scooby.
I'm almost there.
Whoa.
Jeepers, my skin was beginning to chase.
You won't get away that easily.
You think that was easy?
What?
Here, I think this old friend of yours is dying.
Oh, God, it's him.
Scooby, I can't believe it.
It's the green ghost.
Not the green ghost.
That's right.
And pretty soon you will.
Daphne too, isn't it?
It's like that Roger clip.
It's Roger, isn't it?
I think it's Daphne's like a friend.
Yeah, how do I...
Where are we?
What am I doing, Daphne?
Oh, wait, that's it.
Okay, okay.
Suck, it's Ghostbusters.
Suck it in!
Just like my Ghostbusters!
Can't stop, number, no, no.
There you go.
Oh, my God.
I don't want you to go over here.
That's right.
What?
How does that hit me?
Oh, my God.
That, okay, I can't crush the...
Okay, we're dying here.
I can't crush the plants, guys, unfortunately.
Oh my god Daphne, come on Daphne Daphne, come on We gotta be
on, Daphne We gotta be on the same page here, Daphne Oh my,
Daphne, please Alright, open this, open this He's gonna go
here next Alright, God, never mind Daphne Never mind your
choose God damn
Alright, it's okay, we can do this again Daphne, we can work
together Daphne, we're all Wrong way, wrong way, Daphne.
Right here, that's right, this is right, this is right,
yeah.
Suck it in!
Those things are heavy to lift, Stokey.
Give her a break.
Daphne, please, you will have eyes!
We both see where the ghost is!
We can both see where the ghost is going, Daphne!
I assume we both have the same eyes All right, here you go
Okay, maybe he'll go this way
There you go Is that number three?
Goodbye Oh, he's waiting for five Oh, yeah, why is it a
ghost attacking her?
Good job, Scooby But what's the green ghost doing here?
We're so many ghosts around here Scooby-Doo, the green ghost
isn't really a ghost Well, what about the weeper?
Yeah About the suppers seeing them as well Do you not did
you not see the green ghost those are all villains from our
past Scooby-Doo something strange is definitely going on
here Okay, you better have seen the witch or you see the
witch don't you that you and you got me crazy Daphne whoa
Daphne too easy guys it's just me Holly it's Holly it's
Holly isn't it Holly she's the villain isn't she wow so that
is a very tight dress by the way God.
Polly, your dress is one size, too small.
Yeah, she's pretty.
Pretty sus right now.
Yeah, that's where he thinks up all his crazy inventions.
Maybe there's something in here.
Crazy.
You mean boots?
You mean rain boots?
So fucking crazy.
It plunges.
Solar-powered nightlight.
Underwater.
Wind is whack-it.
Microwave safe ice.
cube tray yeah no he's crazy right what's with this umbrella
oh my god there it is that's actually one of my uncle's more
useful inventions he invented the umbrella oh oh my god an
umbrella he did it come again lap please lap at least we
know when to laugh guys hold down the x after you do a
double jump
run away a rambella oh my god finally we have he did it he
invented a rambella they invented a rambella okay guys I
don't remember what places need a rumbella.
Guys, guys, does anyone remember where is the rumbella
places?
Which one was it?
I'm already, I am already too confused.
The lighthouse?
Okay, the lighthouse.
Which way?
This way?
Oh, this way!
I remember.
Going down which way?
It's this way.
That's a good timing.
I'm not paying for the goddamn museum.
Guys, I need every fucking cookie.
Sounds like a mystery, dokey.
There's a door.
That's $750, guys.
Like...
Oh my god.
The water actually goes...
up there's actually like coast what is it called when water
like rises up and down
my god lose economy every cookie counts
every cookie counts yeah there's high tide and low tide okay
except for that we've got one cookie that one cookie we
don't need it guys This doesn't add up.
It won't add up guys.
I swear Just that one cookie It's fine as long as I grab all
the other cookies will be fine Oh my I tied game I tied
fucking game That's crazy as
That's so dumb
Okay, it's okay.
It's okay.
We just gotta grab that cook those cookies.
Look at all those cookies.
We just gotta grab them.
See, look, I ended up getting the cookie, guys.
Can't complain no more.
The cookie's been got.
Please tell me.
Please.
Oh, okay, okay.
I got really worried.
Yeah, I gotta make it to the other side before.
Yeah, I had a feeling that plant.
That plant isn't gonna go.
So, oh my, and it's just a sandwich.
Of course, it's just a sandwich.
Do I have to go?
Goodbye.
Ah, the dude it jumps again.
Oh, wait, unless...
No, the button's pressed, the button's pressed.
No.
The buttons are pressed.
I'm safe.
Okay.
The button has been pressed.
I don't have to worry.
Look you get.
There is something over there, but I don't know if to press
a button.
Yeah, I can't make it.
Oh.
that was close that was so close
all right oh my god okay it's okay that boat's coming back
right boat okay okay i make it that's fine
Where is the per- It's fine
I just- I'm having trouble trying to figure out where all of
this is
Okay redo all right it's fine it's just two all right it's
okay we don't need that one
okay oh my god oh we don't need it we don't need it
We don't need it.
We don't need it guys.
Okay, we don't need it Guys, it's okay.
We don't need it
It's not that important What did that one move to?
Okay.
Okay, there we go.
We got that, at least.
Why is there a giant piece of Scooby Snacks right there?
Like, okay, okay.
It's right.
There's a button to activate that.
There has to be a button to activate that.
How?
No!
Don't you...
Oh, my...
It's okay.
Paul, thank you for the super chat.
Thank you.
Oh.
No.
Okay, it's okay.
It's okay.
You can make it
Life will be fat We can we can survive Wait, what?
Okay, there you go This level is okay.
No, I found a worse level
I think the worst part is just the fact that the buttons
reset if you mess up the parkour Like that's not cool That
ain't cool
I would say how come your childhood games always involves
you paying debts to the cookie Mafia Cookies were very
important back in the day The cookie market was very scary.
No!
What?
It was a different time.
Kids fucking love cookies.
It was all about the cookies, bro.
All kids wanted was more cookies.
The cookie sends us or the cookie dog sends us regards.
Yippee Ducky, you get your cookies again.
Where am I wrong?
Wahoo!
Yeah.
I'm trying to be aware of my shadow too.
Alright.
Here I go.
I take those.
That's fine.
Oh my god.
Okay, wait.
These Scooby Snacks are actually very important.
Where the fuck do I go?
What the?
Okay, guys.
I'm very confused.
now guys oh my god i found it
oh my god i found it here we go Oh my god, I made it I made
it across Thank God Oh 400 400 cookies
As long as there's no cookie door here We should be okay
We have time to build more cookies Right Right It's okay.
We still have time.
We
still have time to collect more cookies.
Just need 300 more.
There's some easily 300 more cookies, guys.
Oh, my God, these stupid fucking fish.
Oh.
Oh, that's a lot of cookies.
Okay, but I'm going to check over here first.
because there's a lot of cookies here too
oh my god i could use them as a jump pad yeah
my oh my god forgot it's 750
it wasn't just it wasn't just 700 it was Oh!
It's okay.
That means I can get the monster token, guys.
I'm gonna get the monster token now, guys.
Yippee!
I
don't trust this fish.
God, fuck yeah, I knew I can't trust this fish.
you are you fucking okay my head hits the wall okay it's
okay it's okay we didn't need that guys we didn't need it
am I on it I'm on it okay got the boat see there's no
there's no tokens there oh it's this way Don't go here
All right Thank you, thank you, thank you My dad says those
are scooby snacks Not cookies Love your gameplay of this
game Doki is one of my favorite from early 2000 Leave a
super chat, thank you, thank you It's the water rising No,
don't you do this to me Don't let it go Okay, okay, okay,
that's good That's good, okay, it's just give me a little
cutscene they're like oh in case you didn't do it here's a
little cut i did that's fine that's oh my okay it's fine
those keys weren't that important anyway
but i'm glad you've been enjoying the gameplay can you
where's the boat
where the fuck is that boat
guys i don't know where that boat is.
Oh my god, it was all the way there.
Oh my God, I gotta make that jump of my life.
Alright.
I gotta make that jump.
I, I, oh my god.
That.
Oh my God.
Okay.
Gotta make the leap of faith right here.
Scooby, you can do it.
You can do it, Scooby.
Holy shit.
That was so scary.
There we go.
We got another warp.
Oh, I had to lock in there.
The scariest jump there.
The leap to end our leaps.
Oh.
Okay, I was going to say, wait, I was Oh, hey, nice.
Oh, I don't want to see...
Okay, we're going to keep that.
We're going to keep...
I didn't realize.
We had to keep that.
That one was important.
How?
Where are my sticky, fucking suction boots?
Oh, my God.
This is so rough.
It is actually so rough.
At least we killed a lady.
It's okay, it was a witch.
Down we go.
It's okay, guys.
What we learned from the witch trials, witches don't have
rights.
So it's okay.
What we did was okay.
The technically children of Satan.
Okay.
But true.
And they have no souls, too.
Shit.
What I did was okay for humanity.
All right, it's okay.
Damn toky.
It's their fault for selling their souls to the devil.
Okay.
So I could do all this.
I read my witch lore.
And witches, they don't know.
They don't float, right?
That's like one of the witch trials.
You throw them.
You throw them in the ocean.
And if they start floating, they're a witch.
Like you start, you tie rocks on them.
If they float.
Witch.
It's true!
I know my witch lore.
Yeah, if you can swim, you're a witch.
Yeah, so like they, okay, so like, they were, if they
drowned, then I guess they were just wrong.
You know, if they drowned, then I guess, oops, sorry, we're
just, oops, sorry, wrong guy.
But they don't drown.
Look, it's the risk they're willing to take.
I hear you.
Okay.
all right up we go oh my god look at all these scooby snacks
oh chicken
apparently if you're too pretty you're also a witch i was
reading i was watching these youtube shorts where this lady
was talking about like what what could you get burned for
being a witch and one of them was like if you're too Pretty,
you're a witch.
Like, only beautiful women are witches.
Thank God.
I'm not.
Curse entranches, yeah.
Also, a bear's like, what was it?
If you know how to read, they'll call you a witch, too.
I think that one was wild.
Oh, a rooster token.
What did this open, anyway?
Yeah, good thing I can't read, guys.
Can't possibly be a witch.
I don't know how to grab that scooby snap.
Yeah, can't read.
Can't be a witch.
Oh, I opened this door.
Nice.
Okay, nice.
Oh, I'll
do this.
Are you?
Oh, my God.
Oh, okay, it's fine.
All right, we slam dunk the fish.
Oh, my God.
No, please don't tell me I have to reopen that door.
It's all the way back there, too.
Oh, I don't have to open the door.
I don't have to open.
I don't think so.
Oh, I have to.
God damn it.
That's fine.
But I think I slam dunked the switch and then I used it as a
platform.
Oh, it was close.
I was close, though.
No, that platform is definitely scarier than the monsters.
There is an invisible wall right there.
There?
What the fuck?
Who built that?
It's okay.
Chicano.
Thank you for the super chat.
Thank you.
This is a big surprise for Doki.
Have you heard her top mutant talk?
She'd have a fielded nice guy where she's while she's still
was still immune to the super chat.
Thank you.
If witches are bad, then why do the next girls make me feel
funny if evil why high that's how they tempt you that's why
they burn the hot ones that's why one of the witches like
the uh the hints of someone was a witch wasn't they're too
beautiful Witch Fucking enchantress Oh
my god And it spins now I don't like that it spins
Bro it spins and it goes up and That's actually bullshit.
They spin and go up and down.
Like, it's the double whammy.
Oh my god, I accidentally fucking almost dived across.
Here we go again.
A wombo combo.
So let's try this again.
And just switch.
God damn, it was so...
It was always so close.
Okay.
I don't think I can no-hit this game.
I have to get these fuckers out of here.
I gotta wait.
Jesus Christ, it's so fast, too.
I think that's the worst part.
I sat in the middle of this.
Yeah, I know, that's bullshit.
Like, what the fuck?
Oh my god.
That's actually bullshit.
No!
I didn't realize you can tilt all the way.
Oh my god.
Oh my god, now I know now I gotta be careful
Oh my god fishes are evil
This is the worst platform yet This is 100% the worst one
The spinning is so fucked up
No, that is so fucked up that is a fucked up concept I'll do
it a second time Yeah, I Believe it'll start spinning now Oh
god.
Oh god not the fish Gulp is right scoop gulp is right
Where's the platform?
That that's fucked up.
That's fucked up.
I have no camera.
I have no camera for this Like I can't see it
Laps insert lab track
The fact that There is no fucking oh my god.
There's there's no camera for it.
That's the worst part
Do it the second time it comes up
This is so messed up this is so fucking messed up Oh my god
Oh my god, I got
Oh my god, I made it I made it I made it I made it Oh my
god, I made it Okay, wait Oh I see it Seven
okay we're gonna since we died here this should be our door
right that should be our door
all right here's all the scooby snacks there we go that's
that's fine that's good enough
i see the 750 door i see it Oh, I see.
Thank you for the super chat.
Thank you.
I'm so close to 7.50.
Okay.
But I want to say thank you for the super chat.
Thank you.
Congrats on the blackjack wins.
I'm grabbing these.
Whoa.
Oh, thank God.
There's a war.
Yeah.
Oh my god, where is it?
It's like 181.
It's not too bad, guys.
750 is obtainable.
It's not too bad.
We just got home.
There's 50 more in this one area.
It's obtainable.
Oh my god, wait, wait, there might be 750.
Guys, 750 might exist in here.
I don't know what he means when he says the other side of
the ship, I'm just gonna grab as many Scooby Snacks as
possible.
Why can't I grab that?
Bada-bada-bada-bada-bada-bada-bada-bada-bada.
Rick on the deck.
Does it take me home?
Oh, okay.
Thank God.
Okay.
Alright.
Wait, what?
I finished reading that.
What did I say?
Is it finished spinning yet?
Are you done spinning?
Hello?
Okay, there you go.
It will be difficult getting back up here.
Okay.
Oh.
There's a warp behind me.
It didn't mean what it said.
It did say, it did say it would be hard to get back, it did
warn you.
No,
don't laugh.
Don't laugh at me.
Okay, it's okay.
It's okay.
Here.
Thank you for the five gifted chips.
Thank you, sake.
The fact that he laughed at me, too.
I'm just gonna jump across.
Alright.
Are you fucking...
It's okay.
Oh my god, I have to be able to grab this.
But I don't...
bump it up bump it up all right how much more do i need
maybe it's not 750 guys guys maybe it's not 750 there's hope
guys what if it's not yeah what if it's 800
you're right donky what if it's 800 oh my god
i have 744
maybe it's more okay okay we're gonna buy i like how this
like you're missing three 170.
I'm not going back there.
I refuse to go back there.
Okay, we're going to find our own way.
Okay.
There's 269 behind me.
Suddenly they added up, Toki.
No, how could this be?
I refuse to believe that There's no way There's no way they
ended up adding up guys I refuse to believe it
Okay wait wait Wait a minute See that Wait Hold I have an
umbrella Keep holding.
Right.
There has to be six.
Scooby Snacks right up here.
This takes me back, doesn't it?
Okay.
Okay, that's fine.
That's fine.
Okay.
A platform.
are calling to you.
Wait, wait, hold!
Wait, there is one place.
Keep holding?
Here, here, here.
Alright, okay, okay, it's six.
I found a place.
This is the last, this has to be the last one.
Wait, I can go here.
Wait, wait, wait, wait, wait.
It's here, here.
Here.
The original hedge maze.
It's right here.
There's a lot of snacks in the original.
Okay.
I left a lot.
Guys, I know it looks very empty, but I left a lot.
I'll get there eventually.
You tell when I stop caring.
You can tell.
Get more ingredients from Germany.
They give a super chat bot.
They can thank you.
Good morning to you too.
Okay.
There will be scooby snacks, I swear.
Where does this start adding up?
Where did all the snacks go?
Don't wait.
I ate everything.
Oh my god, it's here.
It's here.
I knew it.
I got, I told you guys.
right here all right oh my god for you okay wait there you
go and I will dig this and I got soap I don't I can't do
anything with the soap yet I got soap oh my god there better
be there might be more snacks here I knew it I knew there
were more snacks I knew it I was always a believer where am
i where the fuck am okay it's okay it's this way it's this
way so i got a little confused there wee all right now now i
can head back see easy i got 750.
there's no way there's 800 i think that's the last one.
That's the last one.
There.
We gotta go.
I still can't think of the super chat.
Thank you, thank you.
Alright.
We're gonna make it, guys.
I told you I left some snacks by emergency rations.
There's no way.
There's not enough Scooby snacks for it to hit an 800.
There's not enough there's it there's no way they made the
jump from 600 to 750 when they were doing increments of 50
like and it's something like hello surprise 150 now the
scooby snack stock market is not that good i refuse to
believe it but this must be where i get fred
Okay, Fred has to be here.
Okay.
The demand went up by a lot.
Someone please pop the fucking Scooby Snack Market.
I swear to God.
Okay, it's fine.
Alright.
Oh, they should have kept the momentum.
By the way, I'm using my I'm using my Dirty Keyblade
controller for this.
nice feels nice
oh okay yeah and then it rubs the wound in the rubs the salt
in the wound
literally the last one
okay I'm just going to use the umbrella and wait until I
fucking grasp it.
All right, there we go.
I'm not risking it.
All right, grab the momentum, Scooby.
All right, there we go.
$5 to my name.
Because I'm going to be homeless.
Scoob.
No, no, we're gonna be homeless, Scoop.
For God, don't.
No, no, not this one.
Oh, Scoop.
What are you gonna do?
Zoids!
I knew you weren't real.
Wait, there's like no Scoopies.
Now there it is.
I was gonna say, where the fuck are the Scoopies snacks?
live in the van i mean we're technically doing that already
school but now now it's not my choice yeah i was gonna say
yeah but this time it's not my choice king because we
couldn't pay for rent no more
i'll take every cookie i could get
gotta make sure i grab all the all of them scooby snacks
leave no scooby snack behind what the fuck am i supposed to
do here oh my god no
no way
no way what child's gonna do this
oh my god
oh my god for one key we did it guys we did it gang we got
one key
where the fuck are the other keys How is that wonky?
Oh my god, excuse me?
I'm just gonna change.
What?
What is it supposed to do?
Oh my god, I'm so...
Oh my god, it goes up.
Scooby!
No!
Please, please let me go up!
There you go.
This is a cruel joke.
This is a cruel joke towards children.
All right, we got the other key.
Oh my god, it kicked me out.
Two.
Where is key number three?
How?
How do I get that?
I can't even hit it.
How?
oh my god where is that gun slowly flowed over this one's so
janky this one I don't know
okay oh my god the wind is playing against me right now oh
oh my god I don't know there's no grab button chat there's
no there's no grab button it's just you like you jump on it
you just jump oh my god I'm just gonna try and like I just
yeah fuck that I can't
Like, we're- oh, I got the key, I got the key, I got the
key, I got the key, I got it.
I got it.
I was like, where the fuck is it?
Now where the fuck is the last key?
Getting over it with Scooby-Doo.
And you're fighting the last key.
Oh, it's here.
It's here.
fine I left the easiest one for last I'm okay with that
thank God the other ones were fucking weird
okay oh my god these platformers these platforms are like
brutal yeah I started the hardest one I'll like, what the
fuck am I looking at?
It's unlocked.
It's unlocked, though.
I did it.
I'm in the pirate ship.
Shiver your timber, Scooby.
I just need soap, right?
Soap is the last power up.
Friend!
See if you can get me down, Scoob.
I know, Fwen.
Thanks, Scooby.
Thank the masterminds behind this mystery.
Oh, yeah, no.
Yeah, you think I'm...
Mastermind?
Ooh, that's not.
If we look around, we can find some clues that will lead us
right to him.
And to the professor.
Oh.
Like behind you.
Fred, no!
I've had a belly full of your meddling.
It's high past time.
I did away with you once and for all.
Oh my God, those pesky meddling kids.
I think you remember this old adversary of yours.
He certainly remembers the years.
Red beard!
It's the roast of red beard!
Not the roast of red beard!
He's real!
I think your old foe has a score to settle with you.
Fred, get out of that barrel!
Tip over!
Oh wait, no, he'll get me stuck even more.
Oh no Rolro Oh my god, he's invulnerable to do this Oh my
god, and there's ghosted fucking rain ghost chasing after me
You No I don't know I don't know I
The ghosts, they don't know how to...
The ghosts, they can't get stunned!
Oh my god, wait, I can kill those ghosts?
Wait, what?
Okay.
I didn't know those ghosts...
It's because he's wearing a raincoat, guys.
I get it.
It's because he has a raincoat.
Oh my god, okay, okay, okay, okay.
Okay.
Apparently, if you have raincoats on, you're vulnerable.
That's what you get for wearing clothes.
He has clothes on.
They reverse everything.
They're not real ghosts if they start wearing clothes.
Guys, dude, that's the rule.
Yeah, clothing is a debuff.
Oh god, there's three of them now.
Oh.
Oh my god, okay.
Okay, okay.
Guys, guys.
There we go.
I was like, chill, guys.
I'm right here.
Oh my god, I have to kill him.
Oh, I have to kill him right when I'm right there.
God damn it.
That's messed up.
Okay.
I have to kill them when I'm here.
all right yeah that's what you get for wearing raincoats oh
gosh come on come on get closer it's fine oh my god it's not
fine it's no longer fine there you go
there you go we got it one more
what it's just he got angry
oh my god he's looking what is he looking for
all right last one oh my god there's four of them now oh my
god there's four of them
it's bad i got one of them
no my last life my last life this all depends oh thank god
one left
oh spider oh my god that's oh he was he guys he ran away
from the treasure guys he ran he's Fine, guys.
He ran away.
No, he's not dead, guys.
We didn't see it.
We didn't see it happen, so he might be alive.
Bro, he did.
Years ago.
How old were you guys?
Hey, guys.
Watch out, guys.
The creeper's chasing me.
Velma, wait a second.
There's something on your glasses.
The creeper times two.
Now this is a clue.
And clues like this just don't follow your map.
10 years ago.
Were you 10 when you caught the creeper?
Oh, Shaggy!
Raggy!
Scoob!
Food!
Yay!
We should go find Daphne and Holly and put all our clues
together.
And find that mastermind.
Try the secret lab.
I have to thank you for the super chat.
Thank you.
Oh.
Before she disappeared with Rathney.
Come on, you two.
You're coming with us.
We're going to be a gang again.
We're not splitting up.
Fred wants us to stop our smorgasbord.
Oh.
Okay, guys.
If you want to stay in this creepy cove all alone.
Oh.
Ready and I got rid of the roasts.
So lots of goodies and no ghosts.
Sounds better than a secret lab, huh Scoob?
Yeah.
A roast free room.
Yay.
All right then.
We'll catch up with you later.
Wait, no, let's not split up.
No, no, no, no, no, wait.
Wait, wait, why don't we just wait and eat together, guys?
We don't have to split up, gang.
What's this?
Professor Graham's tricky, sticky gum do hickie.
What do you say, Scoob?
Want to give it a try?
Okay.
Oh, wait.
Is that the soap?
It says here, this stuff will stick creeps in place so you
can bounce off their heads.
Ah.
Oh, the Rose Diver.
Yeah, like the Ghost Diver.
He invented the gum bar machine.
Would you want to present this game, Tilky?
Not even for a Scooby-Stack, girl.
How about for six...
Oh, my God, you host, Gabby.
Thank you for the super chat.
Thank you.
We're almost there.
The Roast Rider is the ghost that I have it.
Hey, where am I?
Oh.
Shout to the Mystery Manor.
Take me out of here.
Take me out.
Get me out.
Shoot me back to the home.
See, guys?
Look, he didn't break his arm.
And then a supernatural team came over.
And then physics was invented.
Stupid supernatural.
Wait.
How do I use the...
It didn't even teach me how to use the attack.
Oh!
How do I use it?
Oh, it's left...
Okay, it's...
It's left bumper.
Okay, I figured it out.
Alright, where do we have...
to go.
I'm confused.
Oh, do I go to a secret lab now?
Okay, secret lab time.
The super secret lab.
Alright.
lab time.
Oh, what the fuck?
What the fuck?
It's this guy.
I made it.
I don't think I was supposed to.
to be here i don't i don't think oh my god what the out my
how
the bro what
bro it's in the lava
yeah those keys are gone
Come on, the ghost?
Oh my god, what the...
What do I do, though, a bit?
Oh my, I'm so fucking dumb.
That's so goofy.
Like, oh my god, what the fuck?
It's not even, like, forever.
I'm so confused.
Okay, this mechanic sucks.
Okay, there we go.
I...
Where am I supposed to go?
Yeah, I did this thing, but then, like, the keys are in
lava.
Like, what the fuck am I supposed to do?
They put it in lava!
What the fuck?
I'm so confused.
Oh, I have to grab the cages to get them out.
Oh, okay.
Okay, I get it.
I don't have to grab the cages.
Oh, I can't grab it.
Okay.
All right.
I sort of get it, but it's also very confusing.
Oh, my God.
He has guns.
Okay.
Oh, it's going up.
Okay, I get it.
Okay, I got one.
I get it.
All right, I got two.
I got three.
Okay, I got it.
There I roll.
Okay, one more.
Oh my god.
This goddamn fixed camera angles.
God damn fixed camera angles.
Guys, you don't understand.
The fixed camera angles fucked me up.
Guys.
okay
oh it's okay it's okay we don't need it yet we don't need it
we don't need it i just grabbed these two keys first oh no
okay there we go there we
go there we go because i told you we don't need it there you
go see we did it we did it all right there you go there you
go there you go boom
There you go.
See, everything's fine.
We are in the secret lab.
Oh, no, Shaggy.
Wait, how did you get to the secret lab?
I learned just so much fucking parkour to get here.
How did you get there?
It's not fair.
It's not a bug.
It's a feature.
It's unfair.
Okay, I need Shaggy's help for this.
give me a push then press though and i'll follow you all
right follow me shaggy
then press okay raggy raggy there we go wait but what about
over here what's over there though raggy you came from here
yeah you know what fuck it Maybe there's something important
over there.
Oh, yeah, there's definitely something important down here.
A couple hit.
Okay, we got some more bubble gum.
What the fuck?
Okay, all right.
No, I had to take damage there.
Like, what the fuck was that speed?
Like, how would I dodge that?
What's over here?
All right.
Got another button in.
I don't know what that opens, but...
No, I swear to God.
This is just...
Okay, okay, it's gonna stay.
I swear to God, that was just...
That felt like bait.
Open sesame?
I need a key to open...
It's here, isn't it?
I fucking knew it.
I knew that was a fake-ass wall.
All right, here we go.
All right, these guys seem rough.
I knew there were fucking Scooby Snacks in there.
You can't hide from me.
I got my Scooby Snacks sense in.
Are you...
Okay, it's okay.
It's okay.
I purposely died so I can get my HP back.
I had very little HP.
Oh my god, he has it.
It's okay, we'll just wait.
I can wait.
Okay, never mind.
Stop.
Okay, nice.
Okay, I don't know if that was...
That was supposed to...
Are you serious?
Okay, it's fine.
I got more bubblegum.
It's not food, but I got bubblegum.
Open the door.
That's me one of the keys, right?
That's a fake-ass wall!
There's no way that's a real wall.
What do you mean I can't get back up?
What do you...
Okay.
What the fuck?
Why?
Oh my god, what's the point?
What's the point of fixed?
A fucking fixed camera angle.
Actually, oh my god.
The goddamn fixed camera angles.
Oh my god, it's here.
Oh, beware.
Beware.
I know I'm already here, but I'm like Why did it backtrack
me here?
Where am I supposed to fucking go?
I am so confused.
Okay.
We're here now.
Where the fuck do I go?
It's a circle, yes.
But I'm confused.
Back to Shaggy?
Ooh!
This entire game is me going, where am I?
Oh my god, I don't know.
I was like, why is there a fucking random hole here?
Maybe there's something I'm missing.
Woo!
Okay, that's a little too late, bro.
I'm already back here.
backwards because I'm okay yeah because of that yes because
of that okay now I know that was the last axe okay now I
know that is the last axe for real okay I where did he go
where did Jackie go okay I'm just gonna reset the pathway so
if I die
be here.
Ready?
Oh my god.
That's okay.
See?
I used the door.
So I should see.
Look at that.
Speed run.
Okay.
I haven't gone through this door yet.
Yeah.
I was going to go to this door.
All right.
Okay.
Okay, okay, we gotta figure this out Yes, we have to figure
this out I'm so lost
Okay Alright, there is a warrant What do you mean read the
map?
What the fuck got a map in my reading right now?
Okay
Maybe if we go backwards
We are reading the same map, guys
Maybe there's something back here Maybe I'm just, I'm
tanking all these
Okay, maybe There's a path here that we don't know Oh my
god, wait, wait, wait, wait, wait, wait, wait Wait, wait, oh
my god, wait, wait we lead we lead the zombie zombie zombie
come on whoa zombies come on that's right that's right
zombies yeah
no there's nothing we can do there's there's nothing we can
do there's there's nothing we can do there that is uh that's
hopeless that area is hopeless Okay, there's the cauldron
area
Is there anything here?
I'm just going in a circle, guys.
Where am I?
What's over here?
Oh my god.
Oh my god,
what is this area?
Um
I thought I was a genius I guess And
now I'm back here Beware Beware Our roads lead to the
entrance
Beware Our roads lead to the attic Okay where is this that
okay we gotta go back to the secret passage back in the god
damn there's a vent in gusts around underground part two
where the fuck creepy crawlies gusts around underground okay
we gotta go here yeah but Why would you go?
There's no passage.
Oh my god.
It leads to the basement.
We have to go to the basement.
Okay
Oh my god.
Okay, Gus Okay here
Okay, here we are
All right, the vents don't work
It's fine
Okay, we gotta find the vent Wherever the fuck the goddamn
vent is I swear to God, that's a breakable wall right there
That is
That has to be a breakable wall
Oh my god, it's not it
I know what you are Where the fuck?
Where?
wait that's a vent that's a vent
barrel this entire time oh my okay it was a fake a fucking
barrel okay it's fine it's fine it's fine maybe kids would
have kids would have known kids would have I just had no I
just don't have enough whimsy guys I just lack the whimsy to
check the fucking fucking barrel now she just I just didn't
have enough whimsy that's that's my bad
oh my god please stop laughing at me
okay this is why i like how legos is like age limit is like
four to 100 and like what's his name dick band dick band
something the guy in mary poppins turned 100 and they're
like he's now not allowed to play legos he is over the age
limit for legos now
all right he's just looking at me i don't like I don't like
that he's just staring at me like that.
What does he want to do?
Okay.
Here we go.
We're in.
All right, who's yelling in the cellar?
Okay, I just wanted to kill him just to be sure.
I don't trust him.
What the fuck?
What the fuck did I turn on?
Oh, shit.
I need three keys.
Oh my god, it's this key shit again.
Okay.
Oh my god, that's what it means.
Alright, get me that key.
Where the fuck?
Wait, why did that not open?
Oh no.
Oh, no, I'm trying.
I'm heading over.
I'm heading there as fast as I can.
No.
No, no,
no, no.
What are the odds of that happening?
There we go.
That's actually crazy.
It's spawned in the moment.
I'm slam dunked.
He's actually a hater.
Holy shit.
That meant... Oh, my God.
Please, I need, it's not, I don't need gum anymore, please,
I need food, I need food, I am starving, please, oh my,
please, Scooby needs nourishment, you can't feed Scooby with
gum,
I'm too scared of, goddamn, I knew it, I fucking knew it, I
fucking knew he was there, why
do I even go, I feel like, The sandwich is there.
Tease me.
It's like, you know you need the sandwich.
It's fine.
Oh.
Okay, water.
Okay, that's fine.
Oh my god, I didn't mean to go back.
Fast.
That's scary.
Now I'm gonna go downstairs.
Fuck this.
I wanna know what's downstairs in the creepy fucking ghost
room.
What is in the ghost room?
Where am I?
What the fuck is this room?
What the fuck?
Oh my god, it's just a pit.
Oh,
I need the soap power-up for this.
I don't have soap.
That's been invented yet.
Yeah, I need the bubble ability.
There's more abilities?
How is there more?
I thought I got all the inventions
I thought the bubble the bubble gum was the soap ability I
was like oh maybe I got confused about what soap meant I
literally was like did I like just not know what soap is
like
yeah I got I got a little confused I was like wait that's oh
what
oh no One more key.
Oh my god.
Okay, it's fine.
I just want to grab that key.
Okay, before I go that way, I want to know what the secret
passage is.
Ooh.
Back to the secret, but we weren't.
You cannot return the way after dropping down.
Guys, there's the ghost are haunting me.
What the fuck?
The ghost are capped.
Big B!
They're like, when she gets out of the instructions
tutorial, we're gonna get it.
We're gonna get it.
Whoa!
This is fucked up.
They're actually spawn camping.
They came to the wrong name.
neighborhood oh my god shaggy please shaggy please oh okay
goodbye shaggy how am I supposed to save you
oh my god what the fuck am I supposed to do he has a gun oh
my god oh my god oh my okay that's fine that was a little
bullshit but that's fine Wait, the gate's closed.
It opened?
Oh, I have to press all of them.
Jesus Christ, the moment when they spawn in, it's like
fucking freaks me up.
I just never expect it.
Okay.
It just like pop up.
Is it three buttons?
are there?
Oh my god, it's four.
I just can't count.
I'm gonna go straight in.
Jesus Christ, okay.
Of course the ghost haunts the goddamn laundry room.
What else would ghosts do?
Oh, yay!
L2 to trap and soap bubble and then jump on top of it.
Wait, that's convenient.
Oh, sorry.
The washing machine was haunted.
Are you fucking kidding me?
Apparently, the God...
Oh, oh, it's here!
Oh my God, I got everything.
I finally got it all.
Okay.
Now!
I should...
be able to use the secret passage i got the last one
wait where okay i have to go backwards all right we're
breaching
oh my god i'm gonna fucking tank this right there you go i
got burger too Okay, there we go.
Backtrack, baby.
It's time for the secret lab.
Yeah, me too.
I looked up how long is this game?
And I legitimately thought it was not...
They said it would be four hours.
How do I...
Alright.
Okay.
Okay, it's fine.
All right, we got so.
Okay.
Oh, my God.
Okay, I got one of them.
I made it.
Oh, my.
Okay.
Okay, I had to, like, trust the process for that.
I had to trust the process.
I swear to God, if I have another cookie shit thing right
here, I swear to fucking God.
Our electric floors.
Oh my god.
MP1 with the rock roll floor.
I'll grab the scooby snack while I'm here.
I swear to God, if I see 900 cookies, oh my God, I swear to
fucking God, if I see the, if I see the Scooby snack gate,
oh my God, I thought this would be a four-hour game.
There you go.
Where the fuck do I go?
Oh, it's here.
Oh, how long to be said seven hours?
I'm still on track.
I was doing the video.
I didn't do the Google part this time.
Usually I would Google it, but I was just like, I'll just
look at the YouTube video because an adult is playing it.
But silly me, that adult knows what the fuck is going on.
I don't.
Because I was like, okay, this is a kid's game.
So like, I need the most accurate representation if I watch
an adult try and figure this out.
How?
Oh my god, the table is electrified too.
Oh my god, the table was...
Oh, okay.
I didn't think the table was also gonna be electric.
Like, who the fuck makes the table have electricity?
Oh my god, let's do this again.
I thought table was safe.
Oh, whoa, whoa, look at that speedrun tech right there.
All right.
Yeah, I was like, is that not a wooden table in front of me?
Where the fuck do I go?
Do I have to backtrack all the way back there?
All right, where does it go?
Oh my god, it's at the entrance.
It's all the way back at the entrance.
I hope I see the goddamn hospital bed.
Okay, there we go.
I was gonna say, I hope I see the fucking hospital bed when
I...
I hope I'll be able to see the hospital bed when I jump to
the other side.
Thank God, okay.
I was gonna be very, very mad.
No way.
Okay, okay.
Is it salvageable?
It's salvageable.
I just got...
Okay.
Okay, okay.
Okay, okay, that's that was scary.
That was very scary guys.
That it was scary.
I can't believe it There I can't see anything because I
can't move!
I can't move the camera
Oh my god, you guys don't understand the camera is immovable
Oh my god, there was a button over there.
I didn't even see those buttons.
There's no way.
There's that button over there.
Oh my god, there's the fucking thing over there too.
Oh my god, it's the boxes.
okay now that's everything that's everything now
come on scooby we gotta let you gotta do this for a scooby
snack right now
i couldn't find the hospital bed the hospital bed why did
the hospital bed did it no you guys don't understand see no
hospital bed I saw no hospital bed behind me because the
camera angle is fixed chat the goddamn fixed camera angles
okay okay we gotta be able to hit the hospital bed to our
left too oh my god please please stop laughing at me
why is it not synced up oh my god this oh my god this camera
angle oh my god what the fuck am i looking at this camera
angle what the fuck is that okay all
right here we go again
look at that look at that look did you see those chairs Did
you see?
Did you see how unsinked they are?
Did you say, did you see that?
Where?
Where did the chair go?
Oh my god.
They're actually fully unsinked.
Okay.
We got a lock-in for this.
I'm just gonna wait for the pattern.
Oh my.
This is...
This is torture.
Holy fuck.
Fuck.
What the fuck?
Why did it go away so?
this.
What is that?
What?
That was actually so cruel.
No way.
At least she didn't die, guys.
This is actually torture.
This is parkour.
I think the fact that they're not synced up is like they're
so like off-sync it fucks with me so much like even when
they're stopping too I think the worst part is that when
they're stopping is the timing is so fucking weird will you
jump where the beef or the chicken like like what are some
of the what is that okay like what is that okay like it goes
what it stops there for a while but when it comes back
that's fucked up oh
my god oh my god okay I could I should have just floated
stop stop this stop
Okay.
Okay, we're done.
Let's stop this at once.
Whoa, run, Scooby.
Run.
Oh my god, it's him.
It's the cyborg.
Oh, I'm glad it did not crash.
No, I thought so too.
I felt it.
I was like, please tell me it's okay.
Oh, okay.
Cool.
That's okay.
Um, I jump.
Oh, shit.
Oh, my god.
Wait.
No!
Can I not kill these guys?
Okay, it's not activated.
Okay.
Nice.
A freebie.
Yay!
It didn't activate, guys!
It bugged out!
Let's go!
Oh, there, never mind.
I'm just gonna kill you straight up.
Okay.
We go this way.
Ooh, snacks.
No, we don't need it.
Alright.
Up we go.
What the fuck?
What?
What the?
Oh, it goes higher?
Okay, that's cool.
That's cool.
Guys, can you stop lasering?
I gotta...
No, oh, that's fine.
Okay, that's fine.
Oh, wait, I stopped here.
Oh, my God.
Is that not?
Wait, they're unbounceable.
Wait.
These guys are actually unbounceable.
Oh.
Oh my god, it's fully glitched!
Let's go!
If I...
Oh, never mind.
I thought I figured it out, guys.
I thought I was so clever.
I thought I figured it out.
Here.
I hit this one.
Is that all?
There we go.
Okay, I slowly go up.
Okay.
i don't like that they're unkillable it makes me very
uncomfortable
all right here we go all right door is locked
all right bubble gum time oh it's the mister whatever his
name is oh shit maybe he has a Nope, it's just gum.
Just gum.
I should have to go use this platform so I can get this
button and not press that button.
And then the door opens.
Alright.
And up I'll go.
What's he gonna do here, huh?
Oh.
Alright.
Where the fuck?
I made the bad jump in I made I made the wrong jump I made
the wrong jump oh my god here we go again beam me up oh my
not you it's like I heard beam
Okay, they don't know if I stand here, they won't know.
I don't...
Where are you?
All right.
Where the fuck do I go then?
What?
Where?
Okay, okay.
Is that...
Oh my god, it's over there.
I see it.
Oh my god, it was here.
It's a warp gate.
Oh my god.
Are you...
No!
Okay.
I've never felt pure anguish before.
I've never felt pure anguish until today.
The economy is in shambles right now.
Oh, man.
800.
Not even 800.
The fact that it's 850, they had to add the end.
extra 50 just to fuck with me just get me
okay okay there's oh do you guys see that how did i miss
that okay we got one that that's good that's that's a good
amount that's a good amount right there
oh my god there's okay five four hundred ninety seven oh my
god get me get me out of here get me out of here get me one
more time here all right all right back there there were a
ton of Scooby snacks okay there was a ton I remember that I
left this silly meat I thought it was over I thought I
thought it ended.
Okay, I think I could grab a hundred more, right?
Just from this area.
That's so silly of me.
How foolish.
It's never over.
I'm so...
You're so silly dokey.
It's never over.
Oh my god, look at all those scooby snacks.
That's just...
That's just lying.
there oh
okay it's okay it's okay that they see me it's okay if it
means i can grab a couple of more scooby snacks if they see
me that's good okay get me right here okay
oh i got it all right We just get beamed.
Just beam.
Beam me.
Just beam it.
Actually, no.
I think there's one more over there.
Wait, let me just go over there.
I think there's more behind me.
The end is never.
I thought that was the last one.
I didn't know.
There'd be more.
There'd be so...
much more.
Alright.
Me too, Scooby.
Me too.
Okay.
How the fuck is there?
Okay, here.
Okay, back here.
I was thinking for the raid, girl.
We had a great stream.
Thank you, thank you.
yo okay maybe maybe there's maybe there's hope i'm blowing
bubble gum
they're trying to shoot me with a gun but i'm making it okay
oh please please leave me please please leave me alone
okay that's fine we're almost at 600 and Hold up.
It's okay.
We're at 600, guys.
We're at 600.
We're gonna make it a 600.
Right?
That's three more.
Three more right there.
I don't need 300.
I'm worried about going to go.
Okay.
That's okay.
Oh my god, it's here.
It's here.
Surely there's some easy ones, right?
That I left?
Wait, I know.
Guys, I know.
I remember, guys.
Oh my god, I need to find the warp.
Where's the warp play?
Guys, I remember There is one area Right here I'll go here
Watch this, guys I remember There is one place It's the
laundry mat The laundry mat has us something
Okay, he's like right here
There were a bunch of school There will be snacks there.
Wait, is this a laundromat?
Where is this?
Where am I?
Okay, I...
Oh my god.
And now I fly up from here?
Don't worry, I'm gonna make it.
I'm gonna...
I'm gonna make it.
I'm gonna get there.
Oh, hey.
There's a cookie here, though.
There's a Scooby Snack.
Is it here?
Oh, yeah, it is.
Okay.
I wish there was a mod.
That removes, like, half of these.
Right?
Oh, my God, please.
Oh, my God.
Get over here.
I can't.
Oh, my!
Okay, I got it.
I got the Scooby Snacks.
Where is this?
This open, though.
Oh, my God.
Please.
Get back in there.
I'm not done with you.
That plus five is so...
Okay, there we go.
You don't understand.
That plus five adds up.
Okay, there's 50 here.
I'm losing it.
I thought I saw the light.
But I was wrong.
It was no light.
Someone just left their iPhone on.
In the middle of the hallway.
There was no light.
Right here.
I need to lead one of them here.
Oh my god.
God damn stupid ghost.
It's fine.
I just need a ghost to come over here.
Come on.
Okay, well, that's not it.
Don't worry, I'll get unstuck.
There we go.
There we go, that's fine.
And then there was something at the bottom, right?
I know I left some Scooby Snacks in the bottom.
There we go.
That one Scooby Snack.
And then there was something over here.
Wait, what?
How the fuck do I get this?
Oh, here you go.
Oh, there we go.
That's a token.
Oh, my...
Oh, it's just that.
Okay.
The monster token should give me, like, plus 100.
100 Scooby snacks.
They're so rare.
They're so rare, I should get 100 Scooby snacks for that.
The hunt continues for more Scooby Snacks.
Alright.
It's okay.
No.
Oh my god.
We did it.
No!
Oh!
Okay, we did it.
580!
We're home.
All right, I can die here.
All right, this is five.
All right, how many?
Okay.
So what I need to do is bubble this guy.
Jump on him.
And then grab the scooby snack.
All right.
Not a lot.
I don't know where to find the rest of the missing Scooby
Snacks here.
But we're going to figure this out.
Where's the warp zone?
Oh my god, there's no warp zone near me.
There's no warp zone near me.
Oh, I almost got rid of my favorite save file.
Okay.
Map time.
Behind me is a warp zone.
Okay.
It's back here.
We're back here.
We're back in the dungeons.
Alright.
It's time.
It's time to figure this out, guys.
all right 190 this 269 that is a lot okay I'm going to find
the one with the most
okay we got we'll go backwards the maze
backwards we go backwards That's a full hundred scoopy
snacks right there.
Alright.
We go backwards.
This is it.
Wait, is it?
Wait, is there any in the front that I missed out on?
God, it's just all bubble gum now.
I'm gonna do it.
double check down here to be sure.
Okay, yeah, it's all backwards.
I gotta finish the goddamn maze.
Oh my god.
I gotta do it.
Guys, how many Scooby Snacks am I missing, guys?
What's the verdict?
Oh my god.
How do I...
Wait, how do I even get there?
Okay.
270.
It's not as bad.
Okay, it's fine.
It's fine.
Oh my god.
Please.
Oh my god, please for the love of God.
Okay, I need you to get closer.
I missed.
There you go.
Things I do for Scooby-Stacks.
The things I do for Scooby-Stacks.
Goodbye.
Where is the fuck?
Fucking chandelier!
Okay.
Alright.
Why can't I grasp it?
Why won't it fully grasp it?
Oh my god.
Okay.
I fully grasped it.
I did it.
Oh my god.
Oh, there's more over here.
Oh, thank God.
Okay, it's fine.
All right.
Oh, my God.
A fucking curse.
I missed those two.
It's okay.
It'll be fine.
Life will move on.
Life will move on, guys.
Oh my god.
I just literally went backwards.
Is it?
They don't add up now.
Right now it's fine.
It doesn't add up now.
It'll be fine.
Please be a scoopy snack.
Oh, it's never a scoopy snack.
It's never a scoopy snack.
Oh my god, it's fine.
No, don't say that.
Don't say that.
Please, there's no way there.
We're at endgame.
There's no way.
Chat.
What the fuck?
Oh my god, do I have to reset the fucking?
Oh my god, okay.
I have to reset the werewolf.
I gotta reset the- Kill me.
Get the bubbles, get me.
I have to reset the werewolf.
The stupid fucking thorns.
I'm running.
right like i don't understand oh god i'm so scared now
like what there's so many snacks back there it's it's
calling me oh my god i swear to god if it's like all the way
back there
all the snacks they said they're calling telling me be like,
Toki, where are you?
We're waiting for you, Toki.
Oh no, where's the robbing?
Oh, thank God.
It's right here.
Right.
Okay, we're slam dunking this.
As long as the bats do not bother me, I will not bother the
bats.
Oh my God.
Almost fell off that tree.
okay all right how much left oh my god we got so far okay
109 and 143 okay we gotta go back we gotta keep going back
the hedge maze the hedge maze will lead us to the promised
land
the promised land
Oh my god, I'm gonna save just in case.
Just in case I crash
Oh a hundred and seven.
Oh my god.
It does it I felt I thought I made so much progress and then
I see a hundred and seventy I was just thinking like oh my
god, guys look I got so many snacks clearly I'm getting
closer
Surely, surely I'm making it.
The one Scooby Snack I left up.
Okay.
All right.
Back we go.
Oh, yeah, I can't backtrack back there.
But that's okay.
okay and then there's 60 here
okay the graveyard there's a lot of them missing i don't
know how the fuck we're gonna grab those but like i have i'm
just gonna hope for the best all right there's one there's
one
wait there might be oh no secret tunnel i think i've been in
the secret oh wait wait no no i have not i have not been in
the secret tunnel what the fuck
all right oh my god i thought i was gonna miss that jump
please don't okay thank god
oh there's a scooby snack i forgot i decided not all snacks
collected.
I've actually collected everything here.
I've, like, fucking sucked it dry.
I've harvested the land and left.
I harvested this land of all this natural resources.
Alright, save.
Okay.
135.
I feel so.
Why does it feel like a lot?
Alright, Shaggy's not coming.
back okay um 312 all right let's try to find a lot 102 and
200 all right the graveyard what do you mean i've never
activated the warp gate for that area
how was that warp gate never activated Oh my god.
Oh, it's because I never fucking turn on the button.
I remember.
The button was never on.
Okay.
Where is this place?
Oh my god, this area.
I know this.
I got the bubbles.
I have the bubble.
Bubble power
Okay Oh, whoa, whoa How the fuck how did I
how did I do this?
Okay,
oh my god how the fuck I made the jump one time I I made the
jump one time never again I
Okay, there you go.
There you go.
I fixed it.
It's okay.
It's been fixed.
All right.
Every path is intended.
Oh!
It's just super buggy.
Oh my god, there it is.
It must be the button.
The button is here somewhere.
But in this here, I can feel it.
Okay, I can...
Okay, cannot miss.
Okay, and now what?
What the...
Okay, now what does he want me to do?
I assume I swing this way?
Are you fucking kidding me?
Okay, float over to the witch.
I assume that's what I have to do then.
Okay, but what if I just...
Can I blow up Bubba?
Okay, fuck this.
Goodbye.
It's okay.
I'd rather just die so I don't have to worry about...
having to travel back.
Okay, that's fine.
That still hits me!
Okay, no, no, no, no.
We can do this.
Rummy.
Where are I?
Ooh,
okay.
I just float.
I got the umbrella.
all right we open this door and then there should be more
scooby snacks because i have no idea where i am oh hey i can
get out here
oh my god it's here okay we've been here before
okay it is promising this is promising we were able to go
here before because there was a Fucking...
We don't have the umbrella?
I don't know which urns I can break.
Is it the blue ones?
Oh, it was the blue ones.
Oh, there's a secret zombie passage here?
Like downstairs?
They're not getting.
Like here?
Oh, I see it.
God damn it, you didn't...
You would have thought they would give me, like, Scooby
Snacks, guys.
Oh, yeah.
Yeah.
Okay, never mind.
There was one.
I left one.
It's okay.
I left one Scooby Snack.
All right, let's go back in.
Thank God I never bought the goddamn...
What was it?
The fucking Monster Gallery Shit Oh my god Nice there was a
Scooby Snack in there I had a feeling
Yeah I never Figure out how to activate this There was no
buttons I saw no fucking buttons for this one
Chandelier There's a button that opens up the coffin This
In the stone casket?
There was a casket near me?
To the left?
I fly.
I thought on purpose so I could figure out where to fuck the
fly.
I'm flying.
Oh, there it is.
Oh!
It was just a ghost.
There you go.
Oh my god, that's a lot more.
That's some more Scooby Snacks.
Oh my god, that's some more juicy Scooby Snacks right there.
God damn it, the magnifying glass almost fucked me over.
I got scared looking at it.
Okay.
Oh, we made it.
Alright.
How much more do we have?
Okay, 269 ago.
Oh my god, you see a tunnel.
I can see the light.
I can actually see the light at the end of this tunnel.
Oh my god, it actually exists.
Okay.
Oh my god, what?
Wait.
wait a minute why is this saying oh my god
a hundred and ninety five out of three hundred and eighty
six why was i not there why was i not there okay we got it
okay let's figure out it okay that's not where i have to go
i'm trying to Where the fuck is the...
How is the warp this?
That's toky.
Why did you not stop me?
Why did you not do it?
That's toky.
Why is there 100...
200 scooby snacks in that world?
That toky really said fuck that place in particular.
Rono!
Where's the robbing?
Okay.
Okay, we can...
Where the fuck?
Okay, this is where it should be.
Alright.
Okay, we figured out where to go now.
I'll go here and go backwards.
Oh my god, it's this place.
Oh my... I remember why now.
it was this place in particular okay now i realize why no
it's understandable that's sticky no i get it no this place
fucking suck no i get it this place is ridiculous it fucking
suck we
Oh my god, you bitch.
Alright, I hate that it gives me soap now.
Not food.
I have too many items.
Okay, that's a lot of scrooby snacks though right there.
Okay, now I can make this jump.
Well, I'll kill this first.
Okay.
Oh my god.
20.
I see the light.
There's a light!
Guys!
Guys, I see the light.
It's actually possible.
Guys, guys.
It's actually possible, guys.
There is light at the end.
20 more.
The end of the tunnel.
I think I saw it.
Oh my god.
I'm thinking about 50 gifted ships.
Thank you.
I really appreciate it.
Holy shit.
That is so much.
Thank you so much.
That's a big amount of support.
I really appreciate it.
Thank you.
Oh my god.
This is it.
38.
Oh my god.
11 more.
It's like, this is my new year's countdown, guys.
This is...
That's a huge amount of Scooby Snacks.
Nine.
Eight.
Six.
Four.
Oh my god.
Please worry.
Please don't do this to me.
Oh my god.
Two.
One.
Happy New Year.
we did oh my god new year came early guys new year we did it
we did it gang
okay 8 50.
we have a root 50 i repeat all right secret tunnel super
secret i was here There you go.
There you go.
Oh my god.
Happy New Year.
Exactly.
Bro, bro, bro.
Bro, why are you?
Okay, why are you capping me?
Oh my There's a shark?
Look at all of these scooby snack.
for my legs pal there's no way there's no way there's
another one there's no way there's another i refuse him i'm
not you know i'm so confident there's not another one i'm
not picking it up that's how confident i am i'm
so confident there's no way there's no way there's enough oh
my god what happened to the shark get rid of that water pal
There's no way.
There's no way, guys.
Not only did I kill all those people, I even killed a shark.
Fuck that one, shark.
Like, this shark just fucking got evaporated.
Oh, I'm thinking that for another...
Wait, did he do another 50 gift?
Oh, my God, thank you for another 50.
I really appreciate it.
It's to celebrate the new year, guys.
Happy new year.
all right get out okay okay um are we trapped in here shaggy
shaggy dog
oh okay okay he made it out he made it out he made it out he
made it out it's gonna be like if i my soft block is i did
not save okay okay i'll follow him.
I was gonna be like, oh no, was I not supposed to jump down
there?
Raggy, any moment now, Raggy, Raggy, come on, Raggy, come
on, Raggy, come on, Raggy, come on, okay, that's fine, I'll
be fucking heading out, goodbye, Raggy.
Oh, please tell me there's a van here.
Raggy!
Hi, welcome to Tomato Farm 2!
Welcome, welcome!
Hey, Scooby!
Hey, pal.
What am I?
Chopped liver?
Okay.
Okay, Raggy.
We've seen... We've been... We literally just saw each
other, like, five seconds ago.
What the fuck?
Rashing?
Come on, Scooby.
You can do it.
We're almost at the end of this mystery.
And I've got a plan.
His Daphne 2 is my original character.
Go?
That's my original character.
Daphne 2.
Oh my god.
Okay, at least I can save.
Like, what am I looking at?
What am I looking at?
Okay, the final platforming.
Oh my god, I just instant, I instant that.
There's no second chances for Scooby-Doo.
Yeah, I'm just gonna float right over it.
Yeah, hello
I'm not attempting that second jump Yeah The acid in those
vats is used for etching.
It was used to make those funky lenses that were in my
glasses This must be part of the professor's top-secret
invention Jinkies and now I know just what it is the
professor was making super for real holograms.
Those, no, no, no.
There is no way that's a hologram.
Oh my God, that's how, bro, this was before the two-pack
hologram, guys.
That's crazy.
This was before two-pack.
Super there's no way those were holograms.
That's right, Scooby.
No ghosts.
Now listen up, gang.
We literally saw them lift Shaggy up.
Who the fuck was carrying Shaggy.
And that will buy us all the time we need to turn the tables
on old fright face.
Oh my god, her name was Holly Graham.
Oh my god.
My original OC.
Holly Graham.
Oh.
How about a whole box of Scooby snacks?
A whole box.
That better be 900.
That better be 900 Scooby snacks, guys.
Right.
Oh my god, I'm thinking again for another 50 gifted!
Holy shit, thank you, bro.
I really appreciate that.
That's such a insane amount of support.
Thank you so much.
I really, really appreciate it, man.
Thank you, dude.
Alright.
We're in here.
That's a hologram, too.
Mastermind.
The plan is working perfectly.
All that remains is...
What?
Impossible.
How did you...
worthless girl this far i don't know i don't like it for a
box of koopy shacks as well as all nine of your lives i
think that's cats i'm not i knew it i knew it was i knew it
was daphne too it was so obvious i didn't even realize her
name was hologram also how if they were holograms how Was
there a witch carrying shaggy up into those chimneys?
Oh, it's Tim Curry.
If you guys are like he sounds familiar.
I'm trying to figure out what to do, bro.
Okay, are you guys gonna, are you guys gonna, are you guys
gonna, are you guys gonna help?
Guys, if they're holograms, why do they still hurt?
Gang, I thought you said they were holograms.
Why does it still hurt me?
Rump, roll.
I don't know how to kill these guys.
Oh, my God.
I'm trying to blow bubbles.
Oh, helmet and slam.
Oh, these guys can be helmeted.
Oh, my God.
I've been trying to figure out what the fuck how to slam
these guys okay that's good all right thanks for telling me
oh my god another 50 gifted thank you oh my god what thank
you for another 50 gifted thank you thank you oh my god it's
like 200 oh my god keep fucking up thank you i really really
appreciate it all the insane support
Excuse me.
I'm just trying to...
Oh my god.
Alright, we got one button.
Two.
There you go.
Alright.
Okay.
There you go.
We got food for once.
Alright, nice.
Okay.
Nice!
Got it!
Oh god, oh god, oh.
This is a lot harder now.
Okay, we're just gonna...
We're gonna get the skellies out first.
The skellies are easier.
The robot did the robot.
I don't know you saw that.
Alright.
all right third light like every boss fight back in the
early 2000s is three hits three hits and then win
all right here we go
oh my god wait what the fuck what the fuck oh my god
Okay, it's fine.
Are you serious?
Oh my god, are you...
Okay, there we go.
No!
Wait, does it drop down?
Oh my god, it starts from the beginning.
It starts from the beginning!
Okay, okay, okay, I...
Alright.
Oh my god, I thought, like, I didn't realize it starts all
the way from the beginning.
Okay.
I fucked up I fucked up I thought I thought phase two I
don't know oh my god Keith I thought phase two phase two
would be different at least he does the robot afterwards
okay we do this a lot faster now they really just leave the
dog to deal with the criminal I know right so fuck okay it's
fine oh my god I'm trying to get rid of the skellies first
all right we got one of them oh my god okay what the okay
that's not fair that's a actually not fair they're blocking
me are you serious what the fuck okay okay it's fine it's
okay it's okay they respawn they actually respawn wait
that's not fair okay as long as the other guy doesn't
respawn
Okay, okay.
Okay, that's fine.
That's fine.
Okay.
It's just animal cruelty right now.
It truly is.
It really is.
Ooh.
Oh my god, he doesn't get stunned.
No, no, stop.
Stop.
This is not fair.
Please!
Oh, Scooby.
Oh,
my god.
What?
Are you fucking?
Okay.
Oh, my god.
This is actually bullshit.
Bullshit
Okay, I got burger though.
Oh my god.
Oh my god wait what?
I was supposed to press the button.
Was I supposed to press the button?
I can't tell
Oh no
Okay Okay,
okay, okay, come on come on No, no,
it's just taking they go They spawn so fast
Oh my god
I Don't understand the final play do I press the button?
Okay,
oh my god, I hate these guys.
I how did I hit me?
Oh, I hit the mastermind into electricity Wait, is that
true?
I have to target the slam them bash okay slam them bash okay
what okay oh my god leave me alone
oh my god fuck
oh my god keep you keep you keep you get me out of here okay
okay that's a lot of food
Okay, all right.
Slam them bash.
Okay, I get it.
Bro, take a gift, and then give the chips.
Take a thing.
There's light under the tunnel.
There's light in the tunnel.
I'm figuring it out.
Yeah, this is the season.
Slam them bash.
There we go.
I get it.
Okay, I get it now, though.
Oh, my God.
I'm fucking okay.
I mean.
What?
Okay, I tried to use the bubble, but it wouldn't let me.
No!
No, I ran into him!
No,
I ran into him.
Bro, these guys spawned so fast.
fast after i kill them it's not worth killing them i've
noticed it's not worth killing this these guys because it's
like they just spawn back like in two seconds and they just
have to kill them for like loot like just of course he
spawns into me oh my god fucking worse
to see all the food you can get
Okay.
This last one is so difficult.
I am a...
Okay, I didn't mean to do that.
Okay, this guy gets out first.
And then...
Okay.
There we go.
Okay, we have to make sure the skellies don't spam.
All right.
All right, here we go.
I think it's easier to get more scooby snacks.
Please, please no more.
I don't want to watch.
I can't believe I can't skip the cutscene too.
Good morning from Germany.
Seems like we met again before the VOD.
Good luck, Doki.
Thank you again.
Thank you.
Super chat.
Thank you, stay there.
Okay.
We got this.
Are you...
Okay, that's not fair.
Guys, he's...
What?
What hit me?
Boogie.
Scooby Doo.
Yes!
Oh my god.
It was just that easy.
Oh my god There we go
Oh my god I just needed one more hit Look gang There he is
Whoa Whoa Wow it's time to get to the bottom of this mystery
Come on gang Let's see who the mastermind really is Wait
Fred Like I think I know who this guy It's that spooky
groundskeeper, right?
It's always the groundskeeper.
Oh yeah, that's right.
Blame the spooky groundskeeper.
It's always the spooky groundskeeper.
Bro, he's just chilling.
He gave us free shit.
What do people have against groundskeepers?
Some detectives.
Why don't you just say the butler do it?
But no, it's always got to be the groundskeeper, don't it?
Yeah.
Anytime some ghost scares somebody.
That's ground sis!
It's just got to be the groundskeeper.
Like we couldn't just put up a sign that says keep off the
grass.
Nah, I'll just get myself a big old rubber monster suit.
Um, as I was saying, let's see who the mastermind really is.
It's Professor Alexander Graham!
It's Alexander Graham!
Oh my.
Uncle Alexander.
not holly leave it i knew it all the time it's not holly
grab just doesn't add up yeah you ask me someone's playing a
nasty trick a trick of the i knew it holly graham i knew it
wow that was just another hologram holly what are you doing
there zoinks but holly's right what they never try to True?
Wrong, Shecky.
That Holly was just another hologram.
The real Holly has been the mastermind the entire time.
I knew it.
I fucking knew it.
Think about the clues.
I call it.
Holly said she followed all of our cases.
But they respect women.
When the fuck does that happen?
By setting up a hologram of herself when the mastermind was
around she'd have the perfect alibi but what I don't get is
how she got the professor here in a mastermind costume no
less well that's simple she used my patent-pending dressed
for supper suck you up her I spent so much time in the lab
that I built a device that could get me dressed and to the
front door in seconds it actually happened in the cutscene
that's crazy that is actually Nice foreshadowing.
Holly must have used it to get here ahead of us and switch
places with her uncle.
Who she'd already stopped up there.
It was very uncomfortable, let me tell you.
Like and don't forget the most important clue of all.
Holly Graham!
Get it?
Holla Graham!
Yeah!
But why, Holly?
Yeah, why?
Why go through all of this?
You guys would have caught my uncle and when he was sent to
jail I'd steal his super hologram invention and claim I came
up with it myself.
I would have made a fortune too Yeah, what was it for you
meddling kids?
Yeah, and I would have gotten away with it too.
See the thing Whoa She said the thing Let me help you.
Oh, thank you kids.
I don't know how to repay you Well, all these middles are a
great start.
Hey!
We're not eating a foods hologram?
Scooby-Doby-Doo.
Yeah.
She said it.
Yeah, she's like their age.
You can't say that.
What is...
What?
What is this?
What is this remix?
Bro, am I?
What is this?
Electronic remix.
This was before dead mouse time.
Yeah, this is techno shit.
Yeah.
I'm at the club now.
Going to the club after solving the mystery.
It's time for the rave.
After a good mystery case.
Sorry.
Oh, case closed.
Bring the dog to the grave.
Bum.
Bum, bum, bum, bum.
EDM Scooby-Doo.
Yeah, the squirrel legs.
I was like thinking that.
I was like, I have squirrel legs are dead now.
This feels so like squirrel legs right now.
Bum, bum, bum, bum, bum, bum, bum.
That was fun.
That was a nice revisit challenge.
I forgot back then, like, because a lot of these games where
collectathons and, like, platformers, they made you force
you to collect so much.
Yeah.
That was just, I, that's why, that's why Little Jokey never
finished this game.
She was stuck.
She did not collect the Scooby Snacks.
I finally beat it for little dokey right now they could get
for their 10 gift of chips they could thank you oh it was
fun though I felt like it was very well written like it felt
like a Scooby-Doo episode that's why I always want I want to
play this Futurama game too because everyone says the
Futurama game is also really good and it's like a Futurama
episode same with Simpsons I want to play the Simpsons game
as well the one with the the one where you go to heaven and
then uh and I know the plot twist because I did play it
before.
I did play the Simpsons game.
It was really fun.
I remembered when I played it when I was little.
I really want to do the PS2 Futurama and the Simpsons game
where you go to the Simpsons fight heaven.
We did do Hit and Run.
Hit and Run was a game I never played before.
That's what I really wanted to check it out.
It was like, it was in 2007 Simpsons.
That game was really fun too.
See, thank you, but super chat.
Thank you, thank you.
Uh, I don't blame Lil Doki for not being in this game.
Big Doki had enough trouble with it.
Yeah, yeah, like present Doki was struggling hard with the
platforms.
Uh, bro, thank you, the super chat.
Thank you, thank you.
Uh, congrats on the clear Doki.
Little Doki, we brought.
Thank you, thank you, the super chat.
Thank you, thank you.
I don't know what the other Scooby-Doo games.
I just remembered this one because, uh, Lil Doki struggled
hard.
during this also this house was is not that big i still
don't understand how this house this mansion expanded with
it um how this mansion expanded in in general all right how
much is this yeah no yeah yeah yeah no we're not guys we are
not going there Oh my god.
We had a great time.
It was great going through the memory lane trying to
finishing this game.
There's a cheat code to unlock it.
What's the cheat code?
Yes.
How to unlock with cheat code now.
How do we unlock it with a cheat code?
Where is it?
Say the cheat code.
Boobies.
okay up down left right left right what the fuck is b a up
up pp okay there is no b8 here up up down down oh that's the
konami code oh my god that's the konami code okay that makes
sense i was like there's no B here.
Okay, hold.
Hold left and right?
Like, L3?
Or...
Or, wait, what's L...
What's...
Okay.
X, X, B, B, X.
Wait.
Which one's...
My controller has no...
I need to look up PS5 controller real quick.
Hey, which one's B and which one's on the pause menu?
X, X.
Wait, which one's X?
Okay, that's X.
Hold left one.
L2.
Press square, square, square, circle, circle, circle,
square.
Square, circle, square.
That is it.
it okay l1 square circle circle square circle square oh
square circle square right square circle circle square
circle square wait is that the circle is the right one right
what okay wait okay
wait square square square circle circle circle square oh
wait wait oh yeah square square square circle circle circle
circle circle the that okay
guys it's not working it's not okay one two three one two
three one two three square is the left one and circles the
right yeah
i don't have the symbols on my controller by the way
Wahee!
Excuse me.
What the fuck?
It gave me a Wahee.
I saw it.
Okay.
No, I have the PlayStation 5 controller.
Oh, use the warp gate.
Okay, I was like, Wahee.
Okay, he Waheeed me.
Okay.
Oh, warp gate to despawn it.
Okay, I'm going...
I'm going inside.
What?
And then I go out back in.
And maybe it's gone now.
It is not gone.
Oh my god.
The hack was a lie.
The hack was a...
the cheat was a lie it was lie it lied to me okay okay wait
wait wait wait it doesn't work because that because if I
press X it cancels it okay wait yeah it doesn't work because
it cancels it if I do it because X is the cancer but unless
I No, it doesn't.
Someone gave me a...
Nah, it doesn't work.
Okay, he gave me a Wahi.
He gave me a Wahi.
I got a Wahi.
Where does...
Okay, guys, I don't think it works.
It's too late.
All right.
He gave me a Wahi.
That's it.
They patched it.
In 2025, Scooby-Doo, 100 Frights, released a patch of after
20 plus years.
After 20 plus years, they've released a patch to get rid of
all Chico's.
They nerfed Wahi.
Anyway, I turned the link.
Welcome to tomato farm.
Welcome, welcome.
That was fun.
I still had a really fun time playing it.
Guys, I don't think it works, guys.
No matter where we warp, it ain't gonna take us in.
If they release the patches to prevent me, they wanted me to
gather more Scooby snacks.
But I refuse.
I refuse to gather more Scooby snacks.
I'm done.
Anyway, guys, I'm gonna call here.
I hope you all had a wonderful time watching.
I hope you had, um, how you guys enjoyed my company today.
We did stream a very long time.
Um, and, uh, I had so much fun playing it.
Going back to the nostalgia games and going back from my
childhood.
Uh, introducing you guys to the guys to the one of the games
I used to play growing up.
Uh, Pencil, thank you for the super chat.
Thank you.
I looked up, Tommy worked on this game as the music
composer.
He's the guy who tried to claim he made the way.
Really?
Oh my god, that's awkward.
Bro, okay, but he did make, didn't he make, actually make
the original Oof sound effect?
And he just wanted to be paid in like royalties for it or
some shit.
Um, but like, hey, the music was pretty good, despite him
taking away Oof in Roblox.
Anyway, guys, as always everybody, oh, he wasn't?
Okay, I didn't really know the full story.
I thought like, I just, I remember seeing the tweets about
it, but I didn't know the full story regarding the Oof.
He didn't?
He says a lot of things.
Tommy says a lot of things.
I don't know, Tommy.
I just saw, like, the tweets about it.
Oh, one of his employees made it.
Oh, he tried.
Oh, he's like Thomas Edison.
That's why his name is Tommy.
Thomas, my Edison, my Edison, my hero.
Yeah, that is a big oof.
Anyway, guys, as always, everybody, say hi, J-LiPotrists,
Posh Check.
Get him moving around and get that blood flowing.
And if you, except for me, head to bed, cause you deserve
it.
I'll see you guys next time, everybody.
Bye.
guys bye we're so close to 900 000 oh my god thank you
everybody for subscribing and all the support everyone i
really appreciate it we're getting closer anyway guys i'm
gonna head off now bye everyone bye